Hey everyone Diavolo here and today we are
diving into another absolutely BRUTAL yet
visually BEAUTIFUL manga called Jigokuraku
or Hells Paradise that takes place during
the Edo period in a world much the same as
our own.
Throughout the first of these 4 arcs we dive
into the workings of this cruel Naruto esc
Japanese world, were we follow the story of
a vicious assassin named Gabimaru and
his journey in order to gain freedom…
This story is absolutely dope, its themes
are top tier, its art is visually the most
stunning of the dark trio and I’ve had so
much more fun that expected unravelling just
how fine tuned it truly is . Jigokuraku is
effectively a blend of 2 Japanese words “Jigoku”
and “Gokuraku”, Heaven and Hell.
The whole idea of Good and Evil plays out
in so many different ways that really just
leave you there thinking, re reading wanting
to understand the underlying message that's
being told.
So without further ado push this video to
5k likes and subscribe so I know you want
to see the rest of this series.
Either way, sit back and relax as we dive
into the 1st arc Of Yuki Kaku’s Hells Paradise.
So as we kick things off, we find a young
restrained man who’s just been betrayed
by his comrades on a recent mission.
Before bring the sword down, he asks him for
any parting words, BUT the infamous Gabimaru
the Hollow simply replies ‘nah’.
So you see, decapitation demands exemplary
sword technique one in which only a few have
ever been able to master.
Typically the spectacle turns into a brute-fest
that transforms the grounds into an arena
of hell.
However as the sword comes down atop Gabimaru
it leaves everyone absolutely blown away once
it snaps and clatters to the ground apon touching
his skin…
Having managed to survive the initial execution,
Gabimaru wonders why he wont die…
He knows he doesn't have any kinds of attachment
to life as to his core, ‘he’s a Ninja’,
not someone who see’s the value of life.
Later on during his sentence he is visited
by an inspector who records his life story
in excruciating detail.
They go over everything from his parents,
dreams, all of the execution attempts made
on him, how he actually wants to die and finally
how he was betrayed by his village chief.
Later on and after witnessing another failed
execution attempt, the same female questions
Gabimaru, stating that he told her he wished
to die and yet it appears as though he just
resisted his execution now.
She asks him why a man with no reason to live
would do such a thing?
Sitting there, Gabimaru explains that he was
the best of the best in Iwagakure and because
of this he was to marry the daughter of his
village's chief, however, he could not tolerate
her and requested to the chief to end his
relationship with her.
Being restrained apon entry into the house,
the chief states that he would allow Gabimaru
to leave her BUT only on the condition he
would complete one last mission.
Then the moment he learned that they had actually
set him up, he also realized that if he tried
to evade capture, then the Iwagakure would
track him down for the entirety of his life,
so because of this he decided to throw in
the towel and give up.
Then skipping forward to after another series
of failed executions, like oml the actual
insanity and pure beauty of the art in this
story is freaking phenomenal, LIKE LOOK AT
THIS MAN AFTER SURVIVING THE BOILING POT.
Anyways so finally The inspector who has been
recording Gabimaru's past tells the other
men around her that the preparations are complete.
Having collected Gabimaru from his cell, he’s
slowly walked to yet another room in which
he assumes they’ll fail executing him again.
Yet after opening the door, its revealed that
the female who’d been questioning him is
actually A slayer named Yamada Asaemon Sagiri.
(aa-sia-mon) (segeri)
SOO this Yamada Asaemon name is handed down
over generations to the Ronin from the Yamada
Clan who are known to be extremely skilled
with a sword.
They’re also known as, neck chopper asa
or decapitator asa and train their blades
by cutting down a multitude of different people!
As Sagiri prepares to bring her blade down
on Gabimaru, she tells him that his wish is
granted.
Sensing death approaching, he realizes this
woman is indeed genuine and instinctively
flexes destroying the shackles holding him
restrained.
Quickly darting in behind the ninja, Sagiri
attempts to slice down on him with her Katana,
but Gabimaru swiftly dodges at the last second.
Again dodging a quick flurry of strikes from
Sagiri, Gabimaru starts to wonder why he’s
refused to accept his fate and die.
As more fodder fools start to surround the
duo, Sagiri tells him that the blade reflects
ones true nature, some may bluff and keep
a brave face to the bitter end, some turn
desperate and cling to life, while others
deceive themselves into accepting death.
To her its extremely obvious that there is
a great emptiness within him and its fairly
evident given the life he’s led.
Yet even still, he has been lying, she tells
him that he does indeed have an attachment
to life, stating that he loves his so called
dim-witted wife…
To Gabimaru her very existence gives him a
reason to live in the first place…
Lunging at her Gabimaru attempts to slice
Sagiri, but she easily blocks and confirms
her theory.
She wonders if he refuses to be executed because
he still has feelings for her, but he’s
also tried to convince himself that he has
no reason to actually live.
SCREAMING AT HER TO SHUT UP, Gabimaru jumps
back and yells asking what the hell she would
know about this messed up world they live
in, HE IS THE INFAMOUS GABIMARU.
Yettt as our broken man goes to scream the
name that brings terror to the hearts of even
the strongest men, he’s cut off by a memory
of his beloved wife telling him that he really
isn't hollow after all…
No, He’s not the cold hearted demon he’s
made out to be, he’s full of kindness and
is the only one who can stand to gaze apon
her deformed face..
After a small but super cute moment together,
she says that its confirms it!
there is no way you could be hollow inside.
Yet in-reality now he continues his scream
THAT HE IS GABIMARU THE HOLLOW, a completely
heartless monster, he tried his hardest to
live a freaking normal life, BUT ITS JUST
NOT POSSIBLE!
Living somewhere peaceful, a normal life like
ordinary people.
HE ISNT ALLOWED ANY OF THAT!
All of a sudden though, Sagiri disagrees with
his statement and presents to him a document
saying that he would be pardon for his crimes
by the Shogunate if he could complete a certain
task, He would have to travel to the ‘other
side’.
Confused about what she means with this, Gabimaru
asks if she means death, but Sagiri elaborates
that the other side is actually the pure land
or heaven, a revered holy realm hidden since
ancient times.
A place of joy and plenty where none will
suffer, that may even hold the elixir of life,
which has just recently been found in the
seas southwest far beyond even the Ryuku Kingdom…
(btw the Ryuku islands are the set of islands
that hold like Okinawa and stretch down towards
Taiwan!)
Anyways Anyways
Questioning the fairy tale like story, Sagiri
explains to him that in pursuit of this elixir,
the Shogun had already dispatched a research
team to the island, however the single boat
that returned was filled to the brim with
flowers and a foot with some organic growth..
Instantly they sent out 5 more boats, but
not a single person among them ever returned,
as for the things that did return.
They could barely be called human.
The next team to head to the island shall
consist of those ALREADY MARKED FOR DEATH,
so because of this Sagiri is here to actually
recruit someone she see’s fit, she seeks
a man of talent but someone still with the
strong will to live.
Sagiri explains to Gabimaru that his wife
is still alive but has turned inwards from
the moment he was captured and now speaks
to no one and refuses almost every meal.
Sagiri thinks that only one can guess what's
on her mind, but tells Gabi she suspects she’s
waiting on his return..
And so because of all of this that I've rambled
on about, she asks him if he is attached to
this life.
Will he travel to a crazy ass island with
a bunch of goons to complete his pardon and
return to his wife as that is his only hope
of ever having a reunion with her…
Standing there with tears in his eyes as he
remembers his wife's words of encouragement
he asks Sagiri if she wanted to see some Ninjutsu.
Then as she responds affirmatively, he tells
he to watch closely before sparks of fire
start lighting turning Gabimaru into a ball
of flames and he states Ninpō: Ascetic Blaze.
In an absolute blaze of power Gabimaru effortlessly
takes out every single one of the surrounding
guards, before taking the demon lord Sukuna’s
place above a pile of scorched men and confidently
stating that she can count him in, he’ll
find this so called elixir of life.
Going into a flashback Sagiri remembers the
time she saw her father skillfully beheaded
a criminal, so skillfully infact that the
dude didn't even realize he’d been beheaded.
From that day onwards it want to pursue a
career as an executioner.
Later in her life and after completing her
first clean cut she's congratulated by the
clueless men nearby, but Sagiri herself knows
and is also reminded of her weakness of holding
on to fear by her superiors each time she
executes criminals.
Its explained that when there is still fear
inside ones blade, that doubt and fear will
deliver an agonizing death to the condemned.
The blade reflects the truth in all things,
a blade drenched with fear causes the condemned
to suffer which in turn weighs down ones blade
even further…
Being drowned in this fear Sagiri wonders
how its possible to overcome this, how is
she ever able to rid herself of this fear
and doubt like her once father had.
Back in the present day we find all of the
law breakers and the people who brought them
to the capital along with the 11th Shogun;
Lord Tokugawa Nariyoshi.
One of his goons explains that the confidential
mission being offered to them, if completed,
will be given a full pardon by decree of the
Shogun himself.
Then going onto the so called island in question,
he explains that at a glance it appears to
be paradise, but after telling the criminals
to remove their blindfolds explains that the
amalgamation before them returned back from
the land with a few lumps over his body then
the next day they bloomed into what they look
like now!
One absolutely ripped dude who’s like ‘nah
bro I'm out I don't wanna chill with these
weirdos’ gets up and goes to leave.
Suddenly though, his head is cut clean off
as at that moment the same guard screams some
more information, informing every criminal
there that ‘they’ the Yamada Asaemon will
accompany them to the island.
This is mainly due to the fact that their
death sentences are already determined and
they don't need anyone trying to flee once
making it to the island.
The criminals are told that if they make one
wrong move or try to turn on them once landing
on the island then they’ll instantly be
beheaded on the spot.
Then finally just before ending his explanation
of what awaits them he states that before
the trip begins, they’d like to cut down
a few of the numbers, telling the multitude
of ruthless monoliths to go on and reduce
the amount of participants!
As the massacre begins filling the fat Shogun
with glee, we see one young man who’s obviously
on another level when it comes to straight
hands.
Man takes out a few small fry’s before it
skips over to a Kunoichi who by herself had
apparently taken down a bunch of retainers
in Sagiwa castle the previous year.
Back over with Sagiri, she’s approached
by Yamada Asaemon Eizen, who was that guy
who shanked the fodder criminal just before.
ANYWAYS as the two begin to talk he tries
to discourage her from partaking in the mission,
literally saying she should be in the kitchen
not in battle which is kinda crazy haha.
Sagiri explains to him though that she would
have chosen that life if it was a possibility,
but their clan test their blades on bodies
and turns the remains of those fallen into
medicine.
So due to these circumstances her life inherently
revolves around the dead, and as much as she
tried to ignore it she just couldn't as she
knew from the time with her father that the
blade reflects the truth in all things.
A few criminals then try to attack Sagiri
as a chance to escape but fail as she manages
to decapitate them, but just like previously,
she's instantly dragged down by the grotesque
fear coursing through her blade.
Noticing this Gabimaru points out that she's
still shaken when she kills, but states he’d
rather avoid unnecessary killing as to him
that seems perfectly normal.
Having overheard this one of the guards points
out to a large group of criminals and commands
them to take down Gabimaru stating that doing
so will guarantee their participation.
Seeing as he had no choice in the matter,
Gabimaru proceeds to brutally kill the criminals.
After seeing the hollow himself literally
go demon mode, Sagiri comes to the realization
that instead of trying to kill without fear
she needed to try to bear the weight of her
fear and the lives she takes, just like Gabimaru
does.
Sagiri sheds a single tear and declares that
she will be the one to execute Gabimaru.
So after the complete beatdown we just got
to witness the final participants are all
revealed.
We have the scarred up G ‘BANDIT KING’
AZA CHOBE, ‘Blade Dragon’ Tamiya Gantetsusai,
‘Hunter Of The Hundred’ Warped Keiun,
everyone's favorite Nurugai Of The Sanka,
‘The Killing Buddhist Prayer’ Hōrubō,
‘STRAY NINJA’ GABIMARU THE HOLLOW, ‘Cannibal
Courtesan’ Akaginu, ‘Kunoichi’ Yuzuriha
of Keishu, Moro Makiya ‘The Apostate’
and finally ‘The Giant of Bizen’ ROKUROTA.
Remember all of these names, along with each
of the disciples from the Yamada clan that
will be paired with them (they all get revealed
at different moments throughout the early
moments on the island) as moments after the
massacre was completed all 10 survivors were
loaded onto a large ship and sent towards
their freedom!
After arriving on the island, Gabimaru tells
Sagiri of the Iwagakure Chief's immortal body
and how the Elixir of Life may actually exist,
though he doubted it may be on the island
because of the unnatural environment.
He then easily frees himself of his restraints
stating that they dont know what they could
encounter, but Sagiri refuses to allow him
to do whatever pleases him and demands that
he put back on the restraints.
Not listening to her, Gabimaru instead goes
on about the ridiculously small amount of
supplies along with little to no direction
on where to go once arriving.
Snapping back, Sagiri holds her blade to Gabis
throat and commands him to rebind his hands!
She reiterates that, they are not partners,
she is his executioner and should he fail
to find the elixir not allowing him to get
pardoned…
Well she simply couldn't care less…
Clearing her voice she once again tells him
to bind his hands, in which after sighing
he replies that he gets it and rebinds his
hands stating that he’ll go along with these
little rules, BUT only upto a point..
THEN OUT OF KNOWHERE GABIMARU SUDDENLY BENDS
HIS NECK BACK LIKE A SNAKE DODGING A THUNDERING
STRIKE FROM WARPED KEUIN.
Having bounced back out of the way, Gabimaru
instantly points out to Sagiri that the criminal's
arms were not restrained.
(Love that)
Instantly over reacting, Sagiri questions
the rank 2 sword tester Yamada Asaemon Kishō
as to why he wasn't following the rules, only
for Kishō to reply telling her to chill out
and that the rules are not necessary.
Thinking that he’s being ignored by the
Hollow, Keiun charges at Gabimaru and pulls
out a full case of weapons to attack him with.
He states that weapons can only shine after
they’ve bathed in blood and soon his entire
body will learn the beauty of his art.
Gabimaru who’s just blown away with the
complete weirdness of this new opponent, explains
to him, that if he keeps up with how he’s
going then eventually other criminals will
overtake him in his race to the elixir.
Yet Keiun rebuttals him as he actually thinks
it’ll be a best case scenario to take out
all of the other competition first.
Being left with no other choice Gabimaru decided
to take him out, yet Warped Keiun instantly
charges in and attacks with a huge two handed
spear that shatters apon connecting with the
top of his head.
Quickly he changes his stance and sends the
hollow shooting back with a huge jab to his
body with the spear.
However…
they had no effect whatsoever on Gabimaru,
who like the legend he is was just double
checking to make sure his hands were still
tied together.
He then somehow manages to pin the spear under
his arm and fling the giant upwards directly
above him, surprising the two retainers watching
before then returning a bunch of the falling
weaponry that had just fallen out of Keiun
armory with some perfectly placed kicks.
Jumping back, Sagiri wonders if Gabimaru somehow
defeated him in one blow, yet Keiun actually
managed to survive after revealing that he
was wearing a thick armor coating underneath
his clothing.
Getting back up he states that the Legendary
Hollows skills sure are amazing, but they
weren't legendary enough to pierce through
his living armor.
He prepares himself to fight Gabimaru once
more, telling the small demon that he doesn't
understand the use of weapons and couldn't
display the beauty of his blade with his previous
attack, but now he will teach him its true
beauty…
Yet this man is apparently completely fodder
and doesn't even deserve 3 panels explaining
what happens as instead he is instantly finished
by the scattered weapons that had fallen to
the ground just previously.
As Gabimaru walks away from the mess, he signs
and shows the surprised retainers he never
removed his bindings during the fight.
Over with another group and while Rokurōta
was being transported (which is the massive
giant looking dude, like it takes 3 vessels
tied together to bull this sleeping giant
along) Looking at the size of him the random
staff members become worried overthinking
the possibility that the giant could awake
and go on a rampage, but Eizen, the schools
rank 1 Asaemon assures them that this is literally
the reason they’re here as no one is immune
to there cuts.
Back with our main group, Kishō had actually
moved into attack and its revealed that warped
Keiun was taken by surprise, being taken out
in the process.
Due to the his prisoner dying Kishō advises
the others that he’s going to head home
as he really doesn't have a reason to stay
anymore and while leaving Sagiri tries to
warn him about the sixty men that went missing
on the island.
The swordsman though just finds it a complete
waste of his time to be worrying about others
and infact considers himself lucky being able
to make an escape.
He warns her that the criminals with them
have already made their move, they’re individuals
who’ve never cared for societies laws and
the rules that the shogun gave them should
not be taken seriously since it might risk
their chances of acquiring the Elixir of Life.
In his eyes rather than taking the rules literally,
surely the Shogunate would be more pleased
with success at any cost.
He points out Gabimaru as a prime example,
asking if she preferred he was cut down now
so she could pretend and run off.
Having heard enough, Gabimaru silences Kishō
getting all up in his face and telling him
nothing else mattered all he wants is to get
back to his wife.
Kishō tells him to hurry then and snidely
warns the hollow ninja that within a few hours,
everything will have changed.
Back with Eizen and probably at somewhat of
a similar time, seeing that the Giant had
risen he asks if he’s hungry but immediately
notices the bloodlust emanating from his criminal.
In a flash the two don't even trade words
but immediately go to attack, sadly Eizen
aint living upto the aura that the name holds
and was literally slapped like a bug by Rokurōta.
(honestly a complete change from all the other
series with an Eizen, plus with him being
rank one I was so expecting him to be insanely
skilled, yet we never really got to see his
true potential.)
As Kishō then continues his ominous statement,
it darts around the outskirts of the island
revealing the dismay that has erupted in other
groups.
Apparently an emissary was already headed
to Iwagakure to ask them to help with this
mission.
Kishō knows the limits of his strength and
tells Sagiri that this mission will likely
determine the next head of the Yamada clan,
then with him having warned them about the
coming possibilities finally makes his leave.
Taking all of this in, she tries to pass of
the idea that Gabimaru would ever make a move
to attack her, however just as she asks where
they should go next, Gabi looking shell shocked
darts at Sagiri trying to strike her down.
Baffled and angered with the change in his
attitude, she just asks him why what could
possibly be the meaning of this?
Standing there, Gabimaru thinks back on the
moments after his birth and how his parents
tried to escape the village with him, but
were sadly slain.
Iwagakure Chief's cruely used this moment
to shape the child, telling him to look apon
their weakness.
He states that because of his parents sentimental
love it made them weak and if he doesn't grow
into a strong man he’ll end up like his
parents; uncapable of protecting even his
loved ones later in life.
Back in the heat of the battle and after learning
what Kishō had to say about Iwagakure getting
involved, Gabimaru knew that it would all
be over for him.
He wont have the luxury of taking time and
protecting random people on his path to find
the Elixir of Life and because of that he
was left with no other choice than to take
out Sagiri..
Dashing in the two let loose a flurry of strikes
causing constant sparks to fly off the clashing
pieces of metal.
Thinking herself, Sagiri wonders why she's
hesitating, why hasn't she been able to write
him off as just another villan.
Opposing her Gabimaru also confused wonders
why, why is he wavering, before then remembering
his wife's words on how its only natural that
he doesn't want to follow through with taking
her out.
Instead its best to follow your sentimentality,
he’s different now, he isn't the hollow
man he once was, its not a form of weakness
but a form strength and it will guide him
into a pure warrior.
Unable to throw away the beliefs he grew up
with, Gabimaru cant help but fall back into
darkness, knowing that he’s learnt of weakness.
Using his hand like a spear, Gabi bursts through
his bandages putting Sagiri easily within
range but once again hesitates allowing her
to notice in time and deflect the strike.
The two once again slash at each other, but
they both note that their own damn emotions
are slowing them down.
Remembering the old fart again though as if
the dude has some kinda hold over his thoughts,
Gabimaru takes things up a notch proceeding
to straight up just cut her sword in half
and as she stands there in utter shock seemingly
finishes the job.
Yet its revealed that Sagiri had used her
sheath to deflect the killing blow.
Momentarily baffled Gabi just tells her that
resisting is useless as he knows she cant
bring him down with the sheath alone.
He apologizes for what he has to do However,
Sagiri again hits a nerve within him by saying
that she didnt realize he wasn't capable of
feeling such sentiment given his reputation.
Agreeing that he doesn't, Gabimaru blitzes
Sagiri appearing atop her as a mass of smoke
and fire.
Before he could kill her though, he is once
again reminded of his wife's influence and
stops himself from killing her.
Appearing on his shoulder the chiefs thoughts
taunt Gabi trying to get him to take out his
retainer.
Leaning over her he tries to will himself
to push forth and do something he’s done
thousands of times before, but he cant as
his wife’s apparition is able to destroy
the evil emotions controlling him.
Laying below the broken man, Sagiri realizes
that throughout the entire time she’s known
him he’s worn an expression of utter pain,
like he was enduring something.
For her she was able to see this and it actually
allowed her to confront the emotions she had
kept hidden.
With Gabi not able to bring himself to kill
Sagiri, he begins crying, believing that with
the way he is he won't be able to survive
on the island or ever see his wife again.
Sagiri realizes that this isn't weakness what
he has is a love for his wife which shows
for a fact that he can feel emotions.
Still lying there she promises him that if
he faces his emotions while reclaiming his
life then she will support him throughout
the journey.
Finally, Sagiri tells Gabimaru to show her
what he’s capable of, as even though their
inherent relationship hasn't changed, he is
no longer the same man he once was.
Ahh so I actually love these 2 characters
that get introduced throughout this part,
complete polar opposites but damn there both
so cool in there own ways.
So in the past the hulking giant Gantetsusai
went by the name “Blade Dragon Eight Provinces
Unparalleled”.
After arriving in a certain province a Daimyo
who shared a similar title offered him work
and food, so he decided to take him up on
the offer.
After a coupley drinks though, the Daimyo
insisted that even with his nickname he doubts
he could ever take down an actual dragon.
Utterly insulted with the idea he couldn't
take down a dragon, Gantetsusai destroyed
the dragon statue atop the entrance way to
the daimyo’s residence along with the whole
gate.
Obviously and as your may have suspected this
resulted in him later being kicked out of
his own clan and sentenced to death, hence
how man ended up on the mission to the island.
Having revealed his past the his retainer
who’s the Rank 9 Yamada Asaemon Fuchi, Gantetsusai
tells him that once he gets his pardon and
walks free will return to cut down the silly
old Daimyo’s mansion.
Fuchi standing there utterly fails to comprehend
how he even came to that being a good conclusion.
Gantetsusai jokingly mocks the tiny retainer
and makes a few negative comments about the
Yamada clan.
Peeved Fuchi draws out his sword and tells
him not to make fun of the clan causing Gantetsusai
to back away from the blade feeling a deadly
bloodlust coming from the midget.
Not escalating the argument, the big man just
tells him to not get in his way before freeing
himself from his bindings.
He then explains his plan of eliminating the
other competition around (criminals wise)
so he can take extra time with finding the
elixir in safety.
Fuchi takes note of the fact that only a few
criminals will survive the trials on the island
and if the shogun becomes impatient because
of that, he will call upon a stronger and
more venomous batch of warriors to dispatch
in their stead.
(btw the symbolism here is actually taken
from real life, back in early Japan they used
to put venomous insects in a pot and let them
battle, then the venom that remained would
be used to curse someone.
Another big Mangaka to go out of his way to
use this is actually Gege with some of the
recent stuff in the Manga there like ive explained
before!)
Eitherway having moved forward together, the
two then stumble upon some ancient man-made
statues.
Not paying attention to his surroundings Gantetsusai
is stung on the hand by a random looking butterfly
that had a human face on it.
Stunned he quickly remembered what happened
to the guard that had returned from the island
and without a second thought cuts off his
left hand confusing the retainer with him.
Looking at the hand though its shown that
in a matter of moments after landing it started
morphing into a bunch of flowers.
Suddenly from within the tree’s around them
butterfly's start bursting out, causing Gantetsusai
to get excited as he prepares to defend himself
against the random creatures.
However, appearing from behind them once more
a comically large titan like creature starts
walking in their direction.
Meanwhile, Gabimaru and Sagiri are also approached
by the same weird looking creatures.
With them confused over what they’re seeing,
Gabimaru steps forth telling Sagiri to stay
back.
Looking at he wonders what in the world it
could possibly be, why a fish, it doesn't
even look like its supposed to be real, plus
its got these random prayer beads as if its
subject to some sort of religion.
With his instincts screaming danger Gabimaru
watches as the beast tries to attack him.
Easily he’s able to dodge the amalgamation
of hands, before jumping up kicking the monster.
However the monster was actually able to block
the blow, having grabbed the Ninja’s leg
it then proceeds to toss him into the ground,
causing Gabi to jump back and rethink his
attacking strategy.
Remembering his Ironclad Ninja Law number
5 to avoid an unfamilar enemy he thinks about
fleeing the area with Sagiri.
Yet our boy is taken by surprise as a rope
like extension from the monster grabs and
tosses him through the nearby foliage.
Wounded from the blow, he tells Sagiri that
they just need to run for now, but as they
go leave its shown that a plethora of these
random monsters with prayer beads and vestments
have surrounded them.
Seeing no way out, Gabimaru clears his head
of all other distractions and goes utter demon
mode.
Jumping into the sky he easily takes out the
fights monster with a punch before igniting
it with his Ninpo Ascetic Blaze.
Sagiri who’s watching in horror behind him
remembers how Gabi explained that in his clan
they go through all kinds of bizarre training
and though that they learn abilities akin
to breathing fire or becoming one with the
sea.
Gabimaru having sparked alight from the use
of his technique knows that in order to survive
this hellish island and get the pardon he
has to kill anything that gets in his way.
Watching Gabimaru fight off the random creatures,
Sagiri thought that she was prepared to take
on the unknown, but now with everything going
on around her, she starts to wonders if perhaps
this isn't the pure land but instead?
Before she’s able to think any longer though
a large buddha like monster confronts her
from behind.
Gabimaru who’s fading in and out of some
kind of visual experience notices that Sagiri
is in danger, but instead of turning to help
her focuses on taking out the large creature
infront of himself.
However, without even realizing it Gabimaru
had managed to actually attack her creature
saving Sagiri in the process.
As Gabi sits there confused holding her, she
thanks him for saving her life, but then again
out of nowhere has his head is wrapped up
by one of the creatures tentacles.
Randomly in the split second before the monster
squeezed down, someone had managed to sever
its hold on Gabimaru.
Turning around he notices that 3 newcomers
had arrived and saved them from the surrounding
creatures.
Yuzuriha who’s another Ninja like Gabimaru
walks up and makes her introduction.
While Sagiri thinks its odd that a pair of
retainers are escorting her Gabimaru thanks
them for intervening, but asks why, why would
they go out of their way to help someone when
they’re under no obligation to do so.
Yuzuriha just straight up tries seducing him
to get around the question and into teaming
up, however, Gabimaru pins her down explaining
that her methods won't work on him.
(Be like Gabi guys, don't be a sneako cuckboy)
Yuzuriha was really trying to team up with
them, but before they continue as a group
Sagiri asks why two people have ended up escorting.
Rank 8 Yamada Asaemon Genji explains that
he was originally in charge of Moro yet Moro
was quickly deceived by Yuzuriha and taken
out.
After realizing what she’d done Genji proudly
determined that she could not be left alone
with just a single executioner and decided
to watch over her with the other dude.
Yuzuriha explains that before running into
Gabimaru they were also surrounded by bugs.
She knows that the island isn't exactly the
safest place out and because of that knows
finding the elixir and escaping is key.
Yet if she was to run in without a plan or
by herself she’d probably be killed and
it would all be for nothing.
So due to the predicament she found herself
in, the strategy of playing it safe by teaming
up to find the elixir is by far the smartest.
After thinking Gabimaru accepted her into
the group, Yuzuriha tried to give him a hug,
but Gabi instantly pinned her down, telling
her that he wasn't in agreement since he doesn't
trust them in the slightest.
Looking at him, Yuzuriha breaks the ninja’s
hold, pulling him in close and telling him
that they didn't have to trust each other
and can betray one another whenever they’d
like as after all that elixir is just worth
a single pardon.
If they team up though, she’ll provide them
with information regarding the human-faced
butterflies, explaining that they swarm around
the monsters and have scales that emit poison
that causes hallucinations but are still a
mystery overall.
Curious on how she figured this out to start
with, Gabi asks how she came to that conclusion.
Funnily enough, like remember Moro, well Yuzuriha
had got hella friendly with him, then tied
him to a tree to check certain bugs effects.
From this she was able to learn that the centipedes
by far have the worst effect, but the majority
of bugs wont really attack you unless provoked
them.
Yamada Asaemon Senta who’s originally Yuzuriha’s
executioner finally speaks up and lets them
all know that all of the monsters he’s seen
have qualities associated with Buddhism and
Tao.
Those two religions alone have fundamentally
different core structures so he finds he weirdly
unsettling that here they’ve blended together
in some dark nature, from just this fact alone
he believes this islands true nature is defiantly
not pure.
Sagiri agrees, like even though these monsters
appear as godly beings, the feeling her blade
gives her solidifies the idea that they’re
simply living creatures.
To Yuzuriha this just cements that its a priority
they communicate and gather more info but
Gabimaru wondering what's motivating her to
this extent asks why?
According to her, this is all for her little
sister.
She suffers from an incurable disease and
due to their situation in life, they couldn't
even afford basic medicine.
In an attempt to earn money she turned ninja
and took part in the hellish training inside
of the Kai Clan.
Randomly one day the boss turned on her and
thats how she ended up here.
Still Gabimaru literally doesn't believe her.
Finally revealing what seems to be the truth,
she reveals that she doesn't even have a story,
getting to live and return home is more than
enough for her.
Wanting to know one more thing, Gabi inquires
as to what exactly she did to her executioner.
Like last time she insists that he was just
used as a vessel to perform research experiments
on before snidely asking if he really cares
that much about the lives of others.
Knowing that she contains information about
the island, Gabimaru agrees to help her with
fighting but other than that they’re not
cooperating.
As the others bicker about what information
to share, Sagiri looks back on how far she’s
come since arriving on the island, which in
her eyes is pretty much no where.
She knows that she was overwhelmed by the
monsters and the entire situation itself has
just caused her to feel flustered.
Disappointed in herself for how powerless
she currently is, Sagiri drops to the floor
fainting from the effects of the previous
battle.
Going back in time again were introduced to
Toma who’d managed to earn his license as
apart of the Asaemon Executioners after only
a month of training, the only thing remaining
for him to do was the execution itself.
Funnily enough its shown that the person he’d
chosen was his own brother.
In a turn of events that the clan isnt privy
to yet, Toma had purposfully infiltrated the
them so that the two would later be able to
escape together.
Obviously the way they ended up escaping or
trying to was taking part as retainer and
criminal in the trip to paradise island.
Now on the island its shown that the two were
able to make landfall but like everyone else
had been surrounded by a plethora of random
wildlife and religious figures.
Watching Chōbei rush forth to protect him,
Tōma thinks back on how, even when they were
little and had lost their mother to illness,
even after their father betrayed the clan
and was sentenced, even when bandits attacked
them without a second thought Chōbei always
figured things out and adapted to every situation.
He learnt early on that the law of this land
isn't that the strong always win, but rather
a survival of those who manage to adapt best
to the situation and surroundings effecting
them.
(btw you’ll learn all about how this story
teaches us that being strong and weak are
both valuable to someone's personality.
Its a much deeper story that I initially thought
when I started reading.
I came into it under the precedent it was
a darker shounen that went crazy with some
of its battles, but I had no idea that some
of the things it tries to teach its readers
are truly good morals to live by.
Like straight up even with Gabi just being
faithful to his wife and not on that pervy
weirdness that other series tend
to have)
Having taken out a bunch of the monsters,
the duo notice even more approaching and decide
to flee the area rather than take them on.
As they try to escape, Tōma’s hair is caught
by one of the monsters and while freaking
out screams for his brothers help.
However, Chōbei continues to run off.
Left with no other option that to defend for
himself, Tōma strikes at the large monster
trying to take it down.
Blowing through the monster though its shown
that Chōbei had just gapped it to grab a
large axe from one of the previously defeated
members.
Chōbei is then struck by another monster,
taking him completely by surprise and while
looking at the group begin to surround them
hears it tell them that killing is a sin.
Standing there listening to all of the voices
echo around them Tōma begins to freak out
in a similar way to Sagiri earlier.
Chōbei on the other hand tho, like mans on
that demon mode spec becomes enraged by their
speaking of sin and tells them to shut up.
He screams as he destroys the surrounding
monsters that all of them are just slaves,
silly puppets stuck to a regimented code of
law.
UNLIKE THEM HE IS HIS OWN MASTER, HIS OWN
GOD.
Standing there, looking at her brother Tōma
admires Chōbei's ability to adapt, his constant
unyielding sense of self is what defines him.
So when it comes down to their overall plan,
well its now changed from just getting this
pardon and escaping together.
Now Chōbei states that he will kill all of
the monsters and criminals on the island before
downing the elixir of life themselves.
Back with the main squad, Sagiri awakens terrified
after having a nightmare that involved her
father looking down on her.
Genji who’s nearby looking after her while
the others were working brings her up to date
with how they’ve taken shelter in a tree
hollow and that she’d fainted because of
the toxic powder coming off the butterfly's.
As Sagiri leaves the hollow she finds Gabi
chilling outside with Senta making a meal
for the group.
Outside he brings her upto date, explaining
that while looking for ingredients for their
meal he took the opportunity to check out
the island a bit more.
Pretty much he was able to deduce that there
isn't anything resembling the Elixir of Life
around the area they find themselves in.
Instead most of the fauna around are a jumble
of different plants that you could find on
the mainland, with the exception of a few
random flowers.
Genji suggests that the plants might be from
the Ryuku islands, but Gabi explained what
really stood out was how all of the Samurai
were in bloom.
Remember the initial squad that rolled upto
the island with only the one returning, well
yes sadly they’d all fallen prey to the
island and become apart of it themselves.
(btw for anyone who’s curious the Ryuku
islands are a stretch of islands south of
Japan, but still considered apart of their
country.
In Jigokuraku’s story the islands are probably
the closest pieces of Japanese land to this
so called Paradise Island)
Senta (the old-school weeb legend himself)
then gives his input and tells them how the
statues all scattered about the place seem
to be either Buddhist or Taoist in design,
yet that isn't actually what intrigues him.
More he questions if the technology to create
such things even exists on this island or
if their creator perhaps lives elsewhere before
they brought them here.
Sagiri believes that its unfeasible for anyone
to live on the island to start with since
the creatures make it too dangerous for any
humans to exist.
She then explains how she detected human traits
from the monsters when she was cutting them
but detected no signs of organs or reproductive
capabilities.
The monster forms are utterly bizarre with
them possessing some form of humanoid structure,
but with bugs and other creatures riding atop
them.
Senta interrupts and explains it a bit better,
we know they’re religious in nature but
the details aren't exactly right, as if they’re
poorly thought out deities.
This island and the monsters as a whole, its
all to artificial to be the creations of divine
creatures, its as if the group had been tossed
into a ill conceived mandala, an unfamiliar
space with nothing tying them back to reality.
Growing a crazed expression Gabimaru becomes
manic after hearing that creatures without
organs exist, to him that sounds like some
form of immortality, so if he can find that
source he can return home.
Taking Gabimaru's advice, Senta says that
they should do more research on the monsters
before travel any deeper and put their lives
in more danger.
As the sun begins to start setting Genji confronts
Sagiri and demands that she return home on
the ship, he knows that this isn't a place
for her and due to his criminal passing away
can take her stead.
To anyone who decides to stay on the island
will only face death, but Sagiri denies his
attempts to send her home, wishing to complete
her duties.
Genji questions her skill though and points
out that the blade she now has is just some
random one she picked up along the way.
To anyone in the Yamada clan they know that
the Katana is a warriors spirit and with Sagiri
having lost hers its as if she's already lost
what made her a Yamada to begin with.
He doesn't deny that she is truly skilled
with a blade, but this island is different,
some weird skill is needed to win the battles
here and she’s clearly being held back by
one majorly defining factor.
Her Gender.
(Which is LIKE YO DUDE CHILL, Some weirdo
masculinity vibe coming off you now Genji,
like man seemed genuine up until he drops
the Gender play.
Dude’s so unimportant he cant even break
the forth wall and realize this is MANGA Gender
is the least of your issues for building strength.)
Meanwhile, the goats Rank 10 Yamada Asaemon
Tenza and his criminal Nurugai are found on
a small rowing boat attempting to escape the
island.
Nurugai brings up that even if they do manage
to leave they’ll both die as they’ve returned
without the elixir.
Thinking that he can get his way through any
scenario Tenza reassures him that he’ll
try to convince the higher ups somehow once
they aboard the shogunate's ship.
Apparently this large vessel is meant to be
anchored nearby for 3 days, allowing them
to complete the mission and return home.
Yet after pointing out something he thought
was the boat, they’re both disheartened
to only find the remains of their ship strewn
in-between long ago destroyed ships, half
submerged infront of them.
Nurugai who spotted something out the corner
of his eye, tells Tenza to stop drawing his
sword but its to late as a massive tentacle
appears behind and swipes at the two.
Having noticed in time Nurugai was able to
grab his boy and dodge the attack, telling
him that most creatures are sensitive to shiny
things so they should just look for an escape
route.
Unable to find a boat to escape on, the two
become surrounded causing Nurugai to thinks
back to the time he accidently led soldiers
to his village.
Back then he was one of the mountain folk,
someone who didnt pledge loyalty to the Shogunate,
but instead lived traditionally.
With Japan having certain rules in this time
period that meant people couldn't live this
way, they were instead considered rebels against
the regime.
Sadly they used Nurugai to lure out the locations
of his other family and clan members who subsequently
died from this.
Once imprisoned himself, Nurugai had meet
Tenza who out of generosity of his heart offered
him the mission to search for the Elixir of
Life as a way to escape imprisonment.
Conflicted on what to do Nurugai wonders if
he should die for the sin he committed or
live on to continue on his village's bloodline
as the last of its name.
Obviously as we find them stumbling into Kishō's
body which had begun blooming with flowers
he’d chosen the latter and decided to take
his chances with Tenza on the island.
As a massive Tentacle destroys even more of
their surroundings, Nurugai looks upon Kishō's
body and sees the vision of his grandfather’s
last moments, causing him to become frighten
and drop to his knees.
Tenza asked what was worrying him, but Nurugai
utterly broken after the decisions he’d
made in his life notes that it really all
makes sense now.
All of this is a divine punishment, his true
sentence for causing the death of everyone
he holds close.
As a tentacle bears down apon the duo, Tenza
was luckily able to slice it before it took
out Nurugai and after listening to his explanation
about the Sankha people’s customs, tells
him that he doesn't care about the customs
he believes in, he just needs to survive.
With more attacks pushing Tenza to his limit,
he screams that he doesn't wanna hear about
his grandpa or the village, the real question
is if you want to live or not!
Thinking back to a peaceful time in the mountains
with his grandfather, Nurugai says that he
doesn't want to die and instead just wants
to return home.
Throwing him a sword Tenza points out Kishō’s
boat, telling him to survive as they fight
their way off the wreckage.
Teaming up now, the duo are just barely able
to battle their way through the monsters and
make it safely to the shoreline of Paradise
Island aboard Kishō’s boat.
From there efforts to escape the island, Tenza
was able to deduce that even if they find
the elixir its pointless without a way off
the island.
He points out that one boat did manage to
make it back to the mainland so there has
to be some sort of escape current, but as
he turns to look at Nurugai he notices something.
YES thats right I fooled you all or at least
I hope I didnt give it away because its actually
revealed that while there washing up Tenza
noted that Nurugai looked extremely feminine.
To which Nurugai says that he is indeed a
girl, shocking the Asaemon.
With that massive reveal out of the way and
the two funnily joking around, Tenza says
that moving forwards they have to scout around
to find a proper escape route, but the monsters
also pose an issue.
So he proposes the idea of searching for more
allies that also wish to return home which
in my eyes makes perfect sense.
(Plus Nurugai is another really dope character,
its funny how weve got a Yamada who looks
like a chick in Tōma and a criminal that
looked like a dude in Nurugai.
Kinda just opposing factors on each side and
in my eyes it goes with the entire theme of
Yin and Yang that later gets spoken about
in much more depth later on.)
Back over with Genji who’s really keen to
make a point about how this aint no place
for a woman and Sagiri needs to take a boat
back when dawn came and leaves.
Half wanting her to leave and half not Senta
believes that it would be the best choice
for Sagiri to leave but also thinks that she
should stay to watch Gabimaru.
From what he’s seen so far he can say without
a doubt that Gabimaru was not the same man
as he was back at Edo.
It may only be because he knows that he needs
to return with her, but wonders if there is
some other reason keeping her here.
With night falling around them, Sagiri decides
that she’ll watch over the group as they
sleep, but Gabimaru tells her that he literally
doesn't sleep, so there wasn't any need to
stay up.
Even still he asked if she was feeling better
as he suspected that after he wounded her
in there previous battle, the poison from
the butterfly probably speed thru her quicker.
Due to how she helped him see the light, he
realized that rushing in is only going to
result in disaster for the group.
From now on they wont run from anyone that
threatens there chances of survival or the
possibility to reunite with his wife, they’ll
meet everyone head on.
Turning to Sagiri he also compliments, believing
she could be even stronger than himself, as
obviously he does have an eye for strength.
Reflecting back on the time with her in the
prison he states that even then he’d felt
her strength.
They had a saying back in our boys village.
‘One cannot know ones own strength without
first travelling far and wide.’
Most people don't even realize their full
strength until they’re forced to act, its
that way for everyone.
As dawn begins to rise, Sagiri becomes encouraged
by Gabimaru's words and faces Genji, telling
him that she appreciates his concern, but
will not leave the island.
The flipping nob Genji finds this ridiculous,
a womans only role is to bear a child for
the Yamada clan.
Having heard that same thing a million times
before, Sagiri explains her grief growing
up, telling him of how everyone, including
her father, looked down on her for following
the path of a warrior and that now a fellow
clansman is doing the same.
She urges Genji to look at her as a samurai,
to acknowledge that this is the path she took,
man or woman, regardless of someone's situation
they should always be free to choose their
path.
This absolute douche though, like Genji what
happened, who hurt you.
Obviously man is angered by her statement,
saying that this isn't the way of the samurai.
He draws his blade and goes to strike down
on her, however, as he stands there talking
smack, its revealed that Sagiri had managed
to disarm and steal his blade completely perplexing
the bushy eyebrow freak.
Literally taking a dumb on this mans head,
Sagiri reveals that Genji was originally the
person who taught her how to steal a blade
in the heat of battle.
Genji getting even madder screams again that
a KATANA IS THE WARRIORS SOUL, yet unlike
Sagiri he was unable to notice Rokurōta approaching
them from behind.
During his time as an infant, Rokurōta had
I think accidentally killed his entire village
and family by pushing over a tower of stones
he built, sending them shooting off like bullets
around the area (at least thats what I think
happened).
Back on the island Genji had managed to turn
in time, but just like during his childhood
Rokurōta used his infamous palm strike to
connect with the Samurai sending him spinning
back severely wounded.
Sagiri runs towards Genji but is about to
be attacked by the giant, luckily for her,
Gabimaru arrives on time to landing a fat
head kick on Rokurōta, sending him him crashing
back through their surroundings.
Noticing that Eizen, Rokutora’s retainer
isn't with him, Sagiri comes to the correct
conclusion that he’d been taken out as soon
as they landed on the island..
Gabimaru quickly goes over his two options,
escape or fight, but ultimately decides to
take on Rokurōta and tells Sagiri to leave
so that she isn't in danger.
Dodging a massive tree that takes out a few
more behind it, he then looks towards Yuzuriha
who’s big chilling with Senta and asks for
her assistance.
Yuzuriha though is like nah and reminds him
of the deal to providing intel while Gabimaru
deals with fighting.
Rokurōta strikes at Gabimaru once more, but
he easily manages to jump back out of the
way and begins to strategizes on how to handle
Rokurōta.
His instincts tell him its utterly impossible
to guard against the hand, if he’s hit its
game over.
Trying something different, he stomps the
ground causing a few rocks to fly up before
using Ninpo: Stone Storm, sending a plethora
of stones into the body of the massive brute
infront of him.
With projectiles not working, he uses Ninpo:
Unformed blade and goes to strike Rokurōta,
yet his attack is quickly deflected once more
by the hand.
Not knowing what to use now, he decides to
throw a couple more range attacks BUT as you
can see by the like what even is that 1,2,3
7 abilities used on the hulking giant not
a single one worked leaving Gabi completely
confused on his next course of action.
Meanwhile in the forest behind them, Sagiri
tries to save Genji, which im like girl your
should straight up leave him there after what
that man was saying b4.
EVEN Genji who’s still on the weird gender
spiel finds it strange that earlier Sagiri
had the attitude of a man but now has the
compassion of a woman.
Screaming at him Sagiri says that it doesn't
matter what she is, she just doesn't want
to see a comrade die.
With that said, Genji finally has some sort
of enlightening and realizes that Sagiri's
conviction was to accept both sides.
Understanding who she is now, he brings up
his sword and gives it to her to fight Rokurōta
in his stead.
He screams at her now that if she's a so called
Samurai then she wont hesitate to cut down
Rokurōta taking vengeance for him and Eizen.
Over with Gabi its obvious that he’s still
struggling to find an opening.
With Rokurōta swinging at him he’s barely
able to dodge the blow, but as he turns around
he finds that the giant had somehow lost a
finger in their exchange.
Gabimaru is still struggling with coming up
with a strategy to fight Rokurōta but notices
that Sagiri appears and swiftly cuts one of
Rokurōta's fingers.
Its said that any body no matter how sturdy
or unconventional it is, can be cleaved.
The principles of decapitation will never
change, you just need to know the body's framework
and work it to find your own openings.
Standing there together now both Gabimaru
and Sagiri get ready to take down Rokurōta
together.
Still big chilling up in the tree, Yuzuriha
watches the two face off against Rokurōta.
Senta who’s currently pinned up to the tree
branch asks to help Genji but Yuzuriha tells
him that its too late and its much safer to
stay up in the tree watching the fight.
Down below, Gabimaru tells Sagiri that it
will be up to her to finish him off with a
singular cut.
Sagiri informs him that in order to do so
she will need him on his knees since his neck
is too high.
Literally as Gabimaru says he’s sure she
can pull it off Rokurōta throws a punch towards
Gabimaru but he deflects it with a kick, leaving
her with the perfect opportunity to drop the
giant.
Sagiri gets behind Rokurōta and while remembering
her past mentors prepares to cut his right
leg.
However stop just before connecting and jumps
back as a thundering backhand comes thru.
Its shows that she wants to avenge her fallen
comrades so bad that her swordplay is wavering
and becoming unsteady.
Trying to compose herself, she barely dodges
a punch directed at the duo.
Gabimaru himself realizes that he cant deflect
to many more strikes as his leg is already
beginning to suffer.
Sagiri tries to cut Rokurōta's arm but fails
once again, noting how his massive size and
his fighting style is causing his bones to
interfere with her blades path.
Rokurōta's stomach then loudly rumbles, causing
him to start crying and screaming almost deafening
everyone around.
Gabimaru goes to block the noise with his
hands, but as soon as he does the giant takes
the opening and slams the hollow into the
ground.
Darting back up almost immediately Gabi tries
to withstand the unreal level of strength
and almost does, but sadly he succumbs to
the hit and drops to the ground.
Panicking now he screams at himself to get
up as it wasn't a fatal attack, though if
he doesn't move soon hell be annihilated.
Coming to his aid Sagiri gets infront of Rokurōta’s
next attack but quickly realizes if she doesn't
move aswell she’ll die.
Telling herself to calm down, suppress her
emotions and be rational as she has chosen
that way to live.
Sagiri is able to figure out that there is
no distinction between the two, and accepting
both emotion and reason will allow her to
move forward.
Unlike other members of the Yamada Clan, Sagiri
hasn't seen enough battle to make her a true
soldier, but when she's on a mission and her
goals and spirit align, when all doubts leave
her blade.
Her swordplay is unparalleled.
Once the insane bout finally comes to an end
its shown that Sagiri was able to drop the
giant onto his ass.
She quickly darts in behind him and attempts
to deal the finishing blow, but just as quickly
as she got in behind, Rokurōta sprung back
realizing that the next attack would be fatal.
Seeing as how normal moves weren't working,
Gabimaru comes up with a plan but tells his
partner that it may be slightly extreme.
After analyzing the situation, Gabimaru pulls
his clothing up over his face and bursts into
flames.
Taking out some balls, Gabi uses uses Ninpo:
Ascetic Blaze Mode to send them shooting towards
Rokurōta, who just knocks them away.
Following up he combines Ninpo: Zephyr Weave
and Blaze mode to send some flames towards
the giant.
Then using another multitude of techniques
Gabimaru attacks the Giant of Bizen over and
over again, but his opponent somehow manages
to repel every single attack.
Over with Yuzuriha who decided to gap it earlier
knowing what Gabimaru was actually planning
tells Senta that Gabi wasn't actually targeting
Rokurōta, no he was going to burn down the
forest and use the smoke to suffocate their
opponent.
Once the smaller branches and leaves all light
up, the whole area will be covered with smoke
that creates a canopy concentrated overhead.
Bit of a science lesson here, so smoke is
made up of carbon monoxide, carbon dioxide
and particulate matter.
What actually effects us is the Carbon monoxide
as it binds with the hemoglobin's in our blood
even more readily than oxygen.
This causes the body to instantly be deprived
of air, hence why most people in fires die
to carbon monoxide poisoning, not the actual
fire.
Back in the battle and due to the effects,
Rokurōta falls to his knees, giving Sagiri
an opportunity to finally strike him down.
Rokurōta notices her and tries to retaliate,
but Gabimaru rushes in and holds down his
hand.
He screams at her to hurry as his muscles
cant hold on for much longer.
Hearing this and becoming tranquil, yet intense
Sagiri becomes one with her blade and swings
the sword down.
In his final moments, Rokurōta remembers
his past, wandering aimlessly searching for
someone to play.
Obviously from what weve seen with Rokurōta,
like im not gonna slide on his actions but
its fairly evident the dude still has the
mind of a child and never really grew up.
Either way Sagiri apologizes to him and lays
his soul to rest, telling him that no-body
resents him anymore.
As the fire begins to get closer, Gabi says
its probably best they leave incase the fire
attracts unwanted visitors.
While running away, Sagiri remembers Genji
who’s still wounded resting up against a
tree.
Though after realizing she’ll perish if
she returns, makes the decision to leave,
telling herself that she must accept both
her strengths and weaknesses.
(Which like yo I think Sagiri is onto something
with this Strong Weak thing haha, this is
my second read thru now before making the
video and oml you just notice so many things
early on that are foreshadowed in such brilliant
ways.
If you all didnt know From 2016 to 2018, Yuki
actually worked as an assistant to Tatsuki
Fujimoto with his work on Fire Punch before
beginning this series later in 2018.
So its dope to see that greatness breeds greatness
and tbh I don't necessarily see similarities
between their works, but I just love knowing
that these goats worked together.)
As expected all of the nearby monsters are
lured towards the flames, which is already
starting to die down due to the thick level
of mist and humidity around the island.
Gabimaru suggests heading in the direction
all of the creatures came as despite his injuries
they’ve really got no other choice if they
want to find leads about the elixir of life.
As they start to leave Sagiri asks if they
should just take a moment to recover, but
Gabimaru starts freaking out claiming that
it doesn't matter how dangerous it is they
just need to find that elixir and make it
back to his wife.
He asks if Sagiri is worried about all of
her other comrades but she states that everyone
who took this mission, took it knowing the
insane danger that if held.
Having concern for them would only in Sagiri’s
eyes dishonor their resolve.
If she has time to worry about them, then
she also has time to be searching for the
elixir as a way to also free them from this
hellish mission.
Hearing this Gabi notes that it seems as if
they’re finally on the same page and while
running soon catches upto Yuzuriha and Senta
who are stood their in shook looking down
apon something.
Coming up behind them, both Gabi and Sagiri
notice that the others had found an abandoned
village.
Senta comes to the conclusion that if they
are truly in Shinsenkyo the village must be
where the Hermits live.
Which if I haven't mentioned it Shinsenkyo
is the Japanese name for the ancient Chinese
version of paradise, populated by immortal
gods and mountain hermits, hence how Senta
has gathered the information for Hermits living
in so called villages.
Back over with
the bruuuutal brothers, like I love these
two.
Like oml I forgot, but here is when Chōbei
goes full beast mode and began eating the
various monsters of the island as a form of
fluid to stay hydrated.
While this is going on Tōma explains to him
that there is a possibility fictional beings
called Hermits residing on the island.
They’re based on the old Chinese mountain
hermits, but despite their old age they are
actually immortal beings that wield strange
magic.
Shinsenkyo is really meant to be home to these
hermits and not monsters, so Tōma wouldn't
be surprised if they ran into them here.
Chōbei jokes that hell just turn those old
fools into another meal, though as they move
deeper into the foliage of the jungle Tōma
notices something or someone nearby.
Getting closer its shown that in an opening
atop a fallen statue two beautiful woman are
basking in the sunlight.
With all four of them noticing each other
simultaneously one of the random girls atop
the statue wonders why humans are here, becoming
enraged at the thought that the Soshin Guardian
Deities were slacking off.
(So as Senta suspected all of those Creatures
seemed to be some form of poorly thought out
deities created by someone.)
Eitherway back in the battle Chōbei readies
himself while pointing out that the girls
are probably another form of monster.
One of those apparent monsters snidely asks
if they’d like to lay with them, causing
the brothers to get hell confused by exactly
what she meant.
The other one stands up and literally changes
into a male form while cursing them out over
having lost his solidity.
(Man really got blue balled) He slams his
hand closed causing the fruit to explode and
letting the brothers know that now they must
die.
Back with Gabimaru as they look over the village,
the ninja states that it did not matter what
was living on the island, what matters is
if the inhabitants are allies or enemies.
Directly behind the main group, a girl in
a hood is then seen watching them from behind
a tree.
Gabimaru turns and notices someone causing
the spy to run off but Gabi manages to quickly
catch the spy and after removing the hood
discovers that its just a young girl.
While he wonders if its someone who’s native
to the island a branch comes thru and almost
takes his head off.
Its shown that a random looking tree dude,
everyone's favorite bonsai man, kinda like
groot from guardians of the galaxy had managed
to push Gabi back.
Thinking the girl might know something about
the island, Gabimaru decides to run after
her, he manages to dodge another thundering
blow from the tree, before spinning in the
air and using the back of the monster to boost
himself towards the girl.
Since Sagiri is still caught up on the original
missions hierarchy she quickly runs after
him and leaves the rest to Yuzuriha and Senta.
Yuzuriha being the sneaky Kunoichi she is
flicks off Senta's glasses so he can't see
her abilities and decides to take on the tree
monster with her ninjutsu.
Nearby Gabimaru manages to catches up to the
girl but as he asks to just have a chat is
shocked by her strength after she picks him
up before throwing him into a tree.
Sagiri yells to her that they don't intend
to harm her, however, the girl stops in the
forest, turns and throws a punch towards Sagiri.
Gabimaru blocks the punch but as he tries
to push back notices that she is using a mysterious
power behind her attack.
Being pushed back by this random power Gabi
starts to ponder what it could possibly be.
Ever since he came to this island there have
been so many mysteries.
He thought it’d just be a simple mission
to find the elixir and return home, but how
he’s becoming desperate.
Gabimaru starts to act serious and as he dives
at her uses the vines behind him on the tree
to captures her before she even realized what
had happened.
Hanging there restrained in the tree, intimated
by Gabi’s now serious demeanor, the girl
starts crying, prompting Sagiri to tell Gabimaru
to bring her down and let her calm her down.
Seeing her in a helpless state, Gabimaru figures
that she was just an ordinary girl.
Yuzuriha arrives after finishing her business
with the tree monster and asked how things
were going on their end.
Gabimaru wanted to ask her about the elixir
but Sagiri says that it wouldn't be possible
with her crying.
Suddenly, the tree monster started talking,
pleading with them to let go of the child
and in exchange that it would tell them about
the elixir and guide them to the village.
Speaking up Yuzuriha believes that its a trap
as up until now the bonsai dude hadn't said
anything.
After persuading her by mentioning that there
is a bath though, the group follows him to
the village with Yuzuriha overly excited about
that bath.
Hanging back behind them, Sagiri asks Gabi
whether they should trust him or not.
Left with really no other options he says
its probably best because he may know about
the elixir but also tells her that if the
tree man is lying he will take it down.
Hearing the others chat behind them, the tree
man promises that it will not trick them and
calms Senta by letting him know that the monster
and butterflies wont come near the village.
He also reveals that those so called monsters
are like i've said just before called the
Sōshin, guardians of the island.
According to master Tree they provide wisdom
and punish those who turn from the teachings.
He himself isn't one of them but instead used
to be human and was raised on the island.
These Soshin are actually called Kamadogami
in Japanese.
They are known as tutelary deities of the
kitchen and household in Chinese mythology
and Daoism.
Funnily enough the most famous of all the
Soshin deities was Zao Jun, who also went
by the moniker ‘Kitchen God’.
In this universe they mainly take on the role
as a fodder monsters who punish people that
break the islands rules.
Anyway!
They arrive at the village which at this point
is really just a town in ruins and entered
the tree mans house.
While Yuzuriha and Sagiri take a bath which
I aahhh cant show on here, lets just say that
Yuki loves drawing his girls for now hahaha.
Outside of the bath tho the others apart from
Gabi cause he thinks its poisoned eat some
delicious looking fruit.
Moments later both of the girls return and
the tree man goes more in-depth explaining
the ins and outs of the island.
Humans may call the island another name but
to him its known as Kotaku, a paradise for
the Gods.
There is indeed an elixir of life on the island
thats found in the ancient text.
Here it goes by the name ‘Tan’ and pretty
much means the source for everlasting life.
The tree man gives a lay out of the island,
which is broken into 3 distinctive regions.
Eishu is where they arrived on the island,
Hojo is where the village is located and the
elixir, is located at the center of the island
called Hōrai.
In our own world this is the name for the
Chinese Penglai.
A place said to be a mountain on a random
island in the eastern sea’s of mythological
China which was home to 8 immortal hermits
of Taoist thought.
Craaazily enough in a weirdly similar parallel
to this story, during the third century BCE,
a Qin Dynasty sorcerer named Xu Fu set out
on a mission to find this Penglai and an elixir
of life.
Instead though some historical text’s suggest
that he actually found Japan and the mountain
that would later be named Mount Fuji.
Continuing with our real world parallels,
both Eishu and Hojo, the other area’s of
the islands in Hells Paradise are the Japanese
names for two Chinese fantasy islands, both
Yingzhou and Fangzhang respectively.
Just love how much mythology and history is
weaved into this story, its truly fantastic
and just goes to show that Yuki really has
a great understanding of his own countries
past.
Anyways continuing forwards!
Gabi who still doesn't trust this dude asks
him if he’s ever seen the elixir, but Mr
Tree hasn't although he knows he benefits
from its effects.
Senta asks if he’s one of these immortals
then as he’s implied he’s been around
for 1000 years.
Sitting there the Tree just says that they
will encounter them sooner or later and once
they do their doubts will be erased.
For this man, Lord Tensen is, forever young,
undying, beauty incarnate, the perfect being.
At a similar time, remember how the brothers
bumped into a couple gender benders, WELL
it turns out that they are absolutely stuffed
as Lord Tensen was one or both of those beings
and took great pleasure in absolutely obliterating
the pathetic humans who stood in its way.
Yeah so like the tree man was implying, they
are kinda stuffed if they bump into this immortal
being.
Like Tōma and Chōbei were absolutely insane,
especially Chōbei the man didnt care what
he went up against, yet he was defeated in
a matter of moments.
After hearing about Lord Tensen, Gabimaru
and Yuzuriha point their weapons towards the
monster, believing that it wants them to die.
The monster corrects them and says that it
holds no hostility, only speaking the truth
about those who step onto the island.
Meanwhile, the mysterious being carries Tōma
and Chōbei before them down a pit of blooming
humans.
These beings are the commanders of the Soshin,
they pass judgment on mainly the sinful humans
who come to the island.
One dropped into this pit its said people
are reborn as beautiful blossoms freed from
the sin and earthly desires, granting them
everlasting bliss.
Those who eventually become one with the island
are the source of Tan.
The tree man proves that the elixir does indeed
exist by breaking a part of its hand and showing
Gabi’s crew that it can regenerate.
Gabimaru then points his sword towards the
girl wondering if she also benefits from the
elixir but Sagiri and Yuzuriha criticizes
him for his rude behavior, scolding him for
pointing a weapon at a child.
The tree man proceeds to explain that they
can choose to believe it or not, but this
is Shinsenkyo.
A land of Gods that fell down to this poor
state centuries ago.
Escape from the island is impossible and the
gods will be the ones to cast judgement on
them.
Meanwhile, Tenza and Nurugai who’ve been
out searching for an ocean current fail to
find one.
Since they need to come up with another strategy
they start to plan one, when all of a sudden
they’re approach by an unknown woman.
After noting that the forest is indeed full
of activity, she becomes angered by the amount
of Sōshin corpses she discovers on the island.
After asking if they were responsible, the
woman’s face begins morphing as it turns
into a man.
Feeling threaten, Tenza and Nurugai attempt
to run but the man instantly appears in front
of Tenza and strikes him with some form of
attack sonic boom attack.
As Tenza begins falling to the ground, the
godly being flashes in behind Nurugai and
tries to take her out aswell but luckily she
manages to jump back dodging the attack.
Tenza then appears in front of the creature
and slashes his eyes, however, its shown that
its utterly useless as they’d managed to
heal the damage.
Needing to make an opening to escape, Tenza
rapidly slashes away at the man, thinking
it'll allow them enough time to escape with
Nurugai.
Instantly though, the being heals and once
again appears right infront of Tenza.
Then coming in and seemingly saving the day,
the creature is caught off guard by the BLIND
KING Rank 4 Yamada Asaemon Shion's sword throw,
giving his fellow humans a moment to escape.
After getting far away from the man, Tenza
introduces Nurugai to his savior and genuine
blade master Yamada Asaemon Shion.
Slapping him on the head though, Shion scolds
Tenza for using only his speed in his swordplay
against his opponent, stating that he could
hear how messy his footwork was.
Wanting to know why he’s here now, Tenza
asks Shion what happened with his criminal.
Originally Shion was in charge of Akaginu,
but after she tried to seduce him, she paid
with her life.
Which is crazy hahaha, she just wanted a friend
dude.
Either way after leaving her, he managed to
find a current that could lead them away from
the island, however, he pointed out that he
sensed an unfamiliar presence and heard weird
noises.
Tenza says that the three of them should go
to the spot where he found the current, but
Shion raises his sword and asked why he was
helping his criminal.
Tenza explains that she was innocent, however
Shion literally isn't having it.
Before arriving on the island he memorized
every criminal with them and knows what they’ve
done.
Even though she’s not a criminal in both
of their eyes, it isn't up to them to decide
what wrong and right is.
It is the Era that they live in which decides
the crimes people commit.
Tenza rebuttals him and brings up how he himself
used to be just a wanderer without any purpose
in life.
There was no reason for Shion to save him
back then, yet he still decided to take him
off the street.
Now in a similar situation of his own Tenza
wanted to do the same for her as he see’s
a potential for her to live a real life in
the world.
Remembering the past and realizing just how
far Tenza had truly came from the day he meet
him, Shion is convinced and allows his student
to do as he pleases.
Nurugai greets her future husbands master
by calling him sensei to which Shion like
the goat he isn't, says she needn't call him
that since he had not taught her anything.
Wanting to quickly head back to the beach,
Shion tells Tenza to chill out as they need
to be caution of the mysterious being that
they just faced before.
Its best that instead of making themselves
a target they need to take their time and
come up with a strategy.
However, as Tenza begins to ponder what they
should do, the Godly thing drops down into
the middle of the forest now appearing as
a female and saying that they’ve underestimated
it.
Daddy Shion moves the two out of the way but
has his throat cut in the process.
Tenza fights back, yet he’s unable to hit
the creature at all as it dives in and out
of his swings.
Needing to make a stand, Tenza uses his ultimate
technique; Itto-Ryu Pounding Torrent.
Swinging his sword over and over again creating
an unescapable wave of slashes.
The female though is of a different skill
level and easily manages to weave through
all of his strikes before confronting him
directly stating that she’s accustomed to
his speed.
Tapping him 3 different times on the chest,
Tenza is sadly downed by another use of that
mysterious technique, leaving the other screaming
out for their falling ally.
Falling into a memory from his past, Tenza
recalls the time he asks Shion why he even
picked hi up off the street.
a young Tenza asked Shion why he picked him
off of the street.
Shion says that due to how his profession
is to end lives, he likes to help out others
and saw potential in him.
Back in the present, Tenza drops to his knee’s
and while looking at his palms realizes that
he’s currently dying from the previous attacks.
As the god stands over him, its obvious that
if he doesn't do something everyone else is
going to end up just like him.
SCREAMING he rises to his feet and attempts
to fights back throwing a fat right hook into
the face of the immortal creature.
He knows that this is probably it for him,
but he’ll do whatever he can now to make
enough time for the others to escape.
However, Tenza receives another fatal blow
to his stomach catching him by surprise.
With nothing left to do, battered and bruised
Tenza tries to telling Nurugai to run, but
he cant properly muster the strength to say
a word.
Luckily Shion was able to reach out and stop
Nurugai from trying to help.
Not wanting to leave his student alone and
unable to understand what Tenza is trying
to say, Shion takes his stand ready to save
his wounded friend.
Knowing that his sensei wont stand a chance,
Tenza tries to muster just one word to tell
him to leave or run away, but just like with
Nurugai, he’s unable to muster anything
but a shot gurgle.
Sensing something, Shion jumps back and stops
his assault before running away with Nurugai.
Back behind them, the legend himself Tenza
takes his final stand and hinders the immortal
foe’s attempts to chase the others.
Now deeper in the forest, his sensei screams
in pain while fleeing with Tenza’s chosen
disciple.
In his final moments, Tenza imagines what
his life could have been like in the future,
seeing himself possibly teaching a bunch of
young students or drinking with all of his
buddies on a beautiful day.
Over with the others as they flee, Nurugai
screams and hits Shion wanting to know why,
why is he leaving Tenza behind.
With his throat starting to recover, he explains
that he was honoring Tenza's last wishes.
Tenza knew that they wouldn't be able to defeat
these creatures they way they are now and
if they stayed they all would've shared the
same fate.
Retreat was the only way, however he states
that this debt will be paid, before they flee
the island they will beat it.
Meanwhile, as Gabi prepares to take a bath,
him and Sagiri think back on the moments earlier.
They know that both Mei and the tree who goes
by Hoko were born and raised on the island.
They’ve lived here for centuries and only
wish to live in peace.
Senta the big brain also knows that in China’s
Shenxian beliefs, Tensen refers to an elite
type of mystical hermit.
These Soshin and Hōrai are also words originating
from the Tao, so its fair to say that they’re
probably telling them the truth about the
island.
In mainland China’s history Tensen was a
term made up by the Jin Dynasty scholar Ge
Hong.
Its simply a classification for the highest
class of immortals or hermits.
Now in the bath house, Sagiri takes note of
just how many wounds Gabimaru has sustained
since getting to the island.
Looking at Mei she also see’s this massive
scar or some kind of strange marking that
travels up the majority of her back.
While washing himself, Gabimaru remembers
a time his wife washed his back and gave him
advice about to properly relax his body.
She reminded him on how if he didnt take the
opportunity to relax then he’s bound to
collapse in the the real battle they call
life.
In times of peace, stick to your convictions,
wear them proudly at times or conceal them
at others..
But never let go of what truly makes you,
you.
For life is far far longer than even the battle
of Kawanakajima.
Damn I love how poetic Yuki is with his story
and it makes me wanna learn Japanese as I
know for a fact that the story would be so
much more in-depth in a language that is artistically
based.
For example this battle Yui referred to was
actually the site of five or possibly six
different battles that happened in the waring
states period between 1553 and 1564.
If ya wanna check out the actual location,
its situated near present day Nagano.
The battles between commanders Takeda Shingen
and Uesugi Kenshin have becomes some of the
most romanticized pieces of Japanese history,
giving rise to retellings, reimagining's in
script, artistic representations and even
movies.
After remembering how he told her that she
shouldn’t cover her scar with her hair,
he gives the same advice to Mei about the
marking on her back, saying he knows this
lady with a bid scar across her face and shes
the prettiest girl around.
As both girls take this new side of Gabi in,
it causes Mei to becomes star struck wanting
to stay by his side.
Leaving the bath house now and as the three
walk back to Hoko’s residence, Sagiri notices
that Gabimaru is truly starting to change.
At the same time Gabimaru reminds himself
why exactly he’s here.
He’d managed to get a breather in and finally
remembered those feelings of his, but his
priority isn't to bath around.
No its to make it home and save his wife from
her tyrannical father.
Inside Hoko’s house Senta who’s literally
fried his brain after gather so much information
insists that they should spend the night here
as there’s still so much to unravel.
Sagiri tells him that he should rest now but
Senta who’s overheating insisted he’d
be able to keep watch after he takes a bath.
However, once outside and on guard duty he
falls asleep with Gabimaru, who’s chilling
next to him.
Sitting there overthinking everything thats
happened so far, Gabimaru decided that it
would be better to head out alone to Hōrai,
before their enemy makes its move against
them.
As Gabimaru rushes for Hōrai, he sees a number
of immobile tree creatures chanting strange
sutras amongst the fog.
While walking along, he wonders if they’re
praying and thinks back on how Senta said
its probably dangerous to act before they
know what's really going on.
Even though Gabi knows that this could be
the most dangerous place in the world, if
he doesn't press on then there is absolutely
no chance he’ll ever see his wife.
Stopping for a moment though, he wonders how
in the world he’s even gonna know when he
arrives at Hōrai, its not like the Homeland
with road signs.
At the same time an unknown person is seen
following him.
Pressing forward, Gabimaru comes to find a
massive gate.
Remembering what Hōko said about Hōrai being
a place of splendor, he believes this is where
the Hermits and the elixir reside.
Just as he goes to enter the area, he stops
still noticing something behind him...
Coming face to face, both Gabimaru and the
same mysterious being who just took out Tenza
stare into each others eyes.
Randomly it becomes saddened by his presence
and drops to its asking him to leave, explaining
that she had already dealt with capturing
another group of humans today.
Hearing this flicks a switch in our boys head
and he immediately realizes just from her
statement alone that she turns people into
the Elixir of Life.
After seeing each other as a threat, the two
engage in battle, jumping straight for each
other.
Gabimaru lands 2 successive blows on the woman
and comes to the conclusion that she wasn't
human after regenerating her wounds.
Turning things up a notch, he flips back into
a handstand spinning flame kick that lands
directly on the face of the immortal being.
He then activates the ability and uses Ninpō:
Fire Monk to completely incinerates her.
With the creature smoldering below him Gabimaru
noted that it was far to strong to even consider
questioning, when all of a sudden the godly
being darts straight back out with its charred
body and lands a direct hit on Gabimaru, sending
him shooting up into the sky.
Phasing into the sky in an instant, it then
lands yet another kick to the gut of the Ninja.
Thinking that its destroyed the human it reforms
its normal male shell, but is perplexed when
he see’s Gabimaru standing there asking
if he was Lord Tensen.
In a display of skill yet unseen in the series
both Gabimaru and the being known as Lord
Tensen continue fighting in Hōrai.
Coming to a standstill for a moment Gabi asks
where the elixir is, before diving straight
back in and throwing another series of kicks
and punches.
He notes that all of the damage he’s inflicting
is pretty much useless as its regenerative
ability is just too fast.
Trading blows with this thing is just like
Rokurōta, its only going to result in certain
death.
What he needs is a strategy thats actually
going to hurt it, ascetic blaze didnt work
so he opts for a technique he hasn't tried
so far.
He throws a swift kick to the gut or tanden
and notices that the impact felt different
from before.
Somehow it actually did some form of damage
causing Lord Tensen to coughs up blood and
transform into a woman.
(Btw when ever they change into a woman, oml
I have to do so much body modifications so
there isn't any thing sus going on, Yuki himself
goes ham with his art style and its amazing
I just wish they wore tops more often hahaha)
Tensen tells Gabi that he’s probably not
even aware of what he just did and changes
into another fighting form that we haven't
seen so far.
Becoming enraged it tells him to die before
sending what seems to be invisible sonic energy
waves that deal an insane amount of damage.
Not understanding what in the world just happened,
Gabi becomes overwhelmed as Lord Tensen sends
out a barrage of attacks that leave our boy
with physically no way to block.
Unable to counter Gabimaru just throws away
any idea of even trying to defend and grits
his teeth before charging at the immortal
creature.
He gets within throwing hands range and begins
doing his thing, man knows that if he survives
he gets home.
End of story thats it thats what's going to
happen, even with parts of himself missing
he will make it home.
He speeds his attacks up through pure grit
and somehow manages to gain the upper hand,
before beating the false god down into the
ground, defeating it.
After being defeated, Gabimaru tells it to
talk as he wants to find that damn elixir.
However, Lord Tensen smiles and as its body
begins to bloom flowers it states that "they"
would be furious with it again.
In that moment, Tensen loses its natural shape
and morphs into a massive monster made up
of those previously blooming flowers.
After the Lord Tensen transforms, Gabimaru
calms himself and tries to think up a strategy.
However, the transformed immortal unleashes
uncontrollable bolts of lightning towards
that blitz the entire area and badly wounding
Gabi.
Throwing a massive boulder aside, Gabi doesn't
hesitate and darts back in trying to land
some form of hit on the monster but its utterly
useless as he’s blasted back once more.
Lying in a head of rubble he tries activating
Ascetic Blaze, yet its once again useless
as his body freezes up on him, making him
to realize that he’s already reached his
limit and has no stamina left at all.
Being unable to move the monster overwhelms
Gabimaru causing him to wonder if this is
real, or if this has all just been on long
nightmare.
Waking up randomly in his house, his wife
lets him know that he’d been tossing and
tuning possibly having some kind of bad dream.
Breaking down, Gabi tells her that he had
the worst nightmare he’s ever had.
As time passes we see Gabi chilling on his
veranda while his wife brings him some dream
warding tea.
Looking at her, he says that even if this
is a dream, its wonderful that he was able
to talk to her again.
With her becoming confused, Gabi apologizes
as he knows that there is a chance he’s
never going to see her again.
Sadly back in the present Gabi re-awakens
in the grasp of the monster moments before
it seemingly crushes him.
Nah nah nah though Gabi aint done, instead
what we thought was our boy dying was infact
him starting his last ditch effort while remembering
a specific Ninja principle.
Ironclad Ninja Law #20 “Should death be
upon you, in the moments before your doom,
inflict grievous damage upon the foe that
would wring the life from you.”
Bursting into flames once more, Gabi knows
that when facing death, he has to surrender
everything, even his subconscious.
Having activated Ninpō: Fire Monk Gabimaru
eventually burns through the monsters grip,
causing him to fall onto the ground below.
Not having the strength to get back up Gabimaru
just thinks of his wife and apologizes for
not being able to make it home.
Randomly though Mei then appears besides Gabimaru
and helps him escape by creating a crater
using her mysterious ability allowing them
to safely slide down the cliff.
Enraged the monster attempts to attack the
two with its lightning but fails to hit them
before they flee.
Reverting back to normal, Tensen just wonders
what was the reason for Mei's actions.
Inside of Hōrai all of these mysterious rulers
that each in their own can also be called
Lord Tensen, are gathered for a meeting about
the humans that landed on the island.
Ju Fa which is one of the names for these
creatures, becomes angry with Zhu Jin for
failing his guard duties and being reduced
to a Kishikai state, stating that he used
to much Tao.
He violently attacks him but is quickly scolded
by the leader for causing harm to a fellow
family member.
He brings up that they can only punish those
which they serve and because of that only
he man harm Zhu Jin.
Putting the failure that is Zhu Jin aside,
he asks Ju Fa for any information on the humans
they’ve encountered so far.
Ju relays on how he dropped both Chōbei and
Tōma into one of the pits, which in there
eyes is far to deep for any human to climb
out of.
(Massive foreshadowing I think so hahahah)
Mu Dan whos tryna take the role of a boss
here advises them to not underestimate the
humans.
If it had been just the Soshin that was taken
out, it would've been no big deal, but since
they managed to slay a Mōnshin things seem
different about these humans.
He brings up a terrifying possibility, that
say they were to escape the pit Ju threw them
in, then there would be nothing more fearsome
than a wounded beast.
Plus if every other human on the island wielded
the same kind of strength then that might
truly face a terrible beast.
Unbeknownst to these goons, thats exactly
what's going on.
The leader then asked Zhu Jin if he they’d
successfully won the battle they had last
night, which he was certain.
The seven then make a toast to longevity and
Zhu Jin is restored to his normal form.
So what they mean by Kishikai like I think
I mentioned earlier is the monstrous plant
form that they evolve into under great stress,
which also is a representation of Yin and
Yang.
It literally means ‘demon corpse undo’
and is a concept inspired by Ge Hong's weakest
immortal hermit form the Shijie Xian.
From what i've seen a lot of the story dives
into the more Chinese mythological side of
things and especially stuff from this Ge Hong
fellow.
Anyways
Meanwhile, Senta apologies to Sagiri for accidently
letting Gabimaru leave his sight the previous
night.
Hoko brings up that its almost impossible
for any ordinary human to travel through the
mist, but Sagiri believes that if he did indeed
set out, he may have actually found a way
to navigate the area and if thats the case
they need to find him at once.
Yuzuriha disagrees as its not like they’ve
got time to spare themselves and wondered
why Sagiri was even concerned about Gabimaru.
Hōko interrupts and offers to guide them
through the mist, seeing as how Mei left he
has to go find her.
Hearing this, Yuzuriha switches up and is
persuaded into finding Gabimaru.
Once they leave, Sagiri notes that with Gabi
having run off its now beyond the scope of
her duties, still she cant help but hope he’s
okay.
Elsewhere Gabimaru awakens with Mei beside
him and immediately comes to the conclusion
that the thing he just fought was no god,
just a living breathing monster.
Pleased with the realization he stands ready
to figure out a way to defeat the beast.
From the battle so far its obvious to him
that he cant do it alone, but with two, three,
four or even more comrades it might be possible.
In that moment he notices another two newcomers
appear behind him.
After encountering Tamiya Gantetsusai and
Yamada Asaemon Fuchi, Gabimaru and Gantetsusai
go back and forth both predicting each other’s
actions in their heads before they make a
move in the actual battle.
Stepping in-between the two Fuchi ceases their
pointless imaginary battle and instead plans
to extract information from Gabimaru.
Having honed a special ability since he was
young that allows him to recognize someone's
strength at a glace, Gabimaru decides to sit
down and request an alliance with the two.
Gantetsusai draws his sword and swings it
at Gabi to see if he was trying to trick them
but after the previously hollow man didnt
flinch at all, figured he was telling the
truth.
Still he felt disappointed with him showing
just how week he was and told Gabi that he
wasn't looking for cowards who’d bow to
an enemy.
Either way Fuchi asks to hear him out, wanting
to know why the infamous Gabimaru would go
this far.
Going over everything that happened to him
up until this point, both Fuchi and Gantetsusai
especially intrigued to hear about this random
Lord Tensen fellow.
Fuchi who’s just blown away with Gabi’s
explanation asks how it was able to regenerate
and was there any signs it had internal organs.
Not knowing every detail exactly, Gabimaru
says that he’s honestly not even sure what
happened, he just needs to earn that pardon
and get back to a certain someone.
So the more people there are to help the more
likely it will happen.
Just as intrigued himself, Gantetsusai agrees
to teaming up and tells him that he had no
interest in the pardon but rather to become
a legendary figure that will live forever.
Confused because that obviously means the
dude still wants the Elixir, Gantetsusai reiterates
that literal immortality would get boring
fast.
What he wants is to be able to preform feats
that shake the earth, then that way the name
Tamiya Gantetsusai will live on
for eternity.
Screaming to the sky he tells the gods themselves
to believe it, one day they’ll paint pictures
and write tales about his strength.
Fuchi who thinks his criminals absolutely
lost his mind also agrees after learning that
an undying organism exist.
Having come to their agreement, Fuchi asks
Gabi to spill the beans on what he knows.
Agreeing, he goes to start off with Mei and
explain her, yet as soon as he looks at her
he’s shocked to see that she’s grown a
few years in age.
Fuchi asked why Gabimaru was shocked, to which
he explains that Mei has aged for some reason.
Then after hearing her speak for the first
time, Gabimaru quickly rushed in and grabbed
her asking if she was the same as Tensen and
for more information on the elixir.
Noticing how forward he was being, Gabi stepped
back and thanked her for everything so far,
but also questions as to why she couldn't
speak up until now.
At the same time Yuzuriha curiously asked
Hōko what in the world Lord Tensen was.
Finally its explained to us absolutely confused
readers that Lord Tensen is infact 7 different
immortals.
According to Legend its possible that it used
to be one immortal being, but its unsure as
so much has changed throughout the historical
texts.
Whats known is that there the Supreme Shandi
Samantabhadra, Heavenly Dadi Aksho, Enthroned
Juijun Amoghavajra, Sagacious Dasheng Ratna,
Regnant Yuanjun Tathata, Decorous Gonggong
Manjusri, and Deified Dijun Cundi.
Apparently the great hermit over 1000 years
ago reached enlightenment, achieved deification
and thus split themselves seven fold.
The immortal beings appearance and voice are
shared between them, but they all vary in
personality and the role they take.
Like Senta mentioned in the first part on
how it was a poor mix up or religions and
cultures, these names are exactly the same.
They combine titles from Chinese culture and
Mythology mixed in with unrelated Buddhist
deities and their concepts.
Funnily enough in the Japanese versions of
the story they use the Japanese pronunciations
for these people.
Whereas in my video (bar my pronunciation)
and in the English translation it uses the
accepted spellings from each specific language.
The tree man also reveals that everyone of
the island was once human with abnormally
long life spans in comparison to the average
man.
Yet even still with their long lives, there
prosperity ended after 1000 years and eventually
everyone hit arborfication.
Once someone does begin turning they only
have a limited amount of time before their
mind goes blank and they travel to Hōrai
to sit in the Zazen pose and chant strange
sutra’s.
Hearing this information, Senta objects to
Hoko’s previous statement on the island
being Shinsenkyo and believes that its more
likely based around a man-made religion.
Words like, ‘Hōrai’, ’Eishu’, ‘Zazen’
and even lord Tensen’s titles all relate
to existing different religious spheres.
Consider the physical remains of statues all
scattered about the place, all of them reflect
very real human religions.
Due to all of this he cant accept that this
island is cut off from the real world as some
sort of spiritual realm isolated for over
a 1000 years.
He tells Yuzuriha to remember Moro and how
he was originally arrested for trying to overthrow
the shogunate by founding a new religion altogether.
Just like his weird religion, the one that
they’ve discovered here is also made up
from a distortion of different faiths.
In his mind, Hoko’s stories have only supported
his theory that this island and everything
inside of it, including them being lured to
the island, are all the works of a mysterious
creator.
With his explanation in mind, Yuzuriha believes
that its pretty much impossible to stop someone
who’s been planning everything behind the
scenes for over 1000 years and assumes Gabimaru
and Mei are already dead from even trying
to approach it.
However, Sagiri believes that Gabimaru is
very much alive and is already formulating
a plan of action as no matter what he will
see his wife once more.
Shheeeesh even Sagiri on that Gabi wife hype
train now.
Well I cant blame her, though yeah at this
point the idea of them taking on these immortal
opponents and winning seems so foreign.
Anyway Anyways!
Back with Gabi, he inquires as to how in the
world Mei saved him back there.
Mei who cant speak properly tries to tell
him that it was Tao (said Dow), weak strong
spirit, leaving the group confused with what
she's trying to say.
Fuchi brings up that the Tanden which was
one of the words she said could be related
to the flow of Qi or chakra, but cant say
for sure.
This here is obviously another aspect that
a lot of stories, Naruto for example kinda
delve into, yet with Hells Paradise’s botched
world, the Kanji for Tanden is translated
directly as Elixir Of Life and or Field.
On the other-hand Hoko explains to the girls
that Tao is the energy that flows through
everything.
Everything that exists comes from the never
ending flow of Tao and if someone is able
to tap into that flow then it could allow
them to meddle with creation itself.
Elsewhere Shion and Nurugai go through some
training exercises.
After getting absolutely blitzed by the blind
king, Nurugai pleads with him to explain his
swordsman, but he refuses her as he just couldn't
bear to watch another student fall before
his eyes.
Not pleased, Nurugai tells him that she can
sense he isn't any ordinary guy, there was
someone in there clan who could see with sound,
but the level Shion’s on is almost otherworldly
in comparison.
So the reason big Shion is able to merc people
while blind is because just like taste or
smell, all things in this world possess unique
waves and thats exactly what he’s able to
perceive.
The technique is so refined he’s even able
to tell exactly what Nurugai’s hairstyle
looks like, yet there isn't any said name
for the ability so he just calls them waves.
So mastery over Tao allows the user to not
only sense things, but it boosts their physical
abilities to the same level as a god.
Tapping into the power requires an extremely
balanced spirit, so remember the stuff Mei
was trying to say, well the strong, weak more
or less meant a balanced spirit.
Once someone achieves mastery over the ever
flowing cycles between rage and serenity then
they will begin to sense the waves.
According to Buddhist texts its called the
middle way, the state of being able to draw
out a power that exceeds your natural potential.
Asking what the right wave is then, Shion
gives her an example of how he activates the
technique.
He explains everything from his stance to
how he holds the blade and the feeling that
he gets while wielding the blade.
With a bunch of Soshin rolling up behind Shion
he displays just exactly what he sees.
Tapping into all of the specific waves it
reveals a dark world made up of white waves
weaving in and out of the darkness creating
the creatures and landscape around him.
Lashing out Shion easily takes down every
single monster, all the while explaining to
Nurugai what goes into the use of the technique.
As they both begin taking on the remaining
creatures together, he tells Nurugai that
he still refuses to become her teacher but
she is free to learn as much as she wants.
Elsewhere Gabimaru's group is also ambushed
by a large amount of Sōshin.
Stepping forth and in one freaking massive
swing Gantetsusai takes out the first wave
of creatures with ease.
He knows he wants to learn this Tao thing,
but sitting around in lessons is just to damn
boring for the beast.
He teases Gabi for how beat up he’s gotten
since making land fall and tells him that
they need to learn in the heat of battle.
With all of the so called training dummies
infront of him he asks Mei to jump down and
give them a few examples of Tao.
Though as he does so Gabimaru notices an unfamiliar
presence amongst the Sōshin.
Remember that pit Chōbei and Tōma were in,
so that thing there was created by Lord Tensen
in order to assimilate any human dropped inside,
making them one with the flowers.
From that they are able to extract something
called Tan, or more simply the elixir of life.
If anyone tries to escape those pits of theirs,
which is almost impossible due to just how
deep it is, then the walls themselves will
hinder them.
Still its shown that their pits weren't enough
for the demon brothers who somehow managed
to climb their way out.
After escaping, Tōma suggests leaving the
island but Chōbei angrily declares that he
will take revenge on the two that put them
there.
Man doesn't even need a strategy, as from
the first battle he figured out their weakness
was the lower halves of their bodies.
After trying to offer Tōma a piece of flesh
to eat from the pit, the two brothers are
taken off-guard when a random monster rolls
up as if its apart of their conversation.
Not meaning to frighten them, the random looking
thing dressed in a Chinese outfit tells them
to not lash out as it posses some form of
intelligence.
Instead of fighting, they should talk.
So this thing here is used for scouting purposes
and a bunch of them have been sent out to
all of the still alive humans on the island.
Unlike the Soshin which are incomplete beings
that lack any thought or emotion and aren't
even allowed inside Hōrai or the Mōnshin
who act as guards for area.
They are the Doshi, direct disciples of lord
Tensen who posses intellect and are taught
directly by 1 of the 7.
The Dōshi explains that he was ordered to
assure that they were still in the pit becoming
Tan while his other comrades were out locating
the other humans on the island.
He then asked for the two to return to the
pit however Chōbei responds by diving forth
and attacking the creature.
Easily dodging a slow blow by the Doshi, Chōbei
lashes out disarming the monster and causing
it to jump backwards.
Knowing that this thing is in touch with Tensen,
Chōbei demands that he tell him everything
about those freaks but the Dōshi refuses
calling him a foolish idiot.
Bringing in some backup, it commands the Soshin
to take out the humans so he can return them
to the pit.
Chōbei orders Tōma to fight off the Sōshin
while he handles fighting the Dōshi.
As the two continue to scuffle, its revealed
that Chōbei's attacks are causing almost
no harm to the Dōshi because he doesn't wield
Tao.
This leaves a perfect opening for the Doshi
to fatally wound Chōbei, striking him in
the face, causing him to fall face first onto
the ground below.
Seeing his bro fall down, Tōma becomes horrified
screaming out his name.
Getting up he runs at the Doshi who’s taunting
him, when all of a sudden Chōbei re-opens
his eyes.
Doshi leans down to drag him back to the pit,
when simultaneously Chōbei awakens and spins
on the floor facing his opponent before striking
a blow directly to his face.
Looking at his brother Chōbei tells Tōma
to return to fighting the fodder losers while
he deals with this feign.
The Dōshi notices that Chōbei's throat has
regenerated from the previous damage and while
baffled deduces that during his time in the
pit he must’ve been affected by the vines
that infused some kind of Tan into him.
Looking at him some more, The Doshi takes
note that its probably the case since his
Tao has changed shape in such a short period
of time.
Realizing just how dangerous he could be if
Chōbei isn't dealt with now, he re-ignites
the battle against the newly evolved human.
Instantly he breaks his arms by manipulating
the Tao around his body, but just as quickly
Chōbei manages to regenerate them and strike
back.
The Dōshi questions whether Chōbei feared
losing his humanity after his transformation
but the demon brother states that he couldn't
care as nothing in this world is set in stone.
Fixing his statement he says that no there
is one thing that never changes thats always
current, but pointed out that someone like
him wouldn't understand where he was coming
from.
He charges forward, asking to see more of
this new power, yet this time he’s actually
able to visualize what Doshi’s invisible
attacks look like.
He then strikes the monsters navel, causes
damage and showing proof to him that weakness
does indeed lie within the stomach.
These Doshi fellow are kinda like the messengers
and personal assistants to the Tensen.
The word that they originate from, ‘Doshi
or Daoshi’ in Chinese is a blanket term
that refers to Taoist priests, monks and masters.
As Chōbei’s Tao begins to grow larger and
larger the Dōshi becomes frightened, trying
to call forth the Sōshin to save him, but
sadly for our little Doshi its shown that
the other bro managed to dispose of all of
them.
Willing the little Tao he has left, the Doshi
creates some kind of energy orb, but is unable
to use it as his hand is crushed by Chōbei.
Staring into the terrified soul of this pathetic
creature, Chōbei states that he now knows
how he manipulates his Tao.
Its simple, he brings it in from the environment
around him.
With nothing left to do Chōbei activates
the exact same ability the Doshi just used,
perplexing the creature who thought it was
impossible.
Now seeing the waves of Tao in a similar way
to that of Shion, Chōbei smiles knowing just
how weak his enemy is, before finally dealing
the finishing blow.
While Chōbei begins integrating what's left
of the Doshi creature, Tōma looks closely
at the markings on his neck and notices that
they are spreading.
Snapping his head towards his brother, Tōma
gets frightened by Chōbei but soon comes
out of the daze he found himself in.
Walking in to help tie up the Doshi Tōma
takes an even closer look at Chōbei's neck
and notices that his scars look plant like.
Meanwhile, while fighting off the Sōshin,
Gantetsusai asks Mei if he was starting to
understand Tao, but Mei shakes her head in
disagreement, saying that he was focusing
too much on his strength.
Looking at over at his fierce rival who’s
absolutely destroying the other Sōshin, he
asks if he was starting to understand Tao.
Just like himself though Mei also states that
he was also focusing too much of strength.
Fuchi who’s off to the side examining the
remains of the creatures becomes delighted
with his inspection of the Sōshin's anatomy
and relays the information to Gabimaru.
He finds it odd that even creatures who share
the same outward appearance have completely
different anatomical structures.
From that alone he’s able to deduce that
each opponent they go up against has its own
weak point, however that doesn't exactly explain
what Mei is aswell.
After remembering how she helped him escape
Gabimaru comes to the realization that no
ordinary human would have been able to pull
of the feat she did when they escaped.
Funnily he intently looks towards her wondering
what she is, but as Mei see’s him it causes
her to break down and begin crying for a fourth
time.
This always gets me but as Gabi and Gantetsusai
continue taking out the fodder Soshin, he
asks Tamiya if he was married aswell and the
big man lets him know that he has wives all
over the continent.
King.
Taken by surprise Gantetsusai then blocks
a sneak attack by a Dōshi.
Trying to strike back he swings his hook arm
towards the creature but sadly he was unable
to stop it from weaving between his attack
and taking Mei off his shoulder.
Now back a fair distance from the main group,
the Dōshi greets Mei in a polite manner,
stating that they had been searching for her
in secret for centuries.
After she vanished from Hōrai it caused the
Doshi to fall into despair as they were unable
to search for her publicly due to Lord Reins
orders.
Now that they’ve finally re-united he begs
her to return to Hōrai as they are in grave
need of her aid.
(hmm so I wonder what in the world could Mei
possibly be or the relation that she has to
the immortals in Hōrai.
What do the Doshi need her for so desperately
and who in the world is the Lord Rien fellow.
Still so many questions.
Ofcourse with us being like almost a third
through the story here Id love to know your
thought on it down below.
I find some things get repeated quite a lot
but thats always going to be the case when
you have a few different groups all needing
to learn the same information.
So hopefully I was able to slim the repeat
info down here and make it more concise.
Though they way Yuki does it where he swaps
around between characters as he’s explaining
parts of the world is really damn good.
Its hard to script in a way that doesn't sound
whack, but world building wise and visually
this man is cracked out of his mind, so I
cant wait so see what other series he decides
to release in the future.)
Wanting to know what in the worlds going on,
Gabimaru insists the Doshi tell them what
Mei is.
Firstly it tells them that it is non of their
concern as Mei is not supposed to be near
humans.
Yet since they helped with her return it says
that she is similar to Lord Tensen, one nourished
by the lives of humans.
Finding out that she isn't human pushes Gabi
to the edge because he knows that getting
caught up in something he doesn't understand
will only result in death.
He needs to remember why he took this mission,
but after seeing the tears beginning to fall
from Mei’s face, he rushes to her side and
puts himself in-between her and the Doshi
creature.
He knows that acting on impulse is usually
the last thing he would do, yet despite not
having any association with her he cant bear
to make her cry again.
Furious with his interference, the Dōshi
partners himself with another similar looking
goon and declares that they will turn them
into Tan and retrieve Mei if thats truly the
case.
After noticing the second Dōshi's appearance
and how it manipulates the bugs around them,
Gantetsusai realizes he’s the mofo that
made him lose a hand, he’s the butterfly
boss.
Watching the two Dōshi summon a swarm of
their respective insects, Gabi quickly comes
to the conclusion that they’re able to manipulate
the insects around them.
Before he could strategize any further though,
Gantetsusai steps in an cuts down the butterflies
and states that he seeks revenge on the Butterfly
Dōshi for causing him to lose his left hand.
He lunges in for another attack angered by
the fact he’s had to refine his swordstyle
but is hit by and invisible attack by the
Centipede Dōshi that grazes the side of his
face.
Initiating a close hand battle, the two Doshi
charge forth, pushing our boys back into a
defensive fight.
Bugs weave in and out of the battle field
in combination with the Doshi, blocking their
vision and causing them to accidentally hit
each other.
With the boys bickering between each other,
the second Doshi, which is the dude controlling
the centipedes asks as to why they wanted
to protect Mei despite not having any connections
with her.
Gabimaru knows that if it was the old him
he would've just left as soon as possible.
But now wonders as to why he’s begun changing
ever since he landed on the island.
Accepting this as the new him, he replies
to the creature that he was just repaying
a debt.
He then flipped the conversation back on the
Doshi curious as to why their so fixated on
a girl that doesn't want to leave with them.
The Centipede Dōshi explains that his kind
train themselves in the way of Tao, just like
Lord Tensen.
For them Mei is a key component to their training
in the ways of Tao.
There are 5 ascetic methods to train ones
body in Tao.
(That makes me wonder if Gabi’s Ascetic
form is also one of these 5 methods or something)
Do’in, Taisoku, Shu’itsu and Shuten are
the first four and they you can train them
all by yourself.
However the most impost of all, is hot steamy
Bochu Jutsu which as you can probably pick
up on demands a partner of opposite gender.
This is due to how I brought up earlier in
the video, for the cycle of yin and yang to
complete it demands intimate congress.
These 5 meditation methods come from real
life Chinese history thru both Taoist and
qigong practices.
All things inside of this world posses Chi
of either a Yin or Yang affinity, even those
that do not live.
The higher levels of a specific affinity will
result in an even greater level of Tao when
someone performs Bochu Jutsu.
Do’in, Taisoku and similar things will prepare
someone's body and mind, but the method to
join both is thru Bochu Jutsu.
Those who’re able to hone their Tao thru
this method unlock the ability to reshape
the fabric of reality.
Lord Tensen has apparently achieved this level
of power and is now an ascended being in which
the entire Yin and Yang cycle flows unbroken.
Thus it has been this way for the past 1000
years as Lord Tensen manifests the ultimate
Tao.
The reason the need Mei is because the Doshi
are made up of Yang energy and in order for
them complete their training they require
Mei's assistants since she possess Yin energy.
Mei in their eyes is a failure as one of the
Tensen as instead of possesing both Yin and
Yang, Mei was only able to produce the Yin
aligned chi.
Therefore Lord Rien banished her from the
palace and offered her 2 different options.
Either she could pass away back then or like
she chose, reforge herself from the start
as their training partner.
Yeah thats messed up.
Im purposefully not going into depth on certain
aspects of things or showing half the panels,
otherwise the video will be taken down and
I want it to stay up.
The reality of the situation is just sad,
I can fully understand why Mei wanted to break
down after being threatened within going back,
thats all im gonna say.
Hearing all this both Gabimaru and Gantetsusai
becomes disgusted with this information.
Angered Tamiya tells him that hell take on
the Centipede creep, but looking at his boy
he’s blown away to see just how enraged
he is.
Stepping and asking if she's marked? he tells
them to stop with their rude explanation of
Mei and treat her like a normal person, not
an object.
Not bothered with the threats of a human,
The Dōshi's transform into their Shikai form
and declare that they will kill them on the
spot.
Gantetsusai makes the first attack, jumping
up and swinging at the Butterfly Dōshi who
retaliates by sending a swarm after him.
He notices that they’re easier to attack
when bunched up, but gets caught off-guard
by the powder coming off the butterflies’.
Slowly becoming dizzy he asks for Gabimaru's
assistants but gets told to deal with it by
himself as he’s just as busy with fighting
the Centipede Dōshi.
Shooting out an attack itself, the Doshi uses
a similar blast to lord Tensen to push Gabimaru
back.
Yelling to his teammate, Gantetsusai lets
him know that the butterflies are dangerous.
Hearing him Gabimaru uses Ninpo; Pyro Bridge
to expels a torrent of fire that seemingly
burns all of the butterflies and soaks the
Doshi in a cloak of flames.
Looking at his enemy, Gabi realizes that he
won't stand a chance unless he finds a way
to sense Tao.
Yooo so remember Fuchi who’s chilling with
Mei in the middle of this, well, after interpreting
her words from earlier, Fuchi yells out to
Gabimaru telling him that he’s focusing
to much on strength.
To perceive Tao your heart must accept both
strength and weakness and unless he accepts
his weakness, he won't learn it.
Mei also helped Fuchi sense his own Tao by
touching his hand and giving a demonstration
on how she uses it.
Gabimaru tries doing the same with her, but
once she activates her Tao he can only slightly
feel something however thats it he cant see
it.
Yet, After hearing Mei state in her own weird
way that weakness gives birth to strength,
Gabimaru is reminded of Sagiri's words and
how his love for his wife that he thought
was a weakness is actually a strength.
Finally understanding what this strong weak
is that Mei keeps going on about, Gabimaru
watches some form of glowing energy appear
around his hand.
Stepping forth towards the heat of battle
the previously hollow man tells Fuchi that
he thinks he gets the gist of it now.
Watching him walk ahead of them, Mei notices
just how large Gabimaru’s Tao truly is.
Having felt the sensation from before, Gabimaru
is now able to see the invisible attacks from
the Dōshi's and dodges them.
Blown away with just how quickly he caught
on, Gantetsusai states that its probably due
to the specific training he went through as
a member of Iwagakure.
Apparently the people there even have otherworldly
moves and inhuman forms that they can take
on at a moments notice.
Its likely that its not exactly Tao but possible
the techniques are based on similar principles
however Mei shakes her head in disagreement.
As he continues to fight the Centipede Dōshi,
Gabimaru begins to understand how Tao works
and begins perceiving everything around him,
not just the stronger aura’s but also the
weak and dying ones.
He also manages to understand why he perceived
Sagiri as such a terrifying force.
Even with all of her doubt, she still pushes
forth making her a strong person.
With the Centipede Doshi throwing a fat right
hook towards Gabimaru, our boy just puts his
hand out and simply blocks the strike.
Being able to distinguish every single insect
apart that makes up the monsters form, he
reverses the polarity of the monsters Tao
exploding the arm of its Shikai form.
Now with the upper hand, Gabi darts up and
screams that the pathetic Doshi no longer
stands a chance.
Spinning in midair Gabi lands a fat kick that
pushes the creature completely out of its
Shikai form.
Feeling gassed up, Gabimaru tells the Centipede
Dōshi that he’s ready to throw some hands
with their master.
Laying there on the ground after being defeated,
the Dōshi compares Gabimaru's abilities to
that of Lord Tensen blown away with just how
accurate he was.
Annoyed Gabimaru demands that the Dōshi tell
him who he was working with and where can
he find Lord Tensen.
Seeing no other option the Dōshi explains
that itself along with two other Dōshi's
were ordered by Lord Tensen to observe the
humans that arrived on the island.
They were to discover how this new group differed
to those that had landfall in the past.
Mainly though it was to asses if leaving the
humans alone would suffice or if they could
present a threat.
Wanting to make the final blow, Gantetsusai
swoops in to steal the day.
With Gabimaru turning around to look at him,
the two Doshi use their abilities to attack
our boy while his guard was down.
Gabi though having achieved bliss, perceives
the attacks and quickly manages to jump off
Gantetsusai towards the butterfly Doshi.
Falling down on the other one, Gabi uses his
Ninpo: Stone Storm to pepper his opponent
while simultaneously Tamiya Gantetsusai kill
the Centipede Dōshi.
With Tao still a mystery to him, Gabimaru
figures if he experiments more with it he
can find a way to cause damage to his enemies.
Since they cant question the dead Doshi, Fuchi
considers asking Mei for more information
but Gantetsusai thinks it would be best for
her to return home.
Having saved his life twice, Gabimaru wanted
to repay his debt to Mei by going along with
whatever she wanted to do.
Knowing of the notes that Sagiri had written
on Gabi before the mission begun, Fuchi notices
that his behavior is different from what she
interpreted and wonders if this new soft side
will help him on his mission.
Suddenly though Gabimaru begins bleeding from
the nose before collapsing to the ground confusing
everyone around him.
This is for the fact that Tao is life force
itself, to employ it in battle is to eat away
at ones life.
Using to much will cause the backlash to not
only effect someone's body but even their
soul.
This is for the simple fact that the body
and soul are one in the same there a manifestation
of Tao.
Meanwhile in Hōrai, one of the seven is seen
showing Rien the new training area, which
features an indoor pool.
After presenting the final part of the room,
the Bochu Jutsu chamber, another Tensen criticizes
how ridiculous the idea was but Rien objects
saying that by copulating with others can
bring out new powers.
Ju Fa comes out of the chamber covered in
blood after undergoing an absolutely insane
session with another Tensen and is offered
Tan to recover.
After grabbing a fresh glass of the immortality
liquid, Ju Fa asks Rien about Mu Dan's whereabouts,
to which its revealed that as Sagiri enters
the gate to Hōrai, Mu Dan had gone to confront
the them.
Upon entering the palace gateway, Sagiri,
Yuzuriha, Senta, and Hōko don't initially
see Mu Dan as instead they’re blown away
by just how weird their surroundings are.
Bringing them all back to reality though Mu
Dan waves his hand causing Hoko’s head to
fall clean off.
FIIINALLY with a name reveal I can actually
tell you how dope Yuki is, so each of these
Tensen’s true names refer to Chinese names
for flowers.
Ri En is ‘Lotus,’ Mudan is ‘Peony,’
Zhu Jin is ‘Hibiscus,’ and Ju Fa is ‘Chrysanthemum.’
Which itself fits with the whole theme of
fake beauty.
Like im not to keyed in with the flower meanings
themselves but from what I read, their meanings
almost reflect exactly how each specific Tensen
tries to act.
In an inn in the Satsuma Domain, after learning
of his return from the island, the shogun's
officials ask Yamada Asaemon Jikka about the
events that had occurred.
Jikka explains before they even arrived at
the island, Chōbei killed his assigned criminal,
so with heavy heart he had chosen to return
back from the mission.
Even still the current had forced him to the
island, eventually though man made it home.
After cutting the story short about how he
managed to escape, an official begged him
to explain in detail what exactly happened
during his escape but Jikka refuses, saying
that explaining it would only be troublesome
and he no longer wanted to be involved with
that hellish place.
Another Yamada Asaemon then interrupts and
bows while also apologizing for Jikka's behavior.
Knowing that the Yamada knelt before them
isn't any ordinary man, the representative
overlooks this offense and reads a message
from the shogun ordering more Asaemon to travel
to the island.
After the meeting, Jikka complains about how
the Asaemon were being treated as pawns but
the young bloke Shugen reprimands him for
his behavior toward the officials.
Hearing Jikka's half laxed reply about Shugen’s
presence being a help to him in the meeting,
Shugen becomes furious and tells him to change
his attitude as its unbefitting for a samurai.
Jikka apologies and instead of pushing the
issue further, enquires as to what re-enforcements
they’d bring along on this journey to the
island.
Shugen informs Jikka that instead of criminals,
the shogun plans to hire ninja from Iwagakure.
During the time Jikka was returning from the
island, another screening was held to gauge
the average strength of the criminals.
Once the battle commenced, every single one
of the criminals was annihilated by Iwagakure’s
shinobi.
The reason for their involvement in the return
to the island is because their chief wants
to make certain of someone's demise.
Shugen explains that they will make for the
island in a few days and bring a swift end
to the mission.
Having walked outside a random dude then comes
for Jikka asking what they should do with
the giant monster head he had brought back
from the island.
Jikka’s actually to goated, mans so cooked
that he completely forgot to bring up the
evidence he’d managed to grab while fleeing
the island.
Either way he states that it never really
felt like the right time to reveal the literal
monsters he’d fished out of the ocean.
Walking up, Shugen then takes a closer inspection,
curious as to what in the world it is, but
the worker warned him that it might be alive.
However, the Anakin looking wannabe states
that the creature was indeed deceased as he
couldn't sense any waves of life force coming
from it.
(Honestly feel like this dude did the Anakin
and merked a whole village or something, he
just has that demeanor hahah) Nearby and after
having meet with two shadowy-figures, its
confirmed that the Rank 2 Shugen and Rank
3 Jikka will be joining them on a journey
to the island thats based purely on someone's
ability.
Skipping back to the moments before our core
crew entered Hōrai.
After traveling for a day, Sagiri, Yuzuriha,
Senta, and Hōko manage to reach the gates
of Hōrai.
Just like before, they take in the odd surroundings
when all of a sudden the random figure infront
of them cuts off Hōko's head from a distance.
Mu Dan cruely jokes that he’s impressed
with them as they’re the first humans in
over a millennium who’ve made it inside
of Hōrai.
Yuzuriha senses that the thing infront of
them defiantly wasn't human and attempts to
flee but is caught in an instant by him.
Sagiri draws her sword and demands that he
let Yuzuriha go, when from the ground below
Hōko states that he is Lord Tensen, the Peony
Spirit Enthroned Fuku Jukun.
Obviously we know him as Mu Dan one of the
7 gender benders and as he looks at the tree
quickly figures that Hōko was still alive,
however due to his size being reduced tells
the others that his Arborfication process
will only speed up.
Hōko accepts this fate since he believes
that his soul will rest in Hōrai.
Yet in probably the biggest gut punch for
bonsai king, Mu Dan smiles stating that the
religious beliefs of his were all lies in
order to maintain peace and structure on the
island.
In truth, every living thing on the island
were results of experimentations and the humans
that venture to the island were merely research
materials.
Leading into that, coming up behind him he
presents the Kiyōshi as examples of his experiments.
Btw these Kiyoshi is like hells paradise’s
messed up take on the historical Jiangshi
or Chinese hopping Zombie or Vampire.
Like with what you could imagine in the story,
the idea behind these creatures is that they
take out people in the night by absorbing
their life force or Qi, but can also be used
to resurrect the dead.
(Annnyways) With the others disgusted with
what he’s done, Mu Dan states he just loves
tinkering around but this isn't even half
of what he could do and that higher quality
humans usually become Tan.
Hearing him bring up this random Tan thing,
Senta questions if he was talking really talking
about the Elixir of Life.
Quickly realizing what Senta was referring
too Mu Dan tells him that it does exist, yet
the elixir doesn't actually benefit humans
as it will only turn them into trees.
So if they are only here for that, then there
isn't any chance they'll find what they’re
looking for.
After hearing this piece of information, Sagiri
worries over Gabimaru's as now it doesn't
even seem like there's a way to complete the
mission.
Breaking her train of thought, Mu Dan just
asks that they surrender here as their mission
has ended.
Catching him by surprise though, Yuzuriha
substitutes herself for an Arborified tree.
Appearing directly behind him, she throws
a bunch of kunai into the back of Mu Dan,
then as she begins to fall down pulls out
her sword while chanting and slices the immortal
being.
Just as quickly darting away from the monster,
she grabs Sagiri’s shoulder turning the
direction she was facing and telling her that
they need to escape while they have the chance.
With the others trying to gap it, a regenerating
Mu Dan comments that she's extremely impressive,
but got one thing wrong, the Kiyoshi are not
servants but toys.
Again with the flick of the wrist Mu Dan commands
the Kiyōshi to jump at Yuzuriha and detonate
upon coming into close contact.
Getting caught between the two of them, Yuzuriha
only barely manages to avoid the explosion.
Rising to her knee’s Mu Dan notes that though
she’s hidden it extremely well, but she
can already perceive Tao.
Wanting to back up his girl, Senta steps forth
telling Mu Dan that if this concerns her life
and death, then he’ll have to go through
him.
Becoming intrigued the immortal comments that
if Yuzuriha has the aptitude for it then he’ll
teach her how to properly wield Tao, if not
she’ll make quality Tan either way.
Having watched Senta step out infront of her
prepared to put his life on the line, Sagiri
wonders if he had any attachments to Yuzuriha.
Not interested in anyone but the Shinobi,
Mu Dan rushes towards Sagiri telling her to
move aside before launching her across the
area using a distant strike.
Moving his attention to Yuzuriha, Mu Dan asked
if she observed how he gathered Tao together.
Before going any further, Senta who’s way
quickly than I ever expected cuts both of
Mu Dan's hands off, saying that he will have
to get past him first.
Jumping in from behind Yuzuriha tells the
number 5 to back off before using her Ninpo:
Slime String to trap the creature.
Wondering what might work on him she uses
Ninpo: Nectar Prison to melt away the immortals
shell then follows up and annihilates the
rest of him with Ninpo: Grim Garrote.
Reviving himself as bunch of thorns he taunts
Yuzuriha calling her application of Tao nothing
more than a child flailing around.
Thinking that if they keep him blinded they
might stand a chance Senta cuts the top part
of Mu Dan's head but its utterly useless as
he taunts them while blind.
He also ceases the regeneration of his eyes
and dodges every one of their attacks.
Getting in next to Yuzuriha he grabs her leg
and swings her towards Senta knocking them
both to the ground.
The reason that Mu Dan is able to comfortable
fight back even while blind is because Tao
is felt, not seen with someone's eyes.
If he cloaks himself in it, it allows him
to feel out the movements of his opponents
and tells them they are no match for him.
Standing there fully T posed out of his mind,
the immortal god re welcomes them to Hōrai,
causing Senta to fall into about of despair
not knowing what to do against such a monster.
Nearby Sagiri tries to recover from Mu Dan's
earlier attack stating that it was if it affected
her very soul.
She pleads with Hoko to think back over all
of the text’s he own for anything that relates
to a possible weakness.
Hōko though who is obviously going through
it realizing that everything he every knew
was a lie, says that he can't be stopped since
he has the powers of a god and he’s already
accepted his passing.
Unable to just give up Sagiri encourages him
to try remember anything and reminds him of
the fact that if they don't survive here,
then he’ll never see Mei again.
Cutting in, Mu Dan notes that Yuzuriha's Substitution
technique and other uses of Tao appear to
have the same attribute as him, though this
left her confused as to what he was even talking
about.
Not noticing Sagiri behind him he considers
taking out Senta, but quickly catches on and
avoids the sneak attack.
Having figured out that he was using someone's
intent to figure out their next movements,
Sagiri throws her sword forth wondering what
an item without intent would do.
Mu Dan I swear this man just closed his eyes
or something, but dude just watches as Sagiri’s
blade fly's straight into his tanden.
With Hoko screaming at her to finish the job,
Sagiri catches upto her blade and cleaves
down, pulling the blade through the monsters
tanden.
The reason that the Tanden is such a vital
spot to attack throughout the series is because
Tao is born there.
Then from that there it cycles around someone's
body before returning back to that point.
So in the case with Sagiri, even if someone
like Tensen takes damage to the Tanden it
should theoretically destroy them.
However, Mu Dan reveals himself to be perfectly
fine, explaining that attacks without Tao
do no harm to him.
Already having coming to that conclusion herself,
Sagiri thanks him as all she needed was to
get in close and confirm exactly how it was
activated.
Taking a breath, Sagiri releases a massive
burst of Tao completely confusing the immortal
nerd.
Shocked by this phenomenon, Mu Dan leans back
just enough to avoid the lethal swing.
Trying to think about what in the world just
happened Mu Dan quickly concludes that Sagiri
can also control Tao and gleefully smiles..
Due to the stuff thats happened so far throughout
the series like her experience with being
near Gabimaru and fighting Rokurōta, Sagiri
knows that she’s already able to perceive
Tao.
All she has to do now is input a certain amount
of energy while controlling her breathing
pattern.
After learning that Sagiri's Tao can harm
him, Mu Dan screams in delight, wondering
if she will become another piece of beautiful
art, or manage to kill him first.
Placing his hands together and using Hojutsu:
Earth Yin, Night Pilgrim he instantly vanishes
and appears before an unaware Sagiri attempting
to attack her.
Seeing through his trick, Yuzuriha restrains
Mu Dan using her strings and calls out to
Sagiri saying that he’s using a similar
ability to her substitution technique.
Seizing the opportunity, Sagiri tries to take
out Mu Dan, but the immortal uses his Senjutsu
technique to releases a burst of Tao from
his mouth to deflect her attack, allowing
him to kick her back.
Then with both girls somewhat occupied he
commands the Kiyōshi to attack Yuzuriha.
Coming in clutch though Senta quickly cuts
them down before taking a distant Tao strike
directly the the chest.
Thinking that the battles going smoothly Mu
Dan taunts the group letting them know its
to easy to read their movements, yet in that
typical think before you speak manga way of
doing things, dude has his leg forcefully
detached by Yuzuriha using her Ninpo: Whiplash
Slash.
Closing in the group absolutely ravages the
immortal while he simultaneously taunts them
for just how well there doing.
Quickly escaping the mess before Sagiri strikes,
Mu Dan levitates up into the sky above them
using Hojutsu: Earth Yang, Sky Pilgrim.
Speaking as if this dudes a god of something,
it says that those ignorant of the of Tao
would consider his techniques to be divine.
Having summoned large water droplets he then
activates Senjutsu: Tin Splinter sending all
of them rocketing towards the ground below
cracking the very floor they’re all standing
on.
With blood beginning to fall from her nose,
Sagiri notes just how much of her stamina
is being robbed by this Tao.
Remembering Mu Dan's previous statement about
different types of Tao, Yuzuriha informs her
that her Tao might be the specific type that
counters his.
Needing to force an opening for Sagiri to
strike him down, she steps forth and uses
that sticky string ability of hers to bring
the immortal closer.
After withstanding a point blank showering
from Mu Dan’s Tin Splinter, she rips the
creature towards the floor while screaming
out for Sagiri to finish the job.
Reappearing himself, the beaten and bruised
Senta seizes his chance to pin him down allowing
Sagiri a few more moments to prepare her attack.
Boosting it in, Sagiri slices straight through
the Tanden of Mu Dan while implementing her
specific affinity for Tao, finishing off the
supposedly immortal creature.
Absolutely knackered from the battle they
just endured, both Yuzuriha and Sagiri quietly
rejoice.
After finally ending their fight with Mu Dan,
Sagiri comes to Hōko's aid and recaps what
she knows abou Tao.
The amount of Tao depends on a specific individual,
it can be boosted or lessened by manipulating
spiritual intensity.
There are a different attributes, each of
which can give someone an advantage over the
other.
However the most important thing that the
group confirmed, even if it disappointed them,
was that the Elixir of Life didnt exist, not
in the form they suspected at least.
Due to that realization, Yuzuriha states that
they would have to come up with another plan,
but its no use thinking on something they
cant do anything about.
Looking over though she see’s the massive
golden head statues and considers the idea
of replacing the elixir with a massive amount
of gold.
Putting that aside for now though the group
just decide to sit down and rest.
Sagiri sits down with Senta and hears him
give Yuzuriha a compliment, making her question
if he had any feelings for Yuzuriha.
Senta denies this and says that its actually
more he is envious of Yuzuriha's innate freedom.
During his childhood he really wanted to become
an artist, but for generations the boys inside
of his family had been sent to train under
the Yamada clan.
He couldnt deny or change his future because
it was tradition, though in truth he hated
it all.
The idea of killing most of all struck a note
within him that led him to seek religion and
eventually become a scholar.
In the end Senta chose to abandon his dream
and carry out his duties as an executioner.
He recalls how moments after taking out Moro,
Yuzuriha managed to see right through him
and how he admires the way she seemed so free.
Feeling similar about Gabimaru and how he’s
changed over this mission, Sagiri brings up
the possibility that in the future all of
them could work together on the island.
Nearby Yuzuriha notices that Mu Dan's body
is continuing to turn into flowers at a progressively
alarming rate.
Instantly a stinger launches towards Yuzuriha
taking her by surprise, Senta though like
the weeb king he is, quickly comes in shoving
her out of the way but sadly receiving a direct
hit by the plant.
Falling into a hallucination, it shows Senta
thinking about Yuzuriha while showing the
beautiful artwork he’d made of her.
Deeply sinful was the way of his work, yet
she was the gale to completely change the
perception he had about everything.
Back in the present the effects of Mu Dan’s
last ditch attack caused flowers to instantly
begin sprouting from the head of Senta, confirming
his demise.
Rip Big Senta.
Above him though, Sagiri and Yuzuriha watch
in horror as Mu Dan starts to transform into
a monster, before completing his transformation
as a visual representation of Yin and Yang.
It laughs at the flabbergasted humans knowing
that now they’re completely unable to do
anything against another attack.
Readying itself, it shoots a plethora of similar
stingers towards the girls.
However, Saving the day, the blind king Yamada
Asaemon Shion arrives on time and beautifully
cuts the stingers.
Acting quickly, he then orders Nurugai to
remove the growing flowers from Senta's body
and tells Sagiri that he will stand in for
the fight against this creature.
After Nurugai helps remove Senta's blooming
flowers, Sagiri asks Hōko if there was a
way to save him.
Unfortunately, Hōko states that it was beyond
his control, either way she helps Senta by
giving him medicine to slow down the bleeding.
Sagiri looks towards Shion and asks about
his current condition but Nurugai informs
her that Shion is more than capable enough
to fight the monster and that they came with
the purpose of finding a certain someone.
Using the knowledge he acquired from his experimentations
on the Sōshin, Shion fends off a bunch of
stingers, before sprinting at the creature
and using Fiends Flurry along with Autumn
Rains to injure the creature.
Not bothered, Mu Dan’s Shikai form just
annihilates the area by creating more Tin
Slinters that rain down from above.
Throwing his sword forth though the smoke
as a distraction, Shion then appears himself
and kicks the monster across the courtyard.
However, random flowers start sprouting up
all over Shion due to the scratches he was
given by the monsters stingers.
Without even considering the damage, he removes
them by slicing away at the stem of every
flower.
Despite this set back, Shion refuses give
up stating that he has no death wish, yet
if death lies in the coming road, then he’ll
accept it without hesitation.
Sagiri tries to help aid him, but Nurugai
stops her, stating that she can barely walk,
let along fight.
Regardless, Sagiri explains that she can't
allow Shion to sacrifice himself for the lives
of others, however if she intervenes then
by working together they could win.
Hearing this Nurugai is persuaded to fight
alongside but Yuzuriha complains that she
just cant as she’s to low on energy.
Walking over to them, Nurugai randomly hugs
both Yuzuriha and Sagiri, explaining it as
a weird way to restore stamina that she’d
been doing from a very young age and now after
learning of Tao, tried to implement it differently.
Able to move now because of it, Sagiri and
Nurugai ready themselves to step into the
battlefield.
With the duo coated in bandages and Yuzuriha's
protective fluid as a way to prevent infection
from the monsters stingers, they both step
in to fight alongside Shion.
Getting the blind kings attention, she informs
him that she knows the monsters weak point,
so the plan to take him down will be distracting
the monster while he gets in behind and slices
its Tanden.
Rushing at them, Mu Dan attempts to take out
Nurugai first, who somehow manages to weave
in and out of the stingers.
Not seeing its hand though, Mu Dan almost
manages to slam down on Nurugai, however Sagiri
comes in clutch, slashing at the hand and
defending herself from a secondary stinger
attack.
Running to get in behind the monster himself,
Shion uses his Harvest Shower technique to
create an opening, but its just no use as
it quickly retaliates shooting a blast of
Tao towards the Samurai.
Refusing to be pushed back, Shion charges
forth, jumps into the sky and strikes down
on the creature.
Yet, this was all a rouse, using this moment
he lands on the ground and strafes under the
monster as its leg was still coming down.
Appearing behind its back now, Shion unleashes
a flurry of cuts that seemingly cut through
its branch like legs, dropping it do the floor
below.
Now not at the same height, the monster tries
to defend itself but Shion forces himself
through its attacks while Sagiri restrains
one of its hand with her sword, allowing Shion
to get behind the monster.
Thinking about everything that has happened
since he made landfall, Shion becomes enraged.
The fact that all he could do was flee when
his disciple was dying is unforgivable..
For his own unforgivable crimes of weakness,
he curses the gods stating that until this
foe is ended of his life ends, Yamada Asaemon
Shion shan't know exoneration.
This next technique of his took years to craft,
thousands of lives made this hidden technique
so lethal.
For Shion manipulating these waves of Tao
is akin to manipulating his own life force
and spirit.
Swinging his blade down now, he threatens
these false gods, telling him that its time
they learnt about the fleeting nature of a
normal life, its beauty and terror.
Shion swings his blade down towards the monsters
tanden, but halts himself after not sensing
any strong waves making him wonder if those
were even its weak points.
Knowing that he doesnt have time to overthink
the situation, Senta the goat rises from the
ashes for a moment to scream out that the
monsters weakness is its ovule since its body
is plant-based.
Guiding him to exactly where the ovules located
on the creature, Shion dives forth dodging
the regenerated stingers and slashing at its
weak spot causing multiple Mu Dan heads to
begin sprouting out.
One of the heads becomes captivated by Shion’s
unwavering ability to face death, stating
that he had truly achieved bliss, Yin and
Yang in perfect harmony.
Slashing at the open weak spot, Shion finally
manages to take down Mu Dan, sending the massive
creature he’d formed into crashing down
onto the ground below.
With it beginning to dissipate, the surrounding
area becomes covered in flowers.
After finally ending the battle, Sagiri rushes
to Senta who is still somehow alive, but readily
succumbing to his wounds.
Sagiri begs Yuzuriha to apply more of her
medicine to him.
However, she refuses as it just wouldn't make
sense to use the remaining amount she has
left on Senta when he’s guaranteed to die.
Instead she’s more of a realist and understands
that Senta knows he’s at the ends of his
road so it only makes sense to give it to
Shion.
Yuzuriha comforts Senta as she tells him to
let go of his duties as an executioner and
think about something he desires as his last
memories.
Crouching down beside Senta in his final moments,
she tells him to instead think about something
else instead of this honor bound stuff.
Think about something that he holds dear instead,
like a family pet or a lover he wont ever
see again and if it helps she’ll hold him
close in these dark times.
Slowly passing away now Senta just thinks
about the few small joys he had in life and
now the beautiful Yuzuriha next to him as
he dies with a smile.
In a moment of silence the group buries his
body and decides to rest before continuing
on their journey.
Sagiri thanks Yuzuriha and Nurugai for their
help, but states that from now on she will
not suffer the death of another ally.
All of them will survive and escape this island
no matter what.
After waking up from his unconscious state,
Gabimaru instinctually jumps from where he
was to see Gantetsusai, Fuchi, and Mei all
just chilling out staring at him.
Fuchi informs him that they’re in a cave
situated halfway up the valley and are just
stopping in for the night.
Gabimaru thinks to himself that he cant seem
to remember the details of how he fell unconscious.
With him awake, Fuchi begins going over what
they know so far about Tao.
Meanwhile, Sagiri's group enter Hōrai and
settle’s inside of a building to also go
over what they know so far.
Yuzuriha and Nurugai happily use the opportunity
to change into some Chinese looking clothes
while Shion tries to discuss what they know
about Tao.
He explains that they need to use Tao wisely
or there will be grave consequences to their
body, mind and in worst cases even death.
Remembering what Hoko had told him, Shion
brings up the idea that multiple types of
waves or Tao actually exist.
In his eyes they would have to be; Wood, Fire,
Earth, Metal and Water.
These 5 attributes are locked into a web of
constant influence.
Some types would help to heal or restore someone's
Tao whereas others would do the opposite and
hinder someone to a greater extent.
Shion believes that if they can exploit these
attributes or types then maybe even the immortals
might be felled.
Nurugai then reminds him that they need to
also focus on acquiring the Elixir of Life.
(which from what we know doesn't exactly exist
in a fruit like form) Yuzuriha states that
from what Mu Dan had said about the elixir
during the early stages of their fight its
not actually what they’re looking for.
However, Sagiri tells them that according
to Gabimaru, his village chief is immortal
because of an elixir which proves that something
similar must exist.
Being a Kunoichi Yuzuriha just knows how these
villages work behind the scenes and explains
the possibilities of the chief using an illusion
known as genjutsu to try and fool his people
into thinking he was immortal in order for
them to bend to his authority.
Meanwhile, Fuchi interprets Mei's words and
explains to them that the proper use of certain
attributes will help them defeat the enemy.
While listening, Gabimaru wonders if he has
some kinda amnesia or mind blank as he’s
still unable to recall anything from the past.
With this in mind, Yuzuriha also explains
her theory that Gabimaru's wife might also
be an illusion set up by the clan in order
for Gabimaru to have a purpose in surviving
his missions.
With Yuzuriha questioning if she even exists
and asking if she was ever told her name,
Sagiri stands there shocked unable to reply,
while over in the cave Gabimaru confirms that
he cant remember anything once more.
He knows that he’s Gabimaru the Hollow the
strongest Shinobi in Iwagakure, but because
his memory is fragmented decides to go along
with what is happening until he can determine
whether the people around him are allies or
hiding their true nature.
Having finished discussing what they know
about Tao Fuchi decides that they should get
some rest for now and move off tomorrow.
Later on as the others sleep, Mei walks outside
to check up on Gabi who tells her that he
is okay but Mei becomes shocked after seeing
that half of his heads Tao is completely gone.
At the same time inside of Hōrai, Sagiri
sits outside until she’s also joined by
Shion.
The two joke around for a moment, but Sagiri
cant help but to think about all of her fallen
comrades and what could've possibly happened
to Gabimaru.
After hearing her concern, Shion asked if
Sagiri had feelings for Gabimaru, however
she stops him midway and denies his allegation.
Nevertheless she explains that she feels sorry
for Gabimaru, he was born into a murderous
village and his past still haunts him.
Plus what's even worse is the fact that if
Yuzuriha is correct about his wife not existing,
then his motivation for surviving this mission
was a complete farce.
Sagiri apologizes to Shion for spewing out
all her thoughts onto him, however Shion explains
that he understands what she’s talking about
and says that he can "overlook" this matter,
causing Sagiri to laugh at his pun.
(Ya know cause he’s the blind king man cant
see, genius)
The next day, Gabimaru's group leave their
cave and travel up the rest of the valley
before encountering the brothers Chōbei and
Tōma.
Hearing Fuchi say that more humans might mean
more friends, Chōbei smiles and spin kicks
Gabimaru.
Back on demon time, Gabi vanishes from infront
of Chōbei, lands on his shoulders and seemingly
taking him out in one swift move.
However, Mei screams out warning him that
Chōbei’s Tao is massive.
Grabbing ahold of him, Chōbei stands back
up and rips Gabi into the ground telling them
that he isn't interested in becoming allies.
Elsewhere and having left the mainland now,
Lord Aoki finds it foolish that the shogun
has planned to send off around 50 Iwagakure
ninja, believing that their leader has motives
of his own.
Shugen tries to calm the Lord down, assuming
that his concern is with the multiple ninja
on board.
Randomly though, Aoki questions if him and
the three other Asaemon were capable of controlling
these Ninja since two seemed to be unranked.
Yoo so rolling up to the island along with
Rank 4 Jikka and the edgy Aizen stand-in,
is the lil man Kiyomaru and the beautiful
but unmatched in still Isuzu.
Kiyo isn't ranked because the man is still
to young to take part in the system and Isuzu
isn't aswell because she takes the role as
a combat instructor employed personally by
the shogun.
Shugen states that they don't just approach
this mission as mere observers, no.
The whole purpose for their expedition to
the island is to back up and support the vanguard.
Kiyomaru becomes annoyed with Aoki as he thinks
its pathetic some random old fart can judge
them because they’re unranked when in all
reality he could probably take him out before
the dude even knew what happened to him.
Isuzu tries to stop him but Kiyomaru flex’s
the fact that he could literally take down
everyone on the ship alone and cuts the mask
off the ninja that appears next to him.
Furious with Kiyomaru's rude behavior Isuzu
draws her blade, placing it near his neck
and demanding that he sheathes his sword.
With the two exchanging cold glares at each
other a random Iwagakure Ninja tells them
that they mustn't worry about them at all.
Noticing him, she awkwardly apologies to the
male ninja but he continues to assures her
that he didnt mind and if they still had doubt
then to pick any one of them, then that said
chosen one will be thrown overboard to show
their loyalty.
Intrigued Kiyo hilariously tests his loyalty
by choosing the ninja who spoke up as the
one to take emself out.
Crazily enough its shown that this dude was
the leader of the Iwagakure squad and before
following through with what he promised, passed
on the leadership to the ninja next to him.
Following through with the order, he takes
himself out proving the loyalty their squad
commands.
Crazily enough the tune he mutters before
doing the deed called “Tooryanse” is a
tune that accompanies a childhood game, similar
to london bridge is falling down type thing.
Its also often used on the modern day crosswalks
as a tune to let people know when it is and
isnt safe to cross.
(when the music stops the games over)
Having gained leadership, the other ninja
speaks up saying that they only desire to
exist as tools and pleads for their trust.
At that moment, one of the other Iwa ninjas
walks over to his former boss and remembers
the orders given to them by the Chief.
“Infiltrate this mission and kill Gabimaru,
ensure that he is purged from this world even
if you have to sacrifice yourselves for the
cause.
Kiyomaru discusses with the validity of what's
just gone on with Shugen, calling them just
random weirdo’s.
Shugen agree’s explaining that it matters
not as he never trusted them to begin with.
All he’s ever seen them as is criminals,
they are alone are enough to find this elixir
of life.
Becoming enraged with the thought of losing
even move loved ones, Shugen states his resolve
to have every criminal on the island executed
so that his clan members can return home.
Kiyo throws out the possibility of them already
being felled yet after receiving a vicious
glare, sprints off.
I always laugh at this but oh well rip, Shugen
hopes that Eizen and that everyone else is
still safe on the island.
Meanwhile, Jikka questions Aoki if bringing
all these shady dudes was going to make the
mission more difficult.
Again its reiterated that its the shogun plans
to make a swift resolution and he thinks that
the vanguard will be overjoyed by their upcoming
arrival.
However, Jikka knows the reality of the situation,
this ship isn't the bringer of hope, no.
Only chaos and death, the personification
of a vessel equipped with people to drive
them to hell even faster.
The stuff of nightmares.
With this in mind Jikka tries one last time
to persuade him into having the ship return
home.
(I honestly love Jikka, reminds me of the
Ogi-san or similar characters, I guess him
and Shion are similar in ways.
There is so many amazing lines in this story
that are almost artistic with the way they
spark some sort of vivid image in your mind.
Both Shion with when he was trying to fell
Mu Dan and here with Jikka are prime examples.
I think it plays into the whole era that Japan
is in, its one where art and language flourished
and I think its perfectly adapted into this
story in its own subtle way.)
Floating there as he rebounds back off the
ground, Gabimaru knows that Chōbei just healed
a fatal wound and figures that he’s most
likely also one of the immortals Fuchi and
the others were referring to earlier.
Flinging himself into a handstand, Gabi shoots
a kick towards Chōbei but its comfortably
blocked.
Having a hold of his leg now the criminal
then flings Gabi over and smashes him into
the ground below as if he had some sort of
super human strength.
Gabimaru focuses his mind on trying to take
out Chōbei, he screams that he’s gonna
tear him to pieces before pulling up his mask
and activating Ninpo: Blooming Needle shooting
a rock straight at his opponent.
Chōbei dodges but Gabimaru used the previous
attack as a distraction to quickly get above
his target.
Immortal or not Gabi foolishly assumes that
if he targets the brain and other senses then
it should allow him to get the upper hand.
However, as weve learnt so far, when someone
can manipulate Tao that just wont work.
Instead Chōbei kicks Gabi in the head knowing
exactly where he was just off presence alone.
Gabimaru then bites at him as a last ditch
effort which completely throws Chobei off.
Jumping back he wonders as to why he’s acting
so uncivilized while at the same time Gabi
still on that animal vibe tries to bite his
opponents vital areas.
Managing to get on his shoulders, Gabi bites
down carotid but is unable to cause him damage
as Chōbei wounds are instantly healed.
Standing opposite each other now, Chōbei
steps it up a notch and stomps the ground
causing the area to break apart leaving Gabi
open to a free hit as he struggles with his
footing.
Chōbei comments that Gabimaru is weak and
uses his Tao strike him, gritting his teeth
through the pain though Gabi manages to unknowingly
throw a Tao infused punch, however it’s
quickly intercepted by Chōbei lays down a
few more hits.
Standing nearby and having watched the entire
battle so far, Gantetsusai wonders why Gabimaru
is fighting poorly in-comparison to his last
battle and asks Mei if she has any idea.
Being able to see Tao with ease Mei knows
that Gabi’s Tao is lacking its form and
he lost something extremely important to him,
but due to her inability to communicate properly
the others cant follow what she's saying.
Beginning to take a fair amount of damage
now, Chōbei calls out to Tōma to attack
the others.
Listening to his broski, Tōma flies forth
and goes after Gantetsusai assuming that because
he lost his hand he’s easy taking.
Tamiya Gantetsusai, the dragon, utterly perplexed
by this persons choice to attack him first
catches his sword and headbutts Tōma while
stealing blade in the process.
Insulted with the thought a kid could take
him out, he throws the former Asaemon’s
blade down telling them to get ready for the
real battle.
As the battle gets underway Gantetsusai not
even using his blade is able to comfortably
land a direct hit and catch Tōma’s blade
under his foot while taunting the former Asaemon.
Knowing that they have potential, big G beats
Tōma around while telling him that he hasn't
taken form yet and instead is weak because
he relies on his brother to fight his battles.
He offers him the opportunity to join their
group, but Tōma tells him that his brother
has no interest in teaming up with them and
also hates nothing more that seeing random
people band together.
In Tōma’s mind he only see’s himself
as an extension of his older brother and his
brother decides the order of things.
Screaming at the Doshi, Tōma then gets it
to join the battle, commanding it to attack
the small ones but Fuchi who’s still with
Mei, steps in to guard her.
Back in the other beatdown and seeing as how
he is being overpowered, Gabimaru ignites
his body and focus solely on destroying Chōbei.
He knows that when on the verge of death a
shinobi can wreak untold levels of destruction
upon their enemy.
Now completely ablaze, he sprints towards
the immortal criminal and uses Ninpō: Burning
Bridge in combination with Ninpō: Stone Storm
to send a bunch of heated rocks flying through
Chōbei.
Crashing to the ground, Gabimaru gets onto
of him prepared to send himself and Chōbei
to the shadow realm.
The criminal tries saying that they’ll both
perish if he continues, but Gabi literally
doesn't care.
He doesn't even know why he’s on this random
island or partaking in this mission.
If he dies right now, its not like it’ll
even matter, his village will just send another
person to take his place, as at the end of
the day Shinobi are just a hive with nothing
to lose and those who cling to life will never
win.
Hearing this and becoming enraged at the idea
that he cant win because he has an attachment
to his brother, Chōbei thanks Gabimaru for
helping him realize his resolve.
So remember Mei and the Strong Weak stuff
from earlier, well as Chōbei states to himself
that he does indeed have something to lose,
his mind becomes weaker and his body begins
to transform into his breakdown state.
I love how this forms called a breakdown cause
oml these boys bouta dance.
Having unlocked this new form Chōbei unleashes
a transformation and uncontrollably attacks
Gabimaru.
Gabimaru tries to ward him off by releasing
a large burst of flames using Ninpo; Burning
Bridge, but its no use as the demon just slashes
his way through them.
Unable to block in time, big C sends a bunch
of his tentacles shooting into the hollow
allowing him to toss Gabi across the area.
Activating Ninpo Ascetic Blaze, Gabi just
barely manages to detach himself from the
vines.
Unable to see anymore, Chōbei's consciousness
begins to be consumed by the darkness, causing
him to slash out in anger wondering where
in the world the Ninja could have gone.
With the others no longer fighting, Gantetsusai
wonders why Gabi isn't using Tao to fight
like he did yesterday, Mei says that he is
unable to use Tao and can't win against Chōbei
as he’s just too strong.
Falling into a moment of deep though, Gabimaru
makes the decision to use up his remaining
life to kill Chōbei, however, he is briefly
stopped by a vision of someone long forgotten.
Ignoring this uneasiness he rushes towards
Chōbei ready to do whatever it takes.
Watching these beasts become more and more
confused, Fuchi just notes that both of them
have lost themselves.
Turning and seeing his brother become more
beast that man, Tōma remembers Gantetsusai
words from earlier and realizes that Chōbei
has been fighting for his sake.
Back in the battle Chōbei continues on his
rampage, sadly though he soon comes to see
that for the past few blows, as he wondered
what he was, he’d unknowingly attacked Tōma
who tried to make him come to his senses.
Stuck and unable to move, taking in what he’d
just done, Tōma tries to break through his
brothers shell, telling him that he’s everything
in the world to him.
Sadly as he was doing this Gabimaru saw the
perfect opportunity to deal the finishing
blow and prepared himself to do so.
Not wanting Gabimaru to burn away the last
of his Tao because he’ll die, Mei rushes
in to stop him from doing anything else.
Standing behind him she releases a massive
blast from her Tao creating a crater that
causes Gabimaru and the two siblings to start
falling.
Gabimaru manages to get himself to safety
and as Chōbei turns trying to look for an
escape route, throws stones forcing him deeper
into the whole.
Thinking quickly, Chōbei uses his vine things
to throw Tōma to safety while telling him
to wait for his return.
So remember how Gantetsusai and Fuchi don't
really know Mei yet, like this aint the Hoko
group and seeing her use this level of Tao
makes them question just how she accomplished
such a feat.
In an even more surprising revelation for
the two its shown that Mei was now fully grown.
Meanwhile inside Hōrai, Sagiri suggests that
they go outside and reunite with Gabimaru
and the others.
However, Yuzuriha doesn't agree and instead
thinks their focus should be trying to escape
from the island.
Sagiri sees threw her intentions of wanting
to save herself and reveals her own plan to
return home safely with every remaining person
as that way they then have an alibi.
Sagiri reassures her that her desire to escape
hasn't changed its just that EVERYONE will
be leaving this place together.
Switching the conversation up, she ponder
if Gabimaru managed to arrive at the gate
from the very beginning, to which Yuzuriha
reveals that he defiantly did as she found
evidence that he was there before they came.
In her eyes their best bet to bump back into
Gabimaru now is to wait around that gate.
After deciding to head over to the gate the
girls note that seeing Hōrai clearly during
the day is absolutely insane.
Looking around the godly setting the group
becomes captivated by its mystic aura.
Hōko remembers Mu Dan's words about Lord
Tensen experimenting with human life's and
the humans on the island acting as test subjects.
He wonders if the current humans on the island
will bring a change after seeing that they
managed to take out an immortal and wonders
if he will still be himself when they do.
Once they reached the gate, the group encounter
Fuchi, Gantetsusai, Mei, Tōma and an unconscious
Gabimaru.
After the initial surprise of everyone noticing
each other, Both Sagiri and Fuchi ask what
happened in their time apart.
Noticing that Mei was okay and had matured
after using her power, expresses his gratitude
that her allies kept her safe.
Confused on how they arrived here, Hoko asked
if they came up from the Soshin pit at the
valley floor and after learning that they
did, Hōko becomes shocked to see that they
also have a Dōshi hostage.
Left speechless, Hoko can only think that
throughout the 1000 years he’s lived, no
one had managed to accomplish these feats
and because of that believes that the current
travelers are humans beyond compare.
After being informed of Senta's passing, Fuchi
stands next to his grave and cries in sorrow.
After confirming the deaths of most groups
and seeing the remaining survivors, Shion
expresses regret that so little have survived
the ordeal on the island.
However, Gantetsusai comments that his feeling
of regret was wasted on the condemned criminals
since they were fated to kill each other the
moment everyone made landfall.
Unlike Shion thought, he also states that
thinking all your comrades would also survive
is ridiculous.
He then points towards Tōma since its obvious
the dude was a traitor and offers to get rid
of him.
Not wanting him to, Sagiri steps in to stop
him as without Chōbei around, he really doesn't
pose a threat to at all.
Yuzuriha interrupts and has everyone around
focus their attention towards Gabimaru's injures,
stating that the dude’s literally knocking
on deaths door.
Rolling up Fuchi elaborates on what happened
before they got here and how he’s expended
far to much Tao.
He did what he could when it came to healing
him, but because the injuries go beyond physical
he wasn't able to do much.
Kneeling down and looking at her injured friend,
Sagiri watches as Gabimaru re-awakens and
instantly tries to stand up.
Sagiri says that they should look into his
wounds but Gabimaru though shrugs her off
while saying he’s fine.
Shion warns him that without proper treatment
he will die, but Gabi claims he’s already
accepted this fact.
Stunned with hearing the old Gabi again, Sagiri
just questions who he is.
Looking at her Gabimaru answers that she already
knows who he was.
He’s Gabimaru the Hollow.
Launching himself forward Gabimaru attacks
Sagiri, luckily for her though big Fuchi and
Shion noticed what he was upto and blocked
the strike.
Knowing that a disturbance in ones Tao can
effect memory, Sagiri explains that Gabimaru
has lost all of his memories due to every
battle he’s fought wearing away at the construction
of his very soul.
Sagiri tries to reason with her confused friend,
explaining that she is his ally and wants
to help him.
After he repeatedly tries pushing her away,
Sagiri becomes enraged and uses force to pin
him down.
Gantetsusai watches thinking that they’re
doing the sneaky Bochu Jutsu, though Fuchi
doubts this while Mei blushes saying that
this act was different yet similar.
Sagiri explains to that they really dont have
times for such trivial activites, but they
really need his strength to escape this island.
So in an attempt to wake him up even quicker
she reminds Gabi that he has someone to return
home to.
In the same moments Gabimaru's Tao is restored
and his memories begin flooding back in.
Soo throowwwback boys, remember the crater
incident.
Well after reaching the bottom of the valley
and regenerating his limbs, Chōbei reflects
on his actions during his fight with Gabimaru.
Looking at just how far down he fell dude
literally cracks the code and figures out
that the island is shaped like a bowl with
ridges connecting the middle parts.
He then spots a group of Sōshin and decides
to use them to test out his applications of
Tao.
Meanwhile, all of the remaining survivors
relocate to a cave that Gantetsusai found
to remove themselves from Lord Tensen's sensory
in Hōrai.
This is just due to the fact big Rien can
sense where they are at all times using the
Tao in the air.
Remember how there was a higher level of humidity
to the island hiding it to start with, well
thats my thought aswell that he uses his abilities
to hide the island while brining in a select
few to turn into Tan.
After Gantetsusai calls Shion a coward because
he was scared of Lord Tensen and warned everyone
to be cautious.
He receives judgement from Yuzuriha and Nurugai
who also reiterates just how dangerous they
are.
Having regained his memory Shion asked Gabimaru
if he had fought one as well and he confirms
it.
He also confirms to them that he knows how
to manipulate Tao now, but went about learning
it the hard way along with finding out just
how terrifying Lord Tensen truly is.
Having told his experience, Yuzuriha gives
her opinion that it would be best for them
to escape the island but Gabimaru objects
as he knows that without the pardon he’ll
never be safe.
Hearing this, Yuzuriha goes to tell him about
her theory, but a shocked Gabi cuts her off
knowing that she was going to say his wife
was just a form of Genjutsu.
He tries just pushing past what she said,
but Yuzuriha wants to make sure she’s not
walking into a trap.
Our boy knows she exists though as he can
tell just based off the sensation he has when
he thinks about her.
Wanting to know more info that isnt just a
sensation, as its not very logical of him
to think a sensation is real.
Gabimaru describes the little things he can
remember about her, like her voice or the
shape of her eyes and says that even now on
beautiful days like this when he’s drenched
in nature he can sense her nearby.
Phasing into a blissful memory he reveals
her name as Yui, saying that this was the
only proof he had, the only way to be sure
was to make it home and find out.
His confidence causes Sagiri to feel delighted
and Gantetsusai who calls our boy a mans man
to feel like he finally found a perfect fighting
partner.
Yuzuriha found it weird that a shinobi like
Gabimaru can talk about his weaknesses but
Shion adds in that the fact that he could
sense Gabimaru's Tao growing proves that his
wife is real and people who have something
to lose are considered strong.
So funily enough and continuing with the possible
idea that she doesnt exist, Yui doesnt really
confirm that its a person.
The Kanji he uses for her name simply means
bond or connection and is also the first part
to how you’d spell out marriage.
So does she truly exist or is she a manifestation
made up by the chief of the clan? id love
to know your thoughts on that down below!
Back down in the valley and after merking
every Soshin around, Chōbei is met by Rien
who questions if he was the one who killed
Mu Dan.
Elsewhere Fuchi, Feeling in no mood to examine
the Dōshi after finding out about the death
of his comrades, decides to set him free.
Over inside the cave now Sagiri informs Fuchi
that Mei’s feeling ill and hasn't been able
to recover any strength so would he be able
to make some medicine.
Annoyed after finding out that she’s the
same as Lord Tensen, Fuchi agrees to help
but demands that in return Mei tell them everything
they need to know about herself and Lord Tensen.
Meanwhile, Gabimaru sits outside and makes
a request to the other four to help him train
to utilize Tao even more efficiently.
Super eager to learn more himself, Tōma starts
off by attacking with Gantetsusai's sword.
Dodging the slashes Gabi focuses on sensing
the movements of his opponents Tao not tracking
him with his sight.
Gantetsusai then comes in to make his attack
on Gabi, but he easily uses his Tao to sense
the strike weaving out of its way and allowing
him to examine Gantetsusai’s weak spots.
He then kicks off the Tao in the sky to put
some space between them.
Nurugai jumps in and tries attacking however
Gabi grabs her and uses her to push back the
others as they approach.
As the battle continues, Gabimaru believes
that its pointless trying to hone a more refiened
technique than the immortals since they’ve
been training for over 100 years.
Instead the key to defeating Lord Tensen is
to use their own Tao against them.
Standing back up, Nurugai approaches Gabi
believing that he was more than capable enough
to take down Lord Tensen.
However, Gabimaru believes he still needs
more time to improve.
Gantetsusai asks if he’s finished with the
warm up cause mans keen to get serious, before
randomly diving forth, raging out and preparing
to strike down on Gabi.
While the other 2 start freaking out, back
inside the cave Fuchi explains to Sagiri and
Yuzuriha that the island, the monsters, and
Lord Tensen were created by a singular entity.
This being is apparently a famed Hōshi who
used Shenxian principles in his attempt to
research ways to achieve immortality.
(for those confused on what a Hoshi is, so
pretty much its an Ancient Chinese Mystic
versed in Divination and other healing arts)
This particular Mystic developed methods to
tinker with Tao directly.
From this he created crossbreeds of creatures
that had similar affinities for Tao.
Then after an age of creation Lord Tensen
was born.
This being is a fusion of human an plant Tao
that is both male and female, both Yin and
Yang.
Hence how they can change genders in an instant.
Lifeforms usually use Tao over the course
of their life, but the Lord Tensen's energy
has been polished for over 1000 years, far
beyond the scope of any human ability.
Yuzuriha asks what their purpose in living
on the island was all for, Fuchi explains
that the Tensen's have been practicing Taoism
or more specifically the Inner Ways of Tan,
which is meditation, and also the Outer Ways
of Tan, which is making an elixir, to achieve
immortality.
Hearing this, Yuzuriha and Sagiri become shocked
realizing that the elixir does indeed exist.
Yet Fuchi tells them that its probably just
a prototype, a potion created from harvesting
and extracting the Tao of humans in order
to expand the Tensen's lives.
Knowing this, Fuchi tells them it is possible
to take out Lord Tensen if their Tao is depleted.
Curious after learning this, Yuzuriha questions
why they are going further with their research
since they have already created Tan.
Mei answers saying that it was possible that
Lord Tensen was following the will of their
master, Xu Fu.
Fuchi explains that Xu Fu, also known as Jofuku
in japan, he was a Hōshi Mystic and servant
to the emperor of the Qin Dynasty, who journeyed
off to research the secrets of immortality
1,000 years ago but eventually came to an
end once he entered Japan.
Perhaps though he never really came to an
end and instead lives on as someone to this
very day....
HMMMMMMMM I really wanna know your thoughts
on what you think.
Its given us the image of this dank looking
foot, so surely that hints that someone is
indeed still alive.
So this Xu Fu or Jofuku person is actually
a real man from waaay back in the 3rd century
BCE.
As I mentioned earlier in the video he was
sent out to search for this mythical mountain
and the elixir of life.
He oversaw a fleet of 60 vessels and thousands
of crew members, artisans and civilians.
In 219 BCE he actually made it back after
the first voyage having unsuccessfully found
the elixir or Penglai, yet after heading out
9 years later in 210 BCE he never returned.
Some people suggest that he ended up making
landfall near Mt Fuji, however in Hells Paradise
its obvious that the mans voyage ended in
the sea’s southwest of Japan.
While the girls and Fuchi discuss the Jofuku's
existence, Mei falls back exhausted also revealing
that her left arm has turned into a branch.
She explains that her usage of Tao is causing
her body to turn into a tree and needs to
take in energy in order to heal.
Yuzuriha suggest using a restoration technique,
however, Mei says that it will not work since
she has little Tao already and because Rien
broke her Tanden causing it to constantly
leak.
After the cruel past Mei went thru is shown
to us, Hōko then offers his Tao in order
to fully heal her.
Due to how Lord Tensen can extract Tao from
living life forms its the only way for Mei
to heal herself, but obviously she’s hesitant
to sacrifice Hōko.
He insists though as soon he’ll go through
the process of arborfication.
To him this is one way he can also atone for
his sins, explaining that he ignored Mei’s
desire of wanting to leave the island, choosing
to raise her as a replacement to his deceased
daughter.
Mei tearfully tells Hōko that from the time
he found her, she’s always thought of him
just like a father.
She then accepts his offer, placing out her
hand and absorbing his Tao.
With Hoko’s energy flowing into Mei, she
gives him her final farewell before returning
back to her younger state.
Meanwhile, the previously raging practice
battle has come to a peaceful end.
Shion is left impressed with Gabimaru's abilities
and believes that he may have what it takes
to defeat Lord Tensen.
Tōma then randomly drops down on his knees
and begs Gantetsusai to help train him how
to wield a sword so that he can gain the power
to escape the island.
Big G doesn't believe he can trust him, but
in a show of honor Tōma then cuts his hair
and asks once again to help make him strong.
Impressed with the lil guys determination
Gantetsusai agrees with helping Tōma and
tells him to come follow him.
Braining his hair together states to himself
that until he can fight on his own.
No until he can fight alongside his brother
as an individual he needs to get stronger.
Back down in the Soshin valley, Chōbei notes
that the thing infront of him has the exact
same face as the creature he fought earlier.
Fascinated with the hybridization Chōbei
had achieved, Rien explains that they create
the Waitanhua flower that converts human bodies
into Tan, yet somehow, even as the root of
that plant dug into Chōbei’s Tao he still
kept a sense of self.
Wanting to examine him further, Rien attacks
Chōbei with an attack similar to Tin Slinter
causing him to quickly dodge while realizing
that he has no chance in winning this battle.
In an attempt to fight back he transforms
into his breakdown state and dashes at him
before letting lose a flurry of strikes and
stakes that Rien just barely manage to block.
Somehow Chōbei manages to overwhelm Rien
but finds it difficult to keep the vines inside
his mind from taking over his body.
After piercing Rien's tanden, Chōbei expands
his vines and destroys his the immortals body,
making him assume that the Tanden was the
correct place to take out these creatures.
However, Rien suddenly appears behind Chōbei,
revealing that he has destroyed one of his
many clones he brought along.
After seeing Chōbei unleash Tao from the
Waitanhua flower, Rien expresses his satisfaction
at the fact he managed to control it and decides
to take him back to the palace.
Chōbei tries to attack but is unable to resist
the effects of the vines allow Rien to bend
down infront of him and use a Tao strike to
knock him unconscious.
Slowly falling into a dream he reiterates
his desire of not making the same mistake
as his father by abandoning his brother.
Later, Chōbei wakes up tied to a bed and
sees Rien as a female standing nearby tending
to the plants.
Rien explains that she finds Chōbei to be
the final key to completing her research and
wishes to understand his Tao cycle better
through Bōchū Jutsu.
BUT YA KNOW WE CANT GO THERE.
Just know that man is the key to unlocking
the perfect being.
Okay yeah I really cant go over some of the
stuff that gets revealed here cause its done
in the most Yuki Kaku of ways, BUT pretty
much its revealed that because Chōbei is
the perfect being, when his Tao is extracted
then it will allow these creatures to turn
everyone on the mainland of Japan into Tan.
So yeah thats I guess that big evil plan in
store that our main crew is yet to figure
out.
Something else I wanted to mention was that,
the Kanji in Waitanhua translates to Outside,
Tan and Flower, meaning a flower used for
the outer way of Tan.
Anyways Later on Gantetsusai breaks down crying
in pain that Mei has reverted back to her
child body, in his eyes it was way more comfy
carrying her around when she was older.
Actual chad tho, aint into to that weirdo
shi, thats why Gantetsusai is a champ in my
eyes.
Yuki as an author in general is the one of
the only ones i've read that make a proper
attempt to not do any of the normalized weird
Japanese troupes.
WHICH IS GOATED.
Coming back to the main group Shion in collaboration
with Gabi prepares to announce their next
plan.
However, Mei catches their attention when
she senses that the second landing party has
arrived on the island.
She knows it isn't lord Tensen, but due to
how she cant articulate herself well just
says that their Tao is very strong.
Having taught this man, Shion believes that
its most likely Shugen and the other reserve
Asaemon who were sent as reinforcements by
the Shogunate.
Fuchi also tells them that another group of
criminals were to accompany them as well.
Curious, Gabimaru asks Sagiri if Shugen is
a potential ally and she vouches for him,
saying that he might even be the strongest
amongst them, however, Gantetsusai doubts
her statement knowing that he’ll need more
than just strength to survive here.
Thinking back on the past, Shion confirms
that Shugen is already able to perceive Tao
since it was actually him to first notice
the sixth sense and call them waves.
Over at the coast, Shugen hands off his blade
and confronts a Sōshin.
Obviously mans yolked up, already able to
perceive the environment around him through
the use of Tao alone.
The monster manages to grab him, but through
what he learnt while training with Shion,
Shugen easily lifts its hands from his shoulders
and defeats it barehanded.
On the island Nurugai is impressed with the
idea of how strong Shugen is, however Yuzuriha
mentions a certain story that made him infamous.
Sagiri explains the story of how Shugen executed
all of the captured members infront of their
leader in order to reveal the remaining members.
After he revealed their location, they were
too all arrested and well yeah you can image
what happened next.
The Shogun was so impressed by his brutality
that he presented the young Asaemon with a
ceremonial outfit and the named blade; Fuributsu
Kaneaki
The group becomes concerned but Sagiri reassures
them that deep down he’s a great guy, leading
Fuchi to state that Shugen was Sagiri's first
crush.
She says that even if that was the case, she
merely admires his involvement in her earning
a ranking in the Yamada clan.
After taking out a group of Sōshin, Isuzu
and Kiyomaru come to his aid but Shugen reassures
them that as their senior, he will take on
the responsibility of taking care of lesser
matters like fighting the pathetic monsters.
While Sagiri believes that Shugen will come
to their aid, Shion disagrees and reveals
the full story of how Shugen not only merked
the entire Silver Serpent group but also their
loved ones since they might hold some form
of vengeance towards the Shogun.
Shion explains that Shugen despises criminals
and would not think of allying with them or
have anyone he associates with work with them.
As the new group travels, Shugen stumbles
across the site where Eizen was turned into
a pancake by Rokurōta.
After his were taken out by an infamous bandit,
Shugen was dropped at the door of the Yamada
Clan.
As the two begin talking about what it means
to be an executioner, Shugen tells Eizen that
he fails to see the logic in the their clans
way of executing criminals with and wonders
why they can't give them a painful death instead.
Eizen explains that such an act would defile
the execution grounds and the chipping of
his blade would be meaningless.
Being an Asaemon means ridding yourself of
that hatred and he’ll hone him into a great
man.
He then tells him that he looks forward to
the day he becomes a "glorious blade".
In the present, Shugen screams in pain over
Eizen's death and instead of moving forward
with the mission makes the decision to lay
his soul to rest.
While giving him a proper burial, one of the
ninja thinks to himself that 3 of these people
are extremely odd and Jikka’s just as random.
With the priority for them being Gabimaru,
they all plan on using the dangers of the
island to outsmart the Samurai and complete
their mission.
Out of freaking know where though a massive
flower type thing drops down on the 50 or
so Ninja catching a few of them.
Looking up, the group see a bunch of Mōnshin
rolling up to try and capture them commanded
by a Dōshi.
Another massive flower trap thingy drops down
on the trio, but Kiyo and Isuzu quickly cut
it to shreds while Shugen sat there unmoved
still mourning Eizen's passing.
The genin also dispatch 2 squads to assist
in bringing down the Mōnshin.
After finishing reciting his sutras, Shugen
finally says Eizen can rest in piece.
Not even standing yet, Shugen then swiftly
draws his blade and cuts down a Mōnshin that
attempted to attack from behind.
Angered with everything he’s seen, Shugen
smashes his brand new named blade against
the monsters staff to repeatedly damage it.
Standing there and bleeding from his eyes
with rage, he swears vengeance against all
that resides on the island.
Just like with Naruto the Ninja here have
the same class setup with it being Genin as
foot soldiers, mid level Chunin and high level
Jonin.
Also while im here, the Sutra that Shugen
was reciting is the most recited text in Mahayana
Buddhism and is one that goes over the great
emptiness in all things.
Hearing Shugen declaring his wrath to him,
the Dōshi prepares to attack him with Tao.
However, the fight quickly comes to an end
with Shugen utterly obliterating and stopping
him from regenerating.
He then starts to do some really questionable
acts.
Jikka gets him to stop and tries to reason
with Shugen in returning to the mainland with
the information they gathered but is angrily
told that its not gonna happen.
He then asked why he hadn't drawn his blade,
leading Jikka to state that he can't, even
still Shugen knows that he can making him
get even more furious.
Cutting in on the boy, Isuzu calms him down,
making him realize the stupidity of his ways.
Quickly changing his demeanor, Shugen apologizes
to Jikka, but states that his earlier statement
of eliminating everything living on the island
was true so don't forget that.
Hearing this, one of the ninja recommends
that they should handle everything in regards
to collecting information since the ninja
have special tactics in that area.
Meanwhile, the survivors of the vanguard party
listen to Shion's plan of separating everyone
into two groups where one finds an escape
route and the other finds the Tan elixir.
After Gantetsusai asks how exactly they’re
gonna fight Lord Tensen, Shion repossessions
everyone and creates a diagram on the ground
of the Tao attributes each one of them possess.
The idea is that they will use their attributes
to hinder each member of Lord Tensen and defeat
them.
Yuzuriha believes that it’s hopeless to
continue due to the risks and not knowing
who they’re up against at the coast of the
island.
She then suggests an alternative by finding
a way off the island and instead going into
hiding as a way to possibly survive.
Shion understands where Yuzuriha's is coming
from and knows that there are just too many
unknowns in the coming future.
So because of this he takes everyone's thoughts
on the matter into consideration by giving
them the option of going their own separate
ways or working together in surviving.
After walking into the cave, Shion immediately
senses the presence of everyone behind him
deciding to move forward with his plan due
to their own personal reason in surviving.
With their situation growing more dire, Shion
is relived that everyone came to the same
decision and tells them that they are all
each other’s last chance of survival.
After Mei does her thing, Fuchi interprets
for the group and begins explaining the plan
they’re about to undergo.
From what they can learn, Hōrai is designed
to be a massive fortress modeled off China’s
Epang Palace and that the sea monsters prevent
anything from leaving the island.
However, Mei reveals that Hōrai contains
numerous ships at a underground floodgate
that allows departure along a safe current.
So their mission is to avoid confrontation,
acquire the elixir and steal a ship to make
it back home on.
Gabimaru tells them that according to Mei
the Tan elixir is located in a laboratory,
but the palace's interior is constantly changing.
With time drawing closer to the moment they
invade enemy territory, Shion pulls Gabimaru
and Yuzuriha over to have them instruct the
group in the art of espionage using Tao.
Looking like an absolute babe with these specs
on Yuzuriha teaches the group on how to mask
their presence by suppressing their Tao.
Afterwards Gabimaru also nerded out, teaches
his lesson in using Tao against their opponents.
After the training was over, everyone is divided
into two teams, the Escape-Route Team made
up of big G, Shion, Nurugai, Tōma, Mei, and
Fuchi and the Elixir Retrieval Team made up
of the other 3.
While the 3 powerhouses are off doing there
thing sourcing the elixir, the Escape team
needs to find the boats and open the flood
gates.
Realizing that Mei has wanted to leave the
island for a while now, Gantetsusai suggests
that they let her depart alone and not wait
for the Elixir Team.
However, Gabimaru asks Mei if there was anything
she desired to do before leaving the island.
Surprisingly Mei tells him that she actually
wished to meet with Rien and Jofuku again
to ask why they changed from how they were,
before then escaping.
Remembering his wives words to him about valuing
everyday and living a decent life, Gabimaru
promises to fulfill Mei's wish no matter what.
At a similar time inside of Hōrai, Tao Fa
greets Chōbei after the end of the Doshi
ritual ceremony but is stopped by Ju Fa.
He cruely tells the other Tensen that there
is no need to communicate with livestock and
just breathing the same air makes him feel
ill.
Angered by his presence Ju Fa lashes out at
Chōbei who manages to block the strike.
Realizing just how much stronger he’s become
Chōbei tells the immortal that he should've
finished him off in the last fight, because
now he can see thru all of his moves.
Stopping them from further escalating, Rien
orders Ju Fa to behave himself and has Chōbei
follow him to his laboratory so that he can
study his Tao.
As the two walk and talk Chōbei notices that
he is starting to get use to his new power
but after looking at Rien senses that his
Tao is on a completely different level.
Initially he was planning on escaping as quickly
as possible and running back to Tōma, however
after seeing the difference in strength decides
to stick around incase he can find some sort
of weakness.
Once entering the laboratory, we see a massive
Waitanhua flower which is called a Banko.
These flowers don't allow them to store the
extra Tan, but unlike the smaller flowers
it can process a far greater quality of Tan
all in one go.
The reason Tan cant be preserved is because
over time the Tao eats away at that of the
humans lifeforce, eventually and just like
the human that plant will soon wither before
it can produce the perfect quality Tan.
This is why Rien desires Chōbei's rare Tao,
to complete his research.
Again with Yuki referring to something from
our world, this Banko here or Pangu in Chinese
is an entity that appears in prominent creation
myth.
In this creation myth it explains that in
a world of nothingness, Banko was the giant
who emerged from his egg, separated Yin and
Yang with his axe, elevated the sky above
the earth and apon his death turned himself
into the sun, moon, landscape, weather and
animals.
Pretty much its the god of earth in this creation
myth and maybe something similar in hells
paradise.
Meanwhile, the Elixir Retrieval Team infiltrates
Hōrai and once safely landing on the roofs,
signals to the others that the area is clear
to enter.
Sagiri notices that the plan is moving quickly
and wonders if its truly time for the mission
to come to an end.
Pulling up his mask, Gabimaru States that
they always knew they were on a timer, so
yes everyone will leave this island tonight.
Flashing back to the preparation, Fuchi breaks
down Mei’s explanation and gives out a basic
layout of the castle.
He reveals that each Tensen has a sanctuary
of their own and the Elixir and escape ship
are most likely in the center area.
Popping in Mei tells us who is in each area
of the castle.
In here eyes the elixir is most likely with
Rien in the Laboratory, Ju Fa and Tao Fa will
be doing the silly inside of the Bochu Jutsu
sanctum.
The Taisoku sanctum is the domain of Zhu Jin,
Shu’itsu sanctum which is the meditation
domain ruled by Gui Fa and finally the Shuten
sanctum run by Mu Dan but ya know he know
around anymore hahaha.
She also states that since the Banko flower
drops down at night, Rien will not be in the
temple conducting research.
Instead he’ll most likely move to the main
residence where Jofuku resides, making it
possible to avoid running into him after securing
the elixir.
Gabimaru then explains that he and Yuzuriha
will land at the top of the inner gate and
will survey the layout of the castle using
their Tao sensory.
In the present, Sagiri notices the dreadfully
sinister amount of Tao coming from the palace
and starts to falter.
Gabi and Yuzuriha though console her stating
that it doesn't bother them as they’re already
used to it.
Using what they’d learnt in preparation
for the mission, both Gabi and Yuzuriha take
out all of the guards while constantly keeping
their Tao suppressed to not alert anyone.
After taking out all of the Doshi, the Elixir
Retrieval Team successfully make it through
with the first part of their predetermined
plan and enter the castle.
Almost instantly after getting inside they
make it to the supposed room with the Elixir.
Gabimaru opens the door and senses the layout
of the room but suddenly sees Tao forming
an entity in the middle.
Surprised that someone knew he was there,
the Tao silhouette is revealed to be Ran who
had the same idea of suppressing his Tao.
Stepping forth Mei asks her younger brother
how he knew of their arrival.
Ran commends their attempt but reveals that
Chōbei has informed them that the humans
would be coming to invade the palace and agreed
to keep track of their arrival by sensing
their Tao on one condition.
This is just due to the fact that after hurting
his brother in the last battle, Chōbei was
able to track his exact location.
Just as if he went up against Zhu Jin Gabimaru
finds himself in trouble due to Ran possessing
the Water-attribute which hinders his Fire-attribute.
The plan if they bumped into an enemy with
a stronger attribute was to run, as if try
fighting with such a heavy debuff they’ve
got no chance.
Hoping into a JoJo esque pose Ran becomes
delighted to see Mei once again and begs her
to return back to their side, explaining that
they no longer need to follow the Outer Way
of Tao since they have completed their research
in creating the Elixir of Life.
Utterly Shocked Gabimaru asks for more info
on what he just said.
Obviously because of the fact the Tensen discovered
Chōbei they feel that with his co-operation
they’ll easily be able to create a potent
enough elixir.
All that they need to do now is produce more
Tan that has a considerable quantity of exceptional
material.
Thats why for this exact reason that Rien
has started the Rite of just consumption,
the end is indeed coming near.
Despite his plea, Mei refuses and says that
she only wishes to say goodbye to everyone.
To her now its obvious that she’s different
to them, but dying is sad.
Instead she just came to say goodbye before
leaving the island with everyone else.
Disappointed Ran just states that the Rite
of Just Consumption would have to continue
and she can become another offering.
After Sagiri asks what he meant, Ran explains
that it was ritual to capture and offer the
humans to the grandmaster.
Over with the Boat Squad, Gantetsusai, Fuchi,
and Tōma get separated from Shion and Nurugai
due to a massive cloud of mist that obscures
their vison.
Pushing forward either way the three then
bump into Tao Fa and Ju Fa while Shion and
Nurugai are approached by Zhu Jin for a second
time.
Knowing that their plan to avoid Lord Tensen
has failed, the group decide to move onto
their second plan, which is just straight
hands, giving everything they’ve got cause
its not like they could ever outrun these
feigns.
Not phased, our boy announces to Ran that
they won't give up without a fight and instead
they’re beat him down and say bye bye to
this island.
Seeing as how the ritual has already begun,
Ran prepares to let loose knowing that all
they need know is the sacrifices.
So I just want you all to think back to the
pot analogy I used at the start of the video
and how it was literally shown to us on the
panels themselves.
Now think about how what they’re doing with
this elixir is simply another form of this
old-school Japanese curse, there sticking
all of these ‘venomous beasts’ into the
island which is literally shaped like a pot
in the hopes they can precure a vial of immortality
juice.
Idk its something that just clicked in my
head right now, but I love how early on its
foreshadowed that this exact this would happen.
Knowing that even though he’s going up against
someone with an unfair advantage, Gabimaru
tells Sagiri and Mei to go search for the
elixir while he and Yuzuriha hold off the
creature.
However, Mei warns him that they are not in
the Rien’s Temple, shocking Gabimaru.
Sensing the kick coming at him from behind
he quickly dodges and jumps back, before flying
forth at the immortal trying to land a kick,
but Ran comfortably weaves out of the way.
Hoping into an unrealistically messed up posed,
Ran confirms his sisters comments as he’d
restructured the palace before they arrived.
Apparently the Tao of inorganic material is
even easier to manipulate that of living creatures.
Constructing buildings and renovating are
all tasks that actually fall to Ran, so its
even easier for him to control it than the
others.
With that he creates some spikes from the
floor that trap Mei leaving her with no where
to run as he slowly closes in.
Needing to protect Mei, Gabimaru decides to
fight Ran but is unable to harm him due to
not possessing the right attribute.
Yuzuriha sees an opening to attack Ran and
throws a Tao imbued kunai.
However, the kunai bounces off of his body
due to Ran cloaking himself in Tao armor.
Getting caught off-guard Ran snaps a fat double
kick that pushes both Gabi and Yuzuriha back.
Observing his Tao Gabimaru can visibly seen
the thick layer of armor protecting him from
any attacks.
The crazy thing about Ran’s armor is that
unlike traditional armor that has holes under
the armpits and other vital spots, Ran has
no gaps at all to exploit.
As he says it, his Tao and muscles are in
perfect harmony, flesh perfected.
Needing to force an opening, Gabi re enters
the battle and fights Ran vertically while
they both stand on a bunch of massive pillars.
Ran jumps at Gabi kicking away a massive chunk
of his pillar, however our man uses this to
his advantage as he picks up the rocks and
activates Ninpo: Stone Storm sending them
rocketing back at the immortal.
Not phased due to the elemental diff, Ran
just returns the ability by kicking them at
Gabi causing him to drop to the ground.
Gabimaru then tells Yuzuriha that it was time
to begin their next strategy.
Confused after hearing this Ran examines his
Tao and notices that nothing has even changed,
so he cant see how things would also change
in the battle.
Ran readies himself to fight Gabimaru how’s
closing in, however, Gabimaru suddenly vanishes
from his site, before re-appearing and landing
a fat blow that sends the immortal tumbling
across its sanctuary.
So back before the mission began Gabimaru
explained that Tao was like a current of water
flowing around ones body, its even tangible
allowing the user to change the speed, size
and strength.
The attribute you’ve got determines which
direction your energy flows.
You have your normal ways of combating opposite
attributes, sadly though the Tao currents
of Lord Tensen are so massive that normal
rules don't apply.
Gabimaru theorizes a 3 step process to use
the enemies Tao against themselves.
Firstly you weaken your own energy around
a specific part of your body to take in their
Tao.
Then you ride the current so that the boost
of Tao spinning around your body doesn't damage
you but floats around till you can reverse
its polarity and sent it back straight at
the opponent.
In the present, Gabimaru smashes Ran into
the ground by redirecting the Tensen's Tao.
He sync’s his breathing with Ran’s and
falls into a place between tranquility and
serenity, finding the middle way allowing
him to ward of incoming blows.
Realizing that even getting grazed by one
of the immortals attacks would be brutal,
he considers starting the second step to his
plan, but decides to hold off.
Slowly healing himself Ran becomes impressed
by Gabimaru's skills with Tao, he explains
that the thick clouds of mist tend to activate
a persons hidden powers when the arrive, yet
he’s just something else, Gabi in his eyes
possesses sheer talent.
However, Gabimaru disagrees with his comment,
stating that everything that has happened
was because of everyone's efforts and the
sacrifices they made along the way for the
sole purpose of defeating Lord Tensen.
While Ran is left shocked with Gabi’s pure
determination, Sagiri quickly frees Mei from
the restraints and lets the others know they’re
gonna head for the elixir.
Screaming at them to behave themselves, Ran
swings around and attempts to stop them but
is stopped himself by Gabimaru who yells at
the others to get it done.
Still trying to get past, Ran quickly figures
that Gabi’s using his own Tao against him
and decides to suppress it, yet as soon as
he does, Yuzuriha comes in and slices the
plant man in two.
Darting forth she goes to finish the job but
is warned by Gabimaru to stop.
Ran, impressed with the skills of his enemies
decides that in light of the ritual, he is
not allowed to toy with them.
His body suddenly begins turning into a bunch
of flowers and vines before exploding into
his 4 armed Kishikai state.
Rien sits in the ritual circle and reviews
the names of the human invaders given by Chōbei.
With Zhu Jin encountering Shion and Nurugai,
Rien believes that he holds the advantage
since Shion's Wood Tao will have no effect
against Zhu Jin's Water Tao and Nurugai isn't
able to use hers yet.
Still he does sense a great deal of rage and
knows that anger can greatly increase someone's
abilities.
Also at a similar time Gantetsusai and Fuchi
face Tao Fa and Ju Fa, Rien believes that
his team will defeat them with ease as neither
of their opponents have refined their Tao.
Though he does takes note of Gabimaru as he
can sense that they need to be extremely careful
with him.
After he finishes his review, Rien presents
the completed Elixir of Life to Jofuku and
announces that once they defeat the human
invaders they will be ready to depart to the
mainland to continue with their ultimate plan.
Meanwhile, the Asaemon from the second landing
party become exhausted after travelling so
far in such a short amount of time.
After making it to the Tan pits all of them
are disgusted and disheartened once they find
what remains of Tenza and Genji.
Furious at the fact that more of his close
friends have died before he was able to save
them, Shugen states that they make for Hōrai
now, once there, everyone, the hermits and
the convicts are to be eviscerated.
Having stolen one of the special flutes the
Doshi use to control the Mōnshin, Shugen
blows it and commands them to carry him and
his crew to Hōrai at once.
Remembering their past discussion on how if
the enemy evolves redirecting its Tao will
be impossible, Gabimaru comes up with the
idea of boosting Yuzuriha's Tao imbued weapons
with his own to defeat Lord Tensen.
Back in the fight, Gabi sees Ran going to
attack and prepares to use the same plan of
redirecting his Tao.
However, he and Yuzuriha are completely dumbfounded
when a single punch from the immortals Kishikai
state blows apart the surroundings while also
knocking them back.
Following up Ran pummels the life out of Yuzuriha
and Gabi, sending our boy shooting outside
of the building and causing Yuzuriha to drop
to her knee’s severely injured.
Elsewhere as Sagiri and Mei run throughout
the palace searching for the Laboratory, Mei
notices the loud noises coming from the Dō'in
Temple and become worried for their allies.
Sagiri assures Mei that Gabimaru will be alright
since he has a backup plan but even still
the idea of him following through with that
plan worries her.
Taking things up a level, the Kishikai monster
Knee’s causing massive damage before following
up and smashing him into the ground.
Disappointed in how easily he’s being beaten,
Gabi takes note of how unlike the previous
Kishikai’s they've seen, Ran’s mind is
still in control allowing him to perform his
techniques to an even higher degree.
Despite her past warnings that when push comes
to shove she’ll dip out of the fight, Yuzuriha
lets loose her rope like ability to grab her
teammate in an attempt to try and survive.
However, Ran catches up to them and as she
realizes that if she doesn't block its the
end for her throws, Gabimaru manages to block
the attack on time.
Having had enough with this pathetic cockroach
of a human, Ran throws away any idea of using
Gabimaru for Tan and instead smashes down
breaking his guard and seemingly ending our
mans journey home.
To top it off, Ran then throws Gabi into pillar,
leaving him their to live out his final moments...
Remembering all of the times Gabi had said
that his life takes priority and that he wouldn't
die until he makes it home.
HE AGAIN REITERATES THAT THOUGHT, AS MAN ISNT
ABOUT TO END IT ALL.
No no no no...
Pricking his finger with one of the flowers
the young man chooses to to sacrifice whatever
it takes in order to return to back to the
love of his life.
Regaining his footing, Gabimaru stands back
up fully healed, while revealing his black
eye and the vine like patters that stretch
out over the left side of his face.
So the reason that Gabimaru can achieve this
state and not just bloom into a bunch of flowers
like everyone else who’s been stung is for
a very specific few reasons.
Pretty much if only a little bit of Tan makes
it into the body it has the possibility to
balance out, making someone the same as Tensen.
Gabimaru who had overheard this explanation
got everyone to accompany him to Mu Dan's
pile of bloomed flowers.
He then retrieves one of his flower stingers
and plans to receive the same powers as Chōbei
by overcoming the Arborfication, but Mei objected
to doing it at that time due to just how dangerous
the risks are.
However, Gabimaru reveals that he was already
aware of how Chōbei managed to accomplish
this feat and is willing to take the risk.
What separates Chōbei from everyone else
is that he has someone that he fights for
beside himself.
So when he’s down on his luck he finds the
strength to defy death because no matter what
he’s gotta get back to his brother.
Back with the girls, Sagiri becomes shocked
after only just learning about part 2 of his
plan, but knows that he is willing to do this
all in the hopes of returning back to this
wife.
Over in the battle Gabimaru dodges out of
the way from a few thundering punches and
kicks.
Focusing himself Gabi knows that he needs
to take out Ran before the flower takes over
his body, even still he notices that Ran’s
attacks are starting to become slower as he
consumes more Tao throughout the battle.
Yuzuriha whos still recovering from that previous
blast tells Gabi that he’s not normal, no
matter what happens, even if he dies he doesn't
stop pushing forward, all for the hope of
seeing someone that might not exist.
Turning and looking at her Gabimaru explains
that yeah he may be crazy, but there’s only
some places idiots can truly reach.
Someone who keeps a cool head and thinks logically
just wont survive, there’s times were you’ve
just got to let loose.
He compliments Yuzuriha as someone who pushes
people away on the off chance that they might
make her an idiot.
Hearing this, she becomes encouraged by Gabi
to step forth despite her wounds and fight
with her friend in a dance of death.
Knowing that his Fire Tao has no effect on
Ran's Water, Gabimaru tells Yuzuriha that
they need to rely on her Earth affinity to
defeat him.
Needing to make an opening for her, Gabi starts
off by activating his ascetic form and using
Ninpo: Demonic Firebug to throw a burst of
fire at Ran.
The immortal easily extinguishes the flames
but Gabi slides in next to him and activates
Ninpo: Burning Bridge sending a fireball rocketing
towards Rans face.
Slashing his foot back, Ran comfortably dissipates
the flames from around him, yet as he does
so Yuzuriha makes her move and latches onto
him down with her mucus strings.
Thinking thats good enough to finish him off,
Gabimaru attacks and dodges an attack Ran
makes to his tanden.
He then uses Ninpo: Ascetic Blaze in an attempt
to scorch the creature but as he looks down
at his work, see’s a hand reach through
and toss him towards Yuzuriha.
Slightly impressed Ran says that even with
this scheme of theirs its only a futile struggle
thats prolonging the inevitable and yet its
beautiful to behold.
Hearing Gabi talk some smack, Ran prepares
himself for the final bout and tells them
to show him everything they have.
Okay yeah im not gonna hit ya with 30 seconds
of techniques so re-igniting the battle, the
two shinobi then unleash their various ninjutsu
techniques in combination with each other.
Ran somehow manages to block every ability
and bushes them off but suddenly notices that
his body started to crack.
With the immortal randomly confused with what
just happened, Gabimaru reveals that his earlier
attack was meant to overstimulate Ran in order
to make him lose his sense of judgement and
timing.
Throughout the fight they were able to stall
for enough time to have the Kishikai use up
all of its Tao.
Suddenly Ran's Kishikai form explodes, revealing
his weakened and reforming state, giving Gabimaru
and Yuzuriha an opening to attack.
As the two rush in, Yuzuriha starts to feel
pain coming from her wound but tries to endure
it until they defeat Ran.
Rising back up infront of them, Gabimaru sees
that Ran had managed to cancel out his form
before completely running out of Tao.
While changing genders Ran swipes at Gabi,
making it obvious to the Ninja that he’s
trying to recover his lost Tao by cycling
between yin and yang.
He screams out to Yuzuriha to use her ability
before he recovers and hearing this, Ran reaches
out clutching down on Gabi’s shoulder telling
him that its impossible.
He knows that the wound she received earlier
is extremely deep and should she continue
with the plan, she will die...
Stopping in her tracks Yuzuriha agrees with
Ran's statement and throws her Kunai away.
Suddenly spinning around though, the QUEEN
catches her weapon and sparks up her Tao as
its time to follow through with what she came
here to do.
Slapping his hands together, the immortal
goes on the defense by forming a field of
massive spikes in an attempt to take Yuzuriha
down before she reaches him.
Putting out his hand, Gabi helps Yuzuriha
avoid the spikes by flicking her up into the
air.
She then jumps down off the ceiling and as
she perceives the remaining Tao inside of
Ran’s Tanden, annihilates it with the Earth
affinity infused kunai.
With the battle coming to and end, the immortal
being then starts to crumble away, calling
out for his brother during his pitiful demise.
After he fully turned into a bunch of foliage,
Yuzuriha warns Gabimaru about the Arborfication
process eventually taking over his body.
Still in his eyes he knew that he had no other
option if he wanted to see his wife again.
He then suggests that they catch up to Sagiri
and Mei but Yuzuriha needing to rest tells
him to leave without her.
Before leaving, Gabimaru tells Yuzuriha that
he’ll be waiting for her at the boats and
also thanks once again for saving his life
when they first encountered each other on
the island.
AHHH man this moment always gets my freaking
tear ducts rolling.
After being left alone, Yuzuriha unbuttons
her dress and removes the mucus protecting
the would she received.
Thinking to herself, she finds its sad that
she never showed her heart to anyone, till
the end she remained the same, always going
at it alone whether that be life or death...
Knowing that her life was at risk, Yuzuriha
apologizes to her deceased sister Saya.
She really really tried to live for the both
of them, but this here is the end of her road.
Remembering what she said to Senta when he
passed, she tells herself those same words.
“When it hurts go ahead and think about
whatever you want.
A pet cat, maybe?
A lover left behind?
Your family?
Pass on with that beautiful vision.
Yuzuriha then faints with a smile on her face
after thinking about Saya as her final thoughts.
(Damn that hurts every time, sorry I had to
blur some stuff and have been throughout the
video cause Yuki is crazy.
But yeah that really hurts my soul, I don't
know what false expectation id brought on
myself at this point.
Like I just thought everyone was gonna be
okay)
Nearby while Gabimaru runs, he remembers the
plan that they need at least five people of
their group to help sail one of the underground
ships and goes to push forth to the temple.
However, he stops still dropping to the ground
as the effects of the vines spread through
his body.
Beginning to crawl he remembers Yuzuriha’s
words on how the more he regenerates, the
quicker the vines will take hold.
Thinking of his and the look she’d have
on her face if she saw him now, he fully collapses
before losing consciousness.
Moments earlier in the Bōchū Jutsu sanctum,
Gantetsusai, Fuchi, and Tōma encounter Ju
Fa, Tao Fa, and Chōbei.
Seeing his brother, Chōbei puts out his hand
and informs Tōma that Lord Tensen has agreed
to make them immortal, all he has to do now
is join him.
Big G tells Tōma to leave and rejoin his
brother as he doesn't think that them gaining
one more wimp is gonna even the odd.
After saying goodbye, Tōma walks up the stairs
to finally see his brother for the first time
in days.
INSTANTLY as the BOYS see each other they
break out into a gleeful smile and slash at
the two immortals standing next to them.
The creatures try to retaliate, but the boys
are able to overcome the monsters and send
them tumbling down the stairs.
Proudly standing there, Chōbei tells his
bro that he was slow on the uptake but can
already sense that he’s come into his own.
With a fat smile on his face he thanks both
Gantetsusai and Fuchi for keeping his brother
safe and shows his gratitude by having them
take on Tao Fa, while they take on the other
immortal.
Gantetsusai and Fuchi then watch in shock
as Tao Fa regenerates from the previous attack
and expresses her disappointment in Chōbei's
betrayal.
Getting her attention Gantetsusai points his
blade towards her and asks if she wanted him
to take the pain away.
Over the other side of the room, the bro’s
then prepare to fight Ju Fa, who after recovering
becomes enraged at the fact the attacked Tao
Fa.
Let the rematch begin.
Just like last time Ju Fa believes that nothing
is going to change no matter how much they
try.
Dashing in, the brothers lay down a plethora
of strikes that the immortal manages to fend
off.
Dropping down to the floor, Tōma jumps off
Chōbei’s back and manages to land an attack
on Ju Fa.
However he uses this to catch Tōma off guard
and almost hits him with a volley of Tao energy
balls.
Having been pulled to the side in time by
his brother, the two then re-engage in a close
combat duel, slashing at the immortal and
slowly beginning to push him back.
Unable to stop the force from pushing im back,
Tōma darts in close and manages to deal a
significant strike to the monsters face, making
it realize that this battle is the complete
opposite to last time.
Just like in the battle with Ran, he then
angrily decides to ignore the ritual and take
out the two brothers.
Meanwhile on the first floor, Gantetsusai
explodes after seeing just how beautiful Tao
Fa is after losing some of her clothing.
After taking a complement from Fuchi, she
dashes at Gantetsusai and attacks him with
a strong punch, before following up and kicking
him in the head sending him crashing towards
a pillar.
She jokes that hearing some old creep gawk
over here makes the skin on her body crawl.
(even though she’s literally a 1000 years
old, anyway anyway) Calling Fuchi cute though
she offers to partake in a round of Bōchū
Jutsu with her.
AEEEE MY BROTHER However, Fuchi cuts her off
literally and declines, stating that he’s
only interested in examining the construction
of her biology.
Picking himself back up, Big G becomes excited
with the idea of spending some quality time
with Tao Fa.
Wanting to get down to business and continue
with the rite of just consumption, Tao Fa
bulks up.
The boys dart in and slash at her, but the
immortal easily takes control over the battle
comfortably dodging all of their strikes.
Jumping up Tao Fa lets loose a wave of Tao
that pushes out from all around her, flinging
our guys across the room.
Seeing as they cannot defeat her by normal
means, Fuchi suggests that they formulate
a strategy to fight against her ability to
use Tao.
However, Gantetsusai screams frustrated with
the notion of Tao, having heard the word a
million times isn't gonna change anything
in his eyes, plus he cant even remember half
the stuff that goes into it.
Instead he just wants to have fun, he runs
at the immortal trying his best to take her
out while she simultaneously mocks him for
not being able to use Tao.
She shows him the advantage to using Tao,
kicking him in the back while she stood behind
him.
Floating up Tao Fa lands just a simple tap
to Gantetsusai’s face, but the resulting
blast sends forth a flurry of Tao kicks that
leave him on the ground.
Dancing around him, relentlessly mocking him
she just tells him to give up, however Gantetsusai
refuses and comments on how she must've had
fun toying with humans for the past 1,000
years.
After hearing this statement, Tao Fa loses
her smile and expresses that all of this time
they’ve trained to achieve immortality,
they lure humans over and over and over again
for a thousand yes.
Yet still, even now they haven't been able
to achieve perfect immortal bodies.
They’ve all realized it, its just that if
she stops smiling now, she’ll completely
lose her mind or maybe she already has.
She then attacks the two with another blast
of Tao and disagrees with Gantetsusai's statement
saying that the whole process isn't fun at
all.
Having properly experienced Tao for the fist
time, Fuchi picks himself up and imagines
the breakthroughs he can make to medical science
with this knowledge he just gained.
Also feeling a little different Gantetsusai
stands up excited to continue with the battle.
Initially confused, Tao Fa is astonished by
there enemies ambitions that causes them to
continue fighting and senses their Tao surging
around them.
Sprinting at the immortal now, Tao Fa launches
another invisible projectile towards Gantetsusai.
However, he briefly senses her the attack
and dodges, shocking the immortal who then
receives a fatal blow.
So back before they all left for the palace,
Shion explained to Nurugai, Fuchi, and Gantetsusai
that they were unable to sense Tao because
they depend to much on their eyes in battle.
To use Tao, one must detach themselves from
reality and all the body to embrace the sensation.
Laying there not participating in learning,
Gantetsusai explains he only believes in things
that he can cut while Fuchi explains that
he can only accept things that he can touch.
In the present day, after managing to land
his first attack on Tao Fa, Gantetsusai figures
that he can use this weird technique, only
for the Tensen to instantly retaliate sending
him shooting into a pillar saying that it
was probably just luck.
Fuchi comes in from behind and manages to
push her away from Gantetsusai as he recovers,
however, she suddenly appears right infront
of him and hits him with a point blank attack
before grabbing him by the neck and blasting
him with another flurry of energy balls.
Tao Fa drops Fuchi allowing him to get back
while she comments on how sweet the lengths
he was willing to go to in order to help his
"friend".
Battered and bruised, Fuchi says that Gantetsusai
wasn't his friend, yet in that moment he falls
into a memory where he told big G they weren't
friends, but they also weren't so different
from each other.
This didnt apply to just him aswell, all of
the executioners at the end of the day are
just human and if they make connections with
someone it leads to genuine feelings just
like anyone else.
In the short time they’ve spent together
he was able to observe that the samurai were
no different from the convicts, everyone is
made of skin and bone with an innate desire
to live.
From the bottom of his little heart Fuchi
wished that Gantetsusai along with everyone
else would return home safely, even if they
never spoke again after that day.
Watching the little man infront of him just
standing there, Gantetsusai senses that he’s
in massive danger AND LIKE THE MADLAD he is
rips out his eye.
Back just before when he dodged that blast
he knew that he was relying on sensation and
NOT SIGHT.
Now though, mans on a completely different
level and can perceive everything around him
through the use of Tao.
He quickly grabs Fuchi and dives out of the
way before another volley of energy balls
could take them out.
Stepping back into the frey, Gantetsusai screams
that every attack she hits him with only increases
his strength and now he’s eager to let loose.
Flashing back into the past after our man
big Gantetsusai was defeated by his former
master.
Turns out our big mans actual name is Tetsunosuke,
sitting there he wonders how his master was
able to defeat him despite being an old cripple.
Knowing that his pupil wants to learn more,
his master explains to the young man that
he has become greedy with wanting to become
stronger and tells him that he must let go
of his strength, then let go of it some more
and he’ll finally find everything he wants.
Thinking on that statement some more, Gantetsusai
re-iterates that he didnt have a clue what
his master meant back then.
Yet now after a life of mistakes he finally
gets it, the more you gain, the harder it
gets to take a good look at yourself.
In the present, Gantetsusai manages to dodge
Tao Fa's projectiles and continuously strikes
away at he, not giving her a chance to regenerate.
However, his attacks are unable to stop her
from reviving as sadly Gantetsusai doesn't
have the right attribute to properly take
her down.
Not wanting the battle to turn into one of
attrition, Fuchi knows that only his Metal
Tao will be able to stop Tao Fa from regenerating
and jumps in to grab her so that it subsequently
weakens the immortal allowing Gantetsusai
to cut her tanden.
With time beginning to slow as big G swings
his blade towards their foe, he asks himself
if he should just trust this new sensation.
Remembering his master’s words to stare
good and hard at what's left, as in their
he’ll find everything, Gantetsusai closes
his eyes and uses a Tao infused strike to
precisely cut the immortals tanden without
harming Fuchi who continued holding her from
behind.
Meanwhile, Chōbei over in his own battle
prepares to unleash his transformation on
Ju Fa to increase his abilities but is stopped
by Tōma who believes that they can defeat
him together.
The immortal feign tells them that they are
foolish for thinking that they stand a chance
against him and his sister, to which Chōbei
explains that no matter where, what or who
they are he always crushes his opponents with
his bro covering his sides.
Becoming enraged that the pathetic livestock
wont just end this futile battle The Tensen
tells them that the only thing they have in
common is the fact that they fight better
in pairs.
Reaching out his right hand, another suddenly
reaches through the opening in the curtain
next to him.
Down below its shown that the body of Tao
Fa had begun to bloom into a tree like state
with fruit growing from each of the limb like
branches.
Apologizing to his girl, Ju Fa then begins
fusing with the other Tensen, while stating
that together they will obliterate them.
As a child, Ju Fa and Tao Fa were told that
they were special, in that they were born
as two parts of a whole.
Since then, Ju Fa developed the urge to protect
Tao Fa and always came to Mei for answers.
In one specific memory of his, Mei tells him
that it was natural for him to care for her
since they were partners, the fact that he
is able to imagine the pain she feels is perfect
proof of that!
Empathy is both the root of uneasiness and
compassion.
Yet because of what they are, its inherently
harder for them to understand or internalize
these thoughts.
Sadly though a change soon started showing
itself in Rien after he introduces the five
Tensen's to the Hōko, explaining that they
are allowed to use them to replenish their
Tao.
He then assigns them their true training art
in an attempt to help them achieve immortality.
Both of them were in my eyes disgustingly
assigned with Bochu Jutsu, like common man
they were pretty much family at this point.
During one of their I guess i've gotta call
it a training session, Tao Fa expresses her
pity in using the Hōko to replenish their
Tao.
Ju Fa agrees with her which in turn causes
Tao Fa to feel happy that he understands exactly
how she feels.
After a few centuries had passed, Ju Fa becomes
frustrated that the Hōko are on the verge
of extinction due to their Arborfication and
how Rien and Jofuku are not trying to fix
the problem.
Gui Fa which is one of the Tensen I haven't
mentioned before, suggests using the humans
from the mainland as another source.
Which just like Mu Dan says, if they don't
do exactly that then its likely they’ll
deplete their Tao over time and die.
After remembering everything that Tao Fa has
gone through, Ju Fa becomes angry and slams
the table screaming that everything they’ve
been through has been for nothing.
Looking up he suddenly starts to watch as
the Tensen's faces turn into smiling pits
of darkness.
Fearing what they’ve become he starts to
question if they’re all mad, did the endless
training drive them to insanity?
Feeling broken inside he just ponders the
thought that maybe its him and Tao Fa that’re
the crazy ones.
Later, he walks down to the floodgate and
sees that Mu Dan and Tao Fa are preparing
to send out an Arborified Hōko to lure in
humans to the island.
Ju Fa asks his girl if she was okay with doing
this, as after all she had in the past stated
that she didnt like treating the Hoko this
way.
Turning around with a beautiful open smile
on her face she confirms, answering with yes
while asking if this was crazy of her.
Kneeling down next to her, Ju Fa puts his
arm around Tao Fa and tells her that she wasn't
crazy.
The humans are like the Hoko, lower than the
livestock and fit for their use.
Thinking if he’s indeed crazy, he pushes
it to the side stating, instead its the world
around them thats gone mad.
Sadly back in the present with the two finally
becoming one and transforming into their Kishikai
states, they look down with their own crazy
transformation telling the pathetic humans
that they’re nothing more than livestock.
Daaaaamn I always feel so bad fo Ju Fa man
just wanted his girl to be happy, so he’s
followed her till the ends of the earth.
Absolute respect!
Anyways
Having fused together into their destructive
embodiment of love, the duo emit and ear piercing
screech causing Chōbei, Tōma, Gantetsusai
and Fuchi’s to immediately protect their
ears.
Chōbei throws his sword to attack but misses
as the monster flies up breaking through the
ceiling of the palace before ominously floating
above them in the nights sky.
Confused Fuchi begins to wonder how the monster
is able to fly with an unnatural proportion,
however the way it captivates his thoughts
makes him feel as though its the embodiment
of love itself.
Gantetsusai mocks Chōbei's earlier attack
causing our bandit king to claim that he’ll
fight big g next after defeating the monster.
Fuchi tells Gantetsusai that he needed to
administer first aid before he could fight
again, however, he refuses and says that his
only focus is on defeating the immortals.
Looking at his friend though, Fuchi watches
as Gantetsusai starts to laugh uncontrollably.
Quickly realizing what's causing it, he sees
that one of the spores the monster had sneakily
let loose managed to sink into Gantetsusai's
neck.
Having managed to not get hit himself, he
removes the barb and tells the other that
they need to get under cover.
Chōbei knowing that he needs to break this
stalemate prepares to jump up and fight the
monster.
He transforms and sends forth a couple of
vines that allow him to get ahold of the immortal.
Hanging there he then morphs his hand into
a massive battle axe and cuts Tao Fa's tanden
with his vines, making him realize that his
Metal affinity dominates one of the immortals
wood.
Randomly splitting itself inhalf, the immortal
then sends a lightning fast barrage towards
Chōbei, which connects and manages to skewer
him.
Then picking it up a notch, the creature boosts
itself forwards before using that momentum
to send Chōbei flying across the area and
back through a building.
Gantetsusai mocks Chōbei once again while
next to him Tōma panics thinking that her
brother is in danger.
Fuchi calms them down and says that there
is no way they could slash the monster in
one slice so in order to defeat it they have
to work together.
Big G and the Bandit king exchange some half
assed insults about working with each other,
yet as soon as the creature tries to attack
them, they turn their anger towards it and
deflect its attack.
Fuchi like the calm headed G he is, kinda
just realized Fuchi literally replaced Senta
as a character with his entirety, except unlike
Senta he isn't afraid to inflict injury.
Oh well he reminds them that their enemy is
the Kishikai amalgamation in front of them
and that they can focus on fighting each other
later.
Finally stepping forth with everyone now planning
to work together Chōbei, Tōma, Gantetsusai
and Fuchi all vow to win.
With all of the others standing behind him
Chōbei transforms and blocks the monsters
vine attack.
Growing some more branches, the immortal shoots
some stingers towards the group, but the bandit
throws himself infront of them to save his
bro from being hit.
While stuck dazed wondering if he can even
handle this foe, Chōbei reviews the elemental
attribute cycle and knows that because of
the secret technique he has in store hes the
only who can actually finish the immortals.
Ju Fa sprouts an extra vine to attack Chōbei
but suddenly its sliced in half by Tōma.
He then grabs Fuchi's hand in order to strengthen
his Metal Tao and darts forth with him to
slice Tao Fa's tanden.
Getting in close, Tōma uses Fuchi’s momentum
and flings him in close enough so that he’s
able to land a slice on the Tanden.
Sensing an opportunity, Gantetsusai jumps
in to deliver his attack but accidentally
slips and falls into the pool as the monster
itself once again flies up into the sky.
Standing there Chōbei sees Tōma arguing
with Gantetsusai and remembers how throughout
there lives, he’s never seen this side of
him.
Throughout their childhood he was always someone
who could only ever follow in someone's footsteps,
but now hes noticed that his brother has slowly
started to become his own person.
Realizing they should probably be focusing
on the battle, Chōbei points everyone's attention
up to the newly evolved monster still floating
in the sky.
Knowing that they can't defeat the monster
without destroying both tandens simultaneously,
Chōbei assigns himself with Gantetsusai in
order kill Ju Fa with strategy he has planned,
while the leftovers; Tōma and Fuchi deal
with Tao Fa.
Reverting back to Simpoma he asks his brother
what he should do, Chōbei though punches
him on the head demanding that he make his
own decisions now, since he has faith in his
abilities.
Gantetsusai isn't exactly chill about teaming
up with Chōbei and is initially reluctant
to listen to his orders but after the bandit
complements his strength man gets straight
up manipulated into fighting with him.
Chōbei looks towards the monster and notes
that they are similar for the fact that both
duo’s are willing to protect their own.
In his eyes though, Tōma has grown to the
point where he no longer needs protection
and because of that states that he will rip
them both a part so they can pass on together.
Skipping back to before the battle begun,
we see that Rien while setting up the ritual
of rite consumption told Chōbei that his
brother bears an ill omen.
Back in the present time, Chōbei, Tōma,
Gantetsusai, and Fuchi all charge towards
the Kishikai monster while constantly fending
off barrages of vines.
Turning to the small man, Gantetsusai tells
him to give him some cover as he dives forth
in an attempt to cut it down.
Seeing him get hit directly though by multiple
vines, it causes Fuchi to think that the swordsman
has almost reached his limit.
The monster launches their spores towards
Fuchi but having seen the attack in time,
is protected by Tōma who throws his own body
infront of it.
Needing to snap Fuchi out of the daze he’s
in, Tōma shakes him around and explains that
his tao is vital in their plan.
Jumping up into the sky, Chōbei notices that
everyone is on their last legs, but this is
it, they wont have another chance to win.
Claiming that he’s ready now, the big man
himself manages to sneak under the monster
through the water, before popping up and sending
a massive slash directly up through the immortal,
cutting it in half and leaving the others
with a perfect opportunity to take it down.
Fuchi, Tōma and Chōbei then come in from
both sides swinging their attacks towards
the immortals.
Ju Fa and Tao Fa try to reconnect into their
Kishikai form, but just before they are able
to do so, our team successfully destroys the
Tanden of both immortals.
Screaming for her partner, Tao Fa emerges
from the pool weakened but is quickly stopped
and held in the arms by Fuchi who tells her
to stop as these are her final moments.
Ju Fa then also climbs out of the water extremely
weakened and tries to attack Chōbei.
Since his Tao won't be able to hinder them,
Chōbei punches himself in the gut and removes
two bottles of Water Tao, that he originally
planned to use against Gabimaru.
He then pours the liquid on Ju Fa, which almost
act like an acid to stop him from regenerating.
Basking in victory, Chōbei just tells the
creature that he should have never picked
a fight with the Aza brothers.
Randomly Gantetsusai comes and finishes the
job entirely causing Chōbei to think that
the man was taking pity on the creatures,
when in all reality man really did just want
up the KD.
In our big brutes head though his thoughts
are slightly different, while remembering
Tao Fa's words from their last battle, he
kneels down and places a peach from Tao Fa's
body next to Ju Fa, thanking her for the "fun"
they had throughout their battle.
As he slowly dies and tears appear in his
eyes, Ju Fa apologizes to his girl for not
being able to protect her.
Now appearing as children (which obviously
represents the most sane and happiest time
in both of their lives, before all of the
weirdness started) Eitherway the two then
embrace each other in the afterlife with Tao
Fa saying that she was glad that he was her
partner.
Back in reality and with the battle having
been won, Fuchi wonders how the others are
currents fairing.
Then once again going back a bit earlier in
time, Sagiri and Mei encounter Gui Fa who
says that he wont attack them if they don't
move from where they are, but also adds that
he will absolutely crush them if they even
take once step forward.
After arriving, Mei pointed out that this
was the Rentan Temple, yet Rien wasn't here
so she just casually asked her fellow immortal
where they could've gone.
Gui Fa says that Rien had left not to long
ago and he was given the task to guard the
ritual circle.
Gui Fa explains that the items infront of
him are meant to tell the fortune and current
status of the humans fighting against the
other Tensen's, which is how he knew that
her and Mei were on the way.
Sagiri then reaches for her sword, causing
Gui Fa to emit their Tao towards Sagiri in
a similar manner to someone overwhelming a
person with their aura, which causes Sagiri
to collapse from the pressure.
Impressed with the fact she can still move,
Gui Fa tells that that if she does continue
to resist he will crush her.
Sagiri explains that she doesn't wish to fight
and instead places her sword on the ground
while apologizing for invading their island
along with their behaviour since then.
With that said though, she finds it pathetic
how now he tries to stop her when all along
they were purposely luring people to the island.
This conflict is merely an extension of what
they sowed and sadly with how things are now,
its only going to result in more losses.
In an attempt to prevent this, Sagiri offers
a declaration of peace between both sides,
they will leave and the immortals will allow
it to happen without delay.
Hearing this, Gui Fa drops the hold he had
over Sagiri and allows her to move.
However, he warns them that even if they return
back to Woguo it would be pointless.
Wanting to know what he meant by this, Gui
Fa explains to the two through an illusion
created with Tao, that Rien's true plan is
to depart Hōrai on a ship and release the
Paradise Butterflies on to the mainland, turning
every human into Waitanhua flowers.
Then once all of the humans had turned they
would form together into one giant Banko,
called the divine BEAST BANKO.
From that Rien can finally produce the much
sought after perfected Tan.
Hearing this shakes our girl to her core as
finally for the first time in the series someone
of normal sanity found out the truth about
Rien's maniacal plan.
Btw Waguo is the ancient Chinese name for
Japan, pronounced Wakoku in Japanese.
Funnily enough the name came about in the
3rd century and literally meant dwarf country.
Later on in the 7th century and to amend their
short shaming the Japanese people changed
the Kanji up to mean peace and harmony.
Still rambling on here but its actually crazy
how many times the names changed, like even
now there's still Nippon, Nihon, Jipang and
finally Japan itself.
ANNNYWAYS
Sagiri asks Gui Fa why?
Why would they all go to these lengths, what
could possibly be motivating them?
Gui Fa answers that they as in him and the
other Tensen, feel nothing for humans and
that they are materials for them to use in
order to make an elixir.
Hearing this change in her old friend, Mei
objects to this statement, saying that Jofuku's
original research was for the good of mankind
and using lives isn't.
Yet in the Gui Fa’s eyes, they've all changed,
ever since one specific day in which they
all tested a specific method and managed to
lure in the first group of humans to the island.
On that day they learned just how beautiful
and delicious humans truly are.
It was more than they ever expected, humans
outside of Hōrai were weak frail things,
yet they possessed far more exquisite materials.
The reason for this is because humans are
beings full of doubt and indecision, they
waver between the extremes which itself is
the essence of Tao.
Love and hate, life and death.
Due to the Tensen being born as higher beings
they simply cant fathom those aspects of Tao,
so to Gui Fa its frankly unthinkable that
they would look for a more suitable form of
immortality elixir at this point.
With the elixir completed by Rien, Gui Fa
also says that to come to an understanding
would be meaningless and all they can do now
is to try and steal more lives from the others.
Looking over his shoulder the dude then points
out that as they speak Shion's talisman is
beginning to burn up, symbolizing that in
his battle, he’s nearing the end of his
road.
In his fight with Zhu Jin, Shion manages to
cut the immortals body two hundred n fifteen
times.
Looking at the thing infront of him, he comes
to a quick conclusion that his plan is working,
the creature is beginning to slow its regeneration
speed.
Walking up to it once more, Shion absolutely
exhausted continues to attack, slicing the
thing in half once more.
After getting right above the creature, Zhu
Jin quickly springs back and manages to get
some distance between them in an attempt to
regenerate.
Nurugai goes to attack herself, but Shion
holds her back while explaining that the monster
itself is also just as knackered.
Terrorfied and unable to take him out, Zhu
Jin asks what in the world Shion is as he
defiantly isn't normal.
Remembering the moment where everything first
changed Shion grits his teeth and tells the
feign that those who steal the lives of other
willingly could never under stand, while those
who've been stolen from will never forget.
Looking like an actual 80 year old bag of
bones Zhu Jin defends themselves by attacking
the duo with the remains of all of the other
bodies that have been generated throughout
the battle.
However, Shion sees through the his opponent's
ruse and slices the Tao infused bodies to
bits.
He then jumps forth using his infamous Itto
Ryu Harvest Shower but fails to land a hit
on the fleeing immortal.
Zhu Jin initially thinks Shion misjudged the
distance between them, but the reality of
his attack was revealed when the blind king
acting like he has perfect 20/20 vision fakes
a trip to grabs the tip of his sword from
the ground and throws it towards Zhu Jin's
tanden.
Getting up from his injury Zhu Jin sees that
Shion himself is just as exhausted from using
too much of his Tao and in that moment takes
the opportunity to attack.
Nurugai runs towards Shion to assist him but
as per usual, she is told to stay back as
he doesn't want to put her in danger.
Sadly Zhu Jin uses this moment to her advantage
and seemingly crushes Shion with the Tao bodies.
Laughing out loud thinking that she's managed
to take down one of her opponents, Zhu Jin
is promptly gobsmacked as they watch Shion
slice his way out the coffin.
In utter shock at Shion's determination, Zhu
Jin asks why he would shave away at his own
life force and go so far to avenge his fallen
comrade.
Standing there utterly broken over everything
thats happened on the island, Shion explains
that he hasn't had a single chance to feel
grief or mourn, at times he even finds it
difficult to rage.
Still no matter what, he states that until
he managed to rid the earth of these pathetic
creatures, the grief, despair, NOTHING will
return to him.
He wonders how many more hundreds of cuts
itl take until he can finally put his student
and best friend to rest.
Literally just in fear for their life at this
point, the creature makes a last ditch effort
to heal itself by slipping backwards into
the water.
Coming back up its shown that somehow in just
a matter of moments Zhu Jin was able to heal
themselves by taking a leaf out of Gui Fa’s
book.
So unlike all of the others who partake in
Bochu Jutsu, Gui Fa doesn't, instead he maintains
a middle ground between both Yin and Yang.
Zhu Jin then tries something new on the side
of the Tensen's and begins to partially transform
their body into their Kishikai form.
Standing there and looking super freaking
clean, like the fit actually goes hard the
immortal taunts Shion, asking if it was still
possible for him to land all those cuts.
Just like with Tenza, Zhu Jin states that
it has accustomed to their tricks and its
fairly evident as the three begin their fight
once more that Shion and Nurugai are only
barely able to hold on against the partial
Kishikai form.
Tricks though?
this statement said by Zhu Jin hits probably
one of the saddest notes within one of our
favorite characters as that is literally who
Shion is, a trickster.
He couldn't care what this pathetic amalgamation
of leaves thought, his mother was the one
who gave him these scars.
He was always born blind, but because he was
also born as a travelling performer, it was
a necessity to trick people into giving them
some measly donations to live.
Over time he came to be known as the divine
boy who could see through anyone's swordsmanship
without even seeing.
Moving forth through his life Shion remembers
how it one day led him into the Tōdōza (which
is a real life guild for blind men to join
and the Kengyo was the highest ranking member
of that org, it lasted from the 14th century
all the through to 1871 and there was also
a female section called Gozeza.
The highest ranking member which was the Grand
Kengyo was said to have equal authority to
a Daimyo) Once that said Kengyo in Hells Paradise
heard of Shions abilities, it was through
him that he managed to end up as a student
of the Yamada clan.
To not sully his mother's honor, Shion went
along with the false backstory that he was
the illegitimate child of a famous swordsman
and kept his real past life a secret from
the Yamada clan.
Even still this fact shames him to his core.
After becoming a fully grown adult and hearing
Tenza speak his mind to Shugen about how he
should see him for what he is now, along with
watching him gradually gain acceptance despite
his past, Shion becomes inspired to be like
his student, just like how he grew him into
the man he was.
Back in the present, Shion blocks one of Zhu
Jin's attacks and states no matter what, if
its just this one IT WILL DIE BY HIS HAND,
HE WILL GLADLY GIVE HIS LIFE FOR THAT CAUSE.
Quickly leaning back he dodges Zhu Jin's lightning
Tao attack and hears them gloating about how
he does not stand a chance against their power.
Shion angrily silences Zhu Jin before they
could finish their sentence and declares that
he will defeat them.
That form is just a cheap trick that prioritizes
performance over dealing destructive blows.
He tells Nurugai to stay back as he will end
this himself, before rushing in and detaching
Zhu Jin's left hand, then in the same movement
plunges his snapped Katana deep into her Tanden.
Remembering the survivors strategy meeting
about how they need to target Lord Tensen's
plant like ovules to deal the finishing blow,
Shion disembodies Zhu Jin with his blade.
Then standing above presses his sword down
on the Tensen's ovule to end the battle.
While doing so, Shion is suddenly assaulted
by the remains of Zhu Jin sending a bunch
of vines shooting into his body.
Mei explains that they need to pull the blade
out otherwise the ovule will continue to attack
the one who holds it down.
However, Shion continues to press down on
his sword knowing that if they both die then
he will still be victorious in the end.
Nurugai worries that if Shion continues with
holding the sword down then he will die, however,
Shion tells her to stay back.
He expresses the pain he felt as he left Tenza
behind to fight for their lives and pleas
to Nurugai to leave him behind as he takes
responsibility for past his actions.
He finds it horrid that he made the correct
choice to flee in the past and now all he
can do is this, his eyes don't shed tears
so he’s unable to show how much he truly
cared.
Nurugai tries to intervene and talk to him
but Shion just demands that she flee’s,
causing her to turn and run away as tears
begin to fall from her face.
She knows exactly what her Sensei’s going
through now as she’s been in the exact same
shoes.
She could never forgive herself, instead she
thought she was the reason everyone in her
life died.
Yet after meeting Tenza, seeing his actions
and hearing him say that he was unable to
accept her reason for wanting to die, it causes
her to stop and look at the blade infront
of her.
Beginning to walk now She then sees a vision
of Tenza bending down infront of her before
standing up and gifting Nurugai back her blade.
Nurugai tries to explain her situation but
before she can even verbalize what's going
on, Tenza holds out her blade with one hand
and says that if thats the case then there's
only one thing to do.
Encouraged by her man, Nurugai grabs the blade
and boosts it back towards the palace.
Inside of the building Shion is fully covered
with the vines and sadly starting to feel
his life being eaten away.
This alone to him confirms that just like
him, the immortal is also slowly beginning
to fade away.
However, Nurugai suddenly fly's through tackling
Shion and freeing him from the death grip
he was in.
After tearing away the remaining vines, Nurugai
bear hugs her Sensei in an attempt to restore
his Tao.
Sitting there absolutely exhausted now, Nurugai
points out that the immortal is slowly regenerating,
but at this speed itl most likely take a whole
day to recover.
Shion believes that they should take it out
while its nice n easy, Nurugai objects though
and tells him that thats exactly why they've
got to leave.
If anyone even tries to get close to the creature
when its in that state then the vines will
immediately skewer anyone, so instead they
should get to the others.
Shion cant though, he finds it impossible
to leave while that specific creature still
sucks in air.
Finally...
Nurugai tells him that that isn't it, he’s
wrong.
Tenza never died with pain or regrets.
She saw it with her own eyes...
He was smiling because he knew that the people
he loved were able to escape.
It was the smile of someone who was proud
in their final moments, but also an air of
sadness, she doesn't think that he regretted
a thing about his final moments.
Walking up to him, Nurugai hugs Shion and
asks that instead of holding revenge in his
heart, he tell her all about the man that
he used to be.
After Shion looks towards the blade embedded
in Zhu Jin, he notices a reflection of Tenza
beside him and Nurugai.
Finally feeling somewhat at peace, Shion thanks
Nurugai for reasoning with him and agrees
to leave.
Back over at the ritual circle, two bottles
suddenly shatter while another slowly begins
to crack.
This here obviously indicates that instead
of the criminals or executioners, the members
of Lord Tensen have been defeated.
Noticing that the talismans remained intact
after the battles concluded, Sagiri believes
that Gabimaru and the others are still alive.
With the ritual pretty much over, Gui Fa gets
up and prepares to report to Rien.
Confused, Sagiri questions Gui Fa why they
weren't willing to avenge their comrades.
Pretty much this is just due to the fact that
these Tensen supposedly carry no emotions
or bonds with one another.
Instead their passing's were merely a larger
part of their training in the way of Yin and
Yang.
Gui Fa even reminds Mei that the same went
for her, the Tensen are beings that only ‘Seek
The Way’ no bonds or emotions, what they've
seen is only an act created by a lost child.
Confused as to why she would ever reveal herself
after leaving, Gui Fa inquires as to why she
came back.
Our lil Mei still hardly able to verbalize
herself just answers that she finally understands
what life means.
Turning back, Gui Fa just sadly responds that
he does indeed envies her.
(Honestly Gui Fa along with Ju Fa were really
the only 2 Tensen to see how messed up their
ways had become, obviously Mei understands
aswell hence why she left.
I just think the reason the other 2 didnt
is because they do truly have emotions and
never wanted to break away from what they’d
come to know.
Eitherway everyone is suddenly taken off-guard
as the palace then begins to violently shake
with Gui Fa saying that the situation has
taken a turn for the worse.
Outside its revealed that the maniacal maniac,
the order 66 merchant, Rank 2 Yamada Asaemon
Shugen riding atop his Mōnshin smashes through
the wall that made up Horai’s surroundings.
Back over with the largest squad and after
giving Gantetsusai an eyepatch to help protect
his left eye, Fuchi, Tōma, and big g have
a comedic discussion in its positioning.
Chōbei hilariously interrupts their conversation,
calling them utter fools for weeing away time,
and quickly brings their focus back to the
main issue at hand.
He reveals to them all Rien's plan of turning
every human in Japan into Tan and synchronizing
them all with the monster called Banko.
He also remembers how Rien told him that he
was confident that the other Tensen wouldn't
die, but also stated that if they did happen
to then it would not matter to him.
Chōbei listens to Gantetsusai's compliant
about how he finds the situation far too complicated
and also agrees with Fuchi's suggestion on
his eyepatch, much to the Asaemon's happiness.
Tōma getting a lil curious as to what his
bro got upto with the Tensen inquires but
is utterly shocked after Chōbei reveals that
he engaged in Bōchū Jutsu and was constantly
experimented on.
Knowing that they must stop Rien and retrieve
a ship from the floodgate to escape themselves,
Fuchi asks Chōbei if he is willing to ally
with them.
Before he could give his answer, the four
suddenly feel the room tremble.
Meanwhile, Nurugai helps Shion up so the two
can walk together while he’s still injured.
Shion ensures Nurugai that even if things
don't go as plan and they end up in the worst
possible scenario, then he will ensure that
she’s still able to survive and return home.
Edo though would not be their destination,
instead they will roam the country together.
In the current time period there are still
a fair few mountain clans that remain hidden,
maybe living that life will suit them both.
He gets down on his knees and promises that
so long as the life burns in his eyes he will
be her protector until that day comes.
The two then get into a comedic discussion
about another one of Shions blind metaphors,
when they both suddenly feel the palace starting
to shake.
After the tremors settled down, Shion is unable
to detect what caused it.
All around them though, appearing from the
darkness Iwa ninja masks break through from
the shadows, with one in front of the duo
telling them that they have been ordered by
Shugen to eliminate all convicts and any Asaemon
who have sided with them.
At the same time, Gantetsusai and the other
3 there along with a currently an unconscious
Gabimaru are surrounded by other various ninja.
Instantly the ninja around Gabi lash out in
an attempt to take him out, however, Gabimaru
wakes up and in one perfect motion takes out
all four enemies.
After looking down and realizing that it was
Iwa ninja’s he just merked, Gabimaru deduced
that the next Gabimaru is here.
So in a flashback during the first night they
camped out on the island, its shown that Sagiri
was constantly told by Gabimaru that she was
feeling sleepy, even though she denies it.
She recommends that he sleep after the battles
he fought but is quickly told that people
like him in Iwa are able to go for at least
10 days without sleep.
With this in mind she asked as to why Gabimaru
was even worried about people coming after
him.
Gabimaru tells Sagiri that he has no doubt
that they’ll track him down and find him.
Hearing him, Sagiri becomes confused by this
as like why would they go out of their way
for just one stray ninja.
So this is like Gabimaru reveals, for one
simple fact, the connotation "Gabimaru the
Hollow", is a codename meant to carry and
pass down Iwagakure's strongest shinobi.
Bruh saying Gabimaru 12 times in one sentence
here is finna make my brain implode haha,
eitherway.
Well remember when the chief found Gabi with
his merked parents, turns out that the dude
there next to him was the previous Gabimaru.
He wasn't telling our Gabi to necessarily
behold weakness, but instead the current Gabimaru
of that time who im guessing was the one who
merked our Gabi’s parents.
Otherwise how did the dude gain the position,
unless Gabi’s parents were just tryna leave
and its me who’s read it wrong but oh well.
Back when Senta was alive and during the time
Yuzuriha and him ran off to evade the flames
she actually explained this exact possibility
to the weeb king.
She went over the horrific tale of "Gabimaru
the Hollow" and how the name alone was the
only thing she new was real.
She’s almost certain she heard tales about
how even if Gabimaru was slain he still somehow
shows back up and wreaks even more havoc than
before.
Decades pass but this name never ages or dies,
its as if its as living breathing representation
of terror.
Seemingly falling into a flashback of our
Gabi’s own memories, it shows the Iwagakure
chief telling the potential young Gabimaru
candidates on how he will pick from one of
them to become the next inheritor.
During the training, the chief sets his sights
on the young Gabimaru for his impressive skills
and his lack of emotions.
Soooo Gabi used to be kinda diiiiferent, this
dumb kid threw a rock at his head one time
and well yeah ahh, Gabi didnt have middle
ground.
After finding what happened the Chief asks
the previous Gabimaru on the one who committed
this act and its assumed that our Gabi kinda
popped off.
As the early days brutalization continued,
the chief takes note of how each victim separated
the young Gabimaru from the weak so that now
only those who are like minded equals remain.
Later on, one of the shinobi comes up to Gabimaru
after becoming impressed that he carried out
a dangerous mission.
With admirers and peers that envy him, along
with having true talent, the chief decides
that Gabimaru will be the next shinobi to
inherit the alias.
The chief tells Gabimaru that he has chosen
him as the next successor and must complete
a ceremony where he has to take out the current
Gabimaru in a fight to the death.
Im assuming this is with absolute ease as
we don't even see it, the previous Gabi got
off screened by our boy in a matter of moments.
Overly enjoyed with just how broken Gabimaru
is, the chief screams in delights that he
will become history's strongest Gabimaru the
Hollow.
In the present, Shugen orders the ninja to
execute any lifeform they come across, except
the other surviving Yamada.
Then just as abruptly leaves with Isuzu and
Kiyomaru, while nearby Jikka decides guard
the rear when in all actuality mans tryna
do the least work possible.
Looking up to the ninja next to him Jikka
says that he knows this whole obey the Shogunate
concept is just a front at use to hide their
own agenda on the mission.
Thinking back this specific ninja remembers
the chief's orders to kill Gabimaru in order
to become the next "Gabimaru the Hollow" themselves.
Standing up though she tells Jikka that they
share the same goal since at the end of the
day their objective is to kill everyone else
on the island.
However, the ninja tells themselves that the
only thing that was more important than actually
taking out Gabi was to bring "him" back.
Looking up with a maniacal expression the
ninja just remembers that after all she was
the one who slaughtered everyone in his way
and took out those that were envious of his
success.
In a flashback we see the time were Gabimaru
for the first time realized who it was that
was taking out all of his competition.
After confronting her, the ninja admits to
this, she explains that they’ve been supporting
him all along from the shadows and confesses
their feelings to him, that they love him,
they'd be happy to die by his hand or kill
him.
Bruh Yuki just came out the bag with the maxed
out clingy ex gf.
Holy thats like the personification of crazy
crazy.
Also on another note, those masks all the
Ninja wear resemble ones used in Noh theater.
Noh drama is the oldest surviving form of
Japanese theater.
It combines music, dance, and acting to communicate
Buddhist themes.
The tradition began throughout the Muromachi
period with around 60 masks that originally
had religious connotations.
Funnily enough and you all probably saw this
coming, Gabi’s crazy girl we just meet wears
the mask that represents a jealous female
demon.
Back in the depths of Hōrai inside of the
floodgates, Rien senses the tremors coming
from outside and is also reported to by Gui
Fa that the other remaining Tensen have been
killed, the Rite of Just Consumption has failed,
and extremely skilled human reinforcements
have arrived.
With no other choice, Rien stages a counterattack
by sending the Dōshi out for battle while
keeping a minimum with him as protection..
As they rush towards the battlefield, Rien
reiterates that this is war, the losses and
outcome of this battle matter not, before
long everything should return to how it once
was.
Above ground now, everyone including the Doshi
riding their steeds begin throwing hands.
Seeing as how they cant manage to defeat every
fodder opponent, Gantetsusai, Fuchi, Tōma,
and Chōbei decide to instead make a run for
it.
Over in another battle, Shion procures himself
a sword from one of the ninja and is told
by Nurugai to follow her to safety.
While sprinting away themselves, Gantetsusai
lets them all know that he knows a think or
two about experiencing war.
These fights there currently in go way beyond
just pitting strength against strength.
In war living and dying is complete luck,
there's no fun about the battles and no pride
at all to be won.
Its only hell on earth and the people who
survive are only those that run, those who
have pawns do their bidding and the complete
madmen with the gods on their side.
Over with one of those madmen and as the Dōshi
army charges towards him, Shugen remembers
Eizen and is driven to cut down the entire
freaking army in only a few deadly swings.
After seeing Shugen's battle skills, Kiyomaru
asked him if had some experience with war,
however he’s quickly told by him that this
battle isn't war, its an execution to purge
the scum who dared to defy the Shoguns honorable
blade testers.
He then commands his two underlings to cut
off the enemies escape routes and slaughter
them all.
At the floodgates, Rien encounters this so
called wannabe Gabimaru and is surprised that
he couldn't detect their presence at all.
Gabi’s stalker says that they have no desire
to fight with Rien and is sure that if they
just waited here, Gabimaru himself might come
to the floodgates.
While asking if this person happens to be
from the mainland, Rien also commands the
Dōshi to take them out, however, the second
Gabimaru just like he also did with Sagiri
asks if they’d like to see some Ninjutsu?
before suddenly using Ninpō: Ascetic Blaze
to incinerate the Dōshi.
With the area around them beginning to catch
fire, the Ninja orders its clansmen to burn
all the ships except for one while they themselves
take on Rien.
Back inside of the Rentan sanctum Sagiri and
Mei are confronted by the Dōshi and Iwa Ninja.
Sagiri sees the ninjas charging towards her
and instantly defends herself by sensing their
Tao to track the flow of their movements.
While fighting off everyone, she notices that
the Dōshi don't attack Mei while the shinobi
do not attack her because of her position
in the clan.
Believing that its most likely due to the
specific orders each side was given, she comes
to the conclusion that the key to winning
lies in exploiting this weirdity.
Two Dōshi then come charging in to attack,
however, ayoooo its time, they are randomly
pulled away from the two by a random sticky
string.
Ofcourse its no one other that the snnneeeaky
kunoichi herself, Yuzuriha.
Seeing that her friend is still somehow alive
after her previous bout she runs in and gives
her a hug.
Pretty much we all got hard baited thinking
she’d passed away, when in all reality she
just had
to rest.
Noticing one random ninja, Yuzuriha then finishes
off a small group of them and explains to
Sagiri that before meeting up with them she
checked out the surrounding area’s.
The situation is probably the worst one they
could be in, right now they are seemingly
cornered by all of the battles happening around
them.
Since the shinobi were hired by the shogun,
Sagiri thinks that they could persuade them
to fight together, however, Yuzuriha tells
her that it just wasnt possible since they
are out to kill all of the criminals and reminds
Sagiri that their task for coming here has
not changed.
Sagiri knows this and points out that the
elixir is most likely at the floodgates.
Turning she asks if Mei was willing to accompany
them to confront Rien, but before she even
has the time to answer, the three are approached
by Isuzu.
Seeing Sagiri for the first time since arriving
on the island Isuzu becomes relieved, but
is shocked to see her standing next to the
criminal Yuzuriha of Keishu.
Sagiri tries to explain that she and the other
executioners had no other choice but to team
up with the criminals given their situation,
however, Isuzu pulls out a book and reads
Yuzuriha's criminal records.
She tells her that many lives were stolen
by her hands, so think of her victims, do
not dishonor them as Yuzuriha is truly a villan.
At the same time, Kiyomaru confronts Shion
and Nurugai while Jikka confronts Chōbei
and Tōma.
Isuzu explains in combination with the others
that each criminal and immortal creature are
their enemies and anyone who is willing to
help them, even the Asaemon, are also seen
as an enemy.
With that said, Isuzu asks that Sagiri move
away from Yuzuriha and come join her side.
Meanwhile, Gantetsusai and Fuchi who’d temporarily
separated themselves from the Aza Brothers
run off in an attempt to find an escape route.
Catching their attention though and slowly
appearing through shadows behind them.
Oml Shugen looks rizzed out of his freaking
mind here, like the fit is darth mall spec.
Standing there infront of them, Gantetsusai
notices just how menacing this dude is.
Realizing that Fuchi has untied his criminal's
hands, Shugen angrily demands he give him
a proper reasoning as to why.
Wondering what's up with this uptight weirdo,
Gantetsusai tries doing a similar thing like
he did with Gabi to feel out how his opponent
might fight, however, Shugen, sees through
his intentions and silences his him, telling
Gantetsusai that he only wishes to speak with
Fuchi.
Gantetsusai just stands there dumbfounded
as to who Shugen is since, unlike the other
opponents he has faced, he is unable to get
an exact read on what he’s packing.
Shugen still not over his first question yells
out to Fuchi to explain the reason why his
criminal's hands are untied.
Like we all know from everything thats happened
on the island so far, Fuchi tries telling
him that they had no other choice but to ally
themselves with the criminals due to the extreme
circumstances.
Shugen hears his reason but as he’s here
now, tells him that he no longer has to be
by Gantetsusai's side and can behead him instead.
He pleads with Fuchi to not throw away all
of the memories they have together, all the
times they spoke about anatomy and the path
that he has chosen in life.
Saddened with the reality of the situation,
Fuchi says that he also cherishes the times
he spent learning about life through his experimentations,
but also says that before coming to this island
he didnt understand the value of life, no,
not until the death of his close friend.
He instead draws his sword and apologizes
for disappointing him but what they need to
do now is focus on escaping, they can worry
about everything else later.
After drawing out his sword, Shugen is shocked
to see that Fuchi used his tsuba as Gantetsusai's
eyepatch.
To him and most other Samurai the blade is
a warriors soul, the Yamada’s soul.
Furious he screams that if he’s indeed misplaced
his soul then he’ll be forced to, but before
he can even finish his sentence man is cut
off by the BIG G who himself became dissatisfied
at the fact that Shugen just assumed he could
merc him with ease.
Instantly the two clash swords and while stuck
in the blade tussle Tamiya knows that he’s
fine and should be able to throw him around
with the size advantage.
Winning the tussle like he though, Gantetsusai
manages to knock Shugen off his feet, however
as he think’s he can take advantage of this
scenario, notices that the Samurai had legitimately
transformed into someone else.
Having gained some distance, big G instantly
closes it and goes to strike down on him but
Shugen easily blocks Gantetsusai's next attack
and takes the time to tell him about the fond
memories he had helping Yamada Asaemon Genji
with his calligraphy.
As he starts to describe Genji, Shugen’s
strength increases and causes Gantetsusai
to see him as an image of Genji.
Shugen now with this massive strength buff
deflects Gantetsusai's attack and challenges
him.
With all of the fallen and even alive Yamada
beginning to appear as spirits behind him,
Shugen states that it will not be him who
delivers the final blow, but the blades of
all Yamada Asaemon.
As the bout begins, Shugen uses Genji’s
Helm-Splitter technique to completely off
balance Gantetsusai who is unable to counter
before the Samurai disarms him.
Having lost his sword and with no other option
left, Gantetsusai tries to throw a punch,
but Shugen once again avoids the attack by
imitating Kishō's ability.
With the big guy beginning to fall over Shugen
explains the kind of man that Kishō was.
Though he rarely asserted himself into a conversation,
he was a genius when it came to foreseeing
and warding off attacks.
Stepping things up a notch, Shion suddenly
uses a combination of both Kisho’s harvest
shower and Genji’s Helm Divest in an attempt
to mortally wound the criminal.
Dropping to his knee’s, Gantetsusai says
that he wished he go to play some more, but
now he’s slowly starting to fade.
Not taking him entirely seriously, Shion screams
that mercy isn't meant for the likes of a
criminal, no.
This is an execution.
Having swung the blade down atop big G, Shugen
is left mortified to find that no one other
than Fuchi has blocked his strike.
Fuchi tries explaining that crime and evil
are not the same, Gantetsusai is a undoubtedly
a criminal, but by no means is he "evil".
He tells him that he’s just over this who
thing, he doesn't want anyone else to pass
on, even if it means turning his back on the
laws of this era.
Having heard these words, Shugen sees that
Fuchi hasn't changed since the time they first
met.
Ahh so yeah id love to go over what they got
up to just here, best buds but ya know YouTube
n all these days.
Annnyways, as we bang it back to reality Shugen
suddenly slashes Fuchi before he even has
a chance to react.
With tears beginning to fall from his face,
Shugen just remarks that he was a sublime
man to the end, someone who only ever put
those infront of himself.
Elsewhere inside the Rentan Temple, Isuzu
explains to Sagiri that she has faith in Shugen
because he upholds order.
He protects people who abide by the law and
punishes those who go against them, the level
of crime doesn't matter, in his eyes its the
standard itself that needs to be upheld.
At the same time, Chōbei and Tōma surrender,
Shion lays down his weapon, and Gabimaru is
approached by two ninja with faces resembling
the Iwagakure chief and his wife.
Back with the fallen Fuchi, Gantetsusai thinks
that its mental he’d ever go that far for
the sake of order.
Absolutely raging out at this point, Shugen
screams that no, this isn't crazy, what he
witnessed was pure determination from which
there is no return and for that reason he
condemns Tamiya a villan before seemingly
finishing it all.
Manipulating the flames themselves, Rien controls
the second Gabimaru's fire ninjutsu and uses
it against the surrounding ninja taking out
a bunch of them before they even got a chance
to react.
Dodging out of the blast herself, the female
Gabi throws a kunai at Rien which connects
directly with the immortals face, but after
it recovers immediately sees that not only
can the being use "sorcery" but is also able
to regenerate.
Thinking back to what Gabimaru said about
how no matter what the situation, an enemy
is still a physical being, if it has a conscious
mind then a strategy can be formed.
With that in mind the second Gabimaru places
out her hands onto the shoulders of some ninja
and commands them to use the last of their
life to set the ships ablaze.
Not wanting the ships to burn up otherwise
all the butterflies and the whole plan goes
up in flames, Rien tries to manipulate Tao
in an attempt to crush the ninja boarding
the ships.
Unable to stop everyone and seeing just how
tense Rien had become, the second Gabimaru
calls out that she found her love.
To her its obvious that she’s been holding
back as to not damage the surroundings, but
in reality its only the ships that cause Rien
true pain.
Pondering if its a possible love, the ninja
states that at times it can be troublesome
and at others a strength, but in this fight
here it is indeed the immortals weakness.
All of the surrounding Ninja which seemingly
keep appearing from the cracks like insects,
send a plethora shuriken towards the creature.
Rien easily blocks off the basic attack, but
is shocked to see that the Elixir of Life
has been taken from her by the second Gabimaru
who without a second thought tosses it to
another ninja and commands them to get it
outside.
As Rien tries to stop them, the second Gabimaru
activates Ninpo; Pyro Bridge to launch a torrent
of fire that completely engulfs the immortal.
Rien doesn't drop their concentration over
which ninja has the elixir and destroys them
with a shot of Tao.
However it soon comes to their attention that
one of the items they were carrying was the
squad leader's mask and the other with the
elixir escaped.
The female Gabi knows that she stands no chance
of winning when it comes to strength, but
this is war.
When someone is in an unfavorable condition
one must exploit the enemy's point of view
to create chaos, that way any outcome is possible
as in war it isn't the strong who prevail,
its the wicked and twisted.
After bringing the elixir outside, the shinobi
pulls out a massive sea shell and signals
the team that it has been acquired.
Isuzu hears the signals indicating to her
that the mission is now complete.
Yuzuriha who’s on the ground infront of
her unable deal massive damage due to still
needing to heal attempts to fight against
Isuzu without her full power.
Seeing the slimy string coming Isuzu easily
counters by kicking rubble up from the ground
below.
Sagiri quickly darts in and gets Yuzuriha
out of the way while asking her fellow executioner
to calm down as Yuzuriha is not the villain.
Utterly enraged by the fact that Sagiri just
wont listen, Isuzu responds by telling her
that even though they captured the elixir
she will not stand to see any of the criminals
alive before they leave.
Going into a small flashback, it shows that
even tho Isuzu didnt exactly have a bond with
everyone inside of the dojo she felt a connection
with Sagiri the first met since they were
females in the Yamada clan, so now to see
her teamed up with an enemy on the island
it makes her enraged.
Meanwhile, Gabimaru watches as the two shinobi,
Kinkakubō and Ginkakubō, use Transformation
Jutsu to reform their faces into the Iwagakure
chief and his wife.
Speaking as the chief he tells Gabimaru that
he has been expelled from the clan, no grave
shall bear his name as to leave the village
means that you no longer exist in reality.
Speaking of reality the same goes for his
wife, as apparently she is only an illusion
created as a scheme to help imprison his heart
inside of the clan, however it sadly backfired
in his case.
Funnily enough Gabimaru complements the two
Ninja on their adept use of transformation
Jutsu and hearing him do so makes the big
guy shudder with joy over the fact the revered
Gabimaru would say so.
Hearing the two talk to him about the next
Gabi’s instructions, our boy easily figures
that the next Gabimaru must be Shija, which
the two confirmed.
Along with this they also updated their previous
commander that Kumokiri, along with two others
had perished on the voyage to the island.
They also insisted on telling Gabimaru that
Shija was obviously the person who merced
all the other candidates and that in their
eyes they still view him as the true Gabimaru.
Finally I can let me brain rest and just refer
to the female Gabi as Shija now, holy the
idea her name wasn't mentioned until now blew
my mind when I re-read this.
Gabimaru then asks them to explain the real
reason behind why the clan was hired for this
mission, however, Kinkakubō responds saying
that the chief just works in mysterious ways.
After they also hear the massive trumpet go
off the guys let Gabi know that it informs
them that they’ve acquired the Elixir of
Life.
Then moving onto the main issue at hand, Kinkakubō
humbly asks Gabimaru to end his life as this
way the chief will remove the kill order on
him and if he wants to can make it painless
by licking the ninja’s toxic saliva.
Gabimaru found their method to be gross but
is begged by Kinkakubō to reconsider since
in their hearts they’re all allies.
Pointing out that they hadn't entered his
throwing hands range, Gabi praises them for
following the basic ninja principles.
Despite this Gabimaru flexes his bloodlust
and causes them to stumble backwards.
Somewhat annoyed Kinkakubō asked if he was
still willing to defy the chief and hearing
that Gabimaru planned to escape this place.
Kinkakubō tells him that even if he does
make it back to Japan, Yui does not exist.
Obviously our boys heard this bot ass take
how many times now?
Man just cant fathom the idea that she isn't
alive, especially since he knows the people
from Iwa specialize in psychological warfare,
so in his eyes he has to see it to believe
it.
Although they were unable to reason with him
and much to the annoyance of Gabimaru, Kinkakubō
says that he and the others are all delighted
that he refused since this gives them a chance
to fight to the death with the current Gabimaru
Iwagakure.
Everyone inside of Iwagakure looks up to him,
especially the younglings, the idea that they
all get to fight in mortal combat with him
is a dream.
Funnily enough some of the higher ranks even
dropped down to get the opportunity to become
fodder on this mission, JUST so they had the
chance to throw hands with Gabi.
Bowing their heads in honor of what's about
to come, the plethora of Genin rush towards
Gabimaru, However, using Tao sensation and
looking like he perceives everything in reality,
Gabimaru quickly deals with the ninja, dodging
in and out of all of their attacks and using
their own weapons against them.
With the fodder losers dealt with, Gabi tells
them all that Iwagakure's tactics such as
physiological warfare and numbers will not
work on him.
Kinkakubō notices that Gabimaru has become
stronger but is corrected by the ninja, saying
that no, he finally learned to become weak.
He then states that he doesn't care who he
has to fight, whether its lord Tensen or every
Iwagakure or even these new Yamada, if they
stand in his way and try to hinder him from
escape, he will obliterate everyone and everything.
Dude I laugh so damn hard at this part, like
we’ll just skip around quickly so you get
the idea.
Well as Gabimaru begins taking down the genin
who’re overly satisfied, they all introduce
themselves before instantly being merced by
our man who all the while lets them know what
they did wrong with their technique.
Training them in their final moments like
a true king.
Ending the beatdown Gabimaru takes out the
final attacking Ninja with a fat kick completely
cracking the floor their standing on.
Going byakugan mode Gabi activates his Tao
and takes the opportunity to sense the palace's
layout, revealing the skirmishes taking place
between enemies and allies.
Quickly dodging a random fodder ninja that
tried attacking from behind, he also senses
that Shija is located at the floodgates in
a boat, Sagiri is safe for the time being,
but he’s shocked to sense that Fuchi has
fallen.
Keeping the missions main priorities first,
Gabimaru ignores assisting the others to rush
towards the Rentan Temple to meet up with
Sagiri, steal the Elixir of Life from the
ninja squad, and leave through the floodgates
to reunite with his wife.
Meanwhile, Zhu Jin's plant like remains suddenly
re awaken, slowly moving it leaves the Taisoku
Temple and takes the underground water system
to eventually reach the Divine Beast, Banko.
Remembering Rien's past explanation about
how the Banko required more higher quality
Tao to stay alive and that consuming it would
be dangerous.
Zhu Jin in their half baked state throws the
warnings aside and makes its way into the
amalgamation of vines to become one with the
Divine Beast.
Erupting from the top of the palace, wood
and other remnants of it go flying everywhere
as Zhu Jin emerges completely fused with the
Divine Banko and draws everyone's attention.
At a similar time its revealed that Chōbei
allowed himself and Tōma to be captured by
the enemy as he believes its better to bide
his time rather than fight when out-numbered.
However, Chōbei bizarrely starts to feel
pain coming from his arm which as Jikka stars
to ask him what's up flowers begin uncontrollably
sprouting out from his body.
While this occurrence is happening, a captured
Dōshi walks in front of Jikka and starts
to transform back into a human.
With the dudes sentience returning he just
wonders as to where he is and the whereabouts
of his allies that he arrived here with.
At the same time, Gabimaru's Flower Tao also
starts to react and his body begins sprouting
flowers.
Looking into the distance and seeing the massive
flower monster he assumes that its most likely
got something to do with it.
At the floodgates, Rien's body also reacts
and while sensing what caused this change
finds that Zhu Jin had merged with the Divine
Banko.
The Zhu Jin-fused Banko then releases a plethora
of roots which begin to track to any large
source of Tao, transforming them into trees
in the process.
In the Rentan Temple, Sagiri notices that
Mei's body is starting to react to the Banko
causing Isuzu to rush outside and find out
what exactly happened.
Only making it to the doorway though she then
becomes horrified as she looks outside witnessing
multiple sunflower like human trees, mixed
with taller Mōnshin and Sōshin stuck in
the Zazen pose walking through them towards
the center of Hōrai.
Meanwhile, Shugen notices Gantetsusai's and
Fuchi's disappearance and instead only finds
a bed of flowers infront of him.
While this has been going on, Rien thinks
back on an old conversation he had with Ran.
In it he was saddened about how the Divine
Banko wilted, but refused any thought of ever
turning it into Tan as it was just too strong
to control.
Even for them ‘the Tensen’ it would throw
off the delicate balance of Tao that gives
them form.
Sadly because of what Zhu Jin has done everything
will start anew, endlessly they shall return
to the outset.
Just like before their hopes are dashed a
feeling one only gets while travelling between
Jigokuraku itself.
Having heard Rien state this once again, Ran
asks why he would go so far, what is he truly
trying to achieve.
Shugen who’s still looking at the flowers
infront of him realizes that both Fuchi and
Gantetsusai were covered by them and wonders
what would could've possibly caused it.
He is then found by Iwagakure shinobi who
have come to confirm that Shija was taken
out while fighting Rien but managed to stall
him momentarily and now the Tensen is about
to leave on his ship.
After getting the Elixir of life from them,
Shugen orders the ninja to uncover Gantetsusai
and Fuchi's bodies from the flowers and confirm
their status.
One Shugen had left tho and made his way to
the floodgates, an Iwagakure shinobi reforms
their face and reveals themselves to be Shija
in disguise, stating that they had substituted
themselves with another Iwagakure shinobi
allowing them to escape.
They then for good measure throw two kunai
at the flower bed to make sure that Gantetsusai
and Fuchi don't survive.
Shija jumps on a roof and once she see’s
just how messed up the area has become states
that its almost as if there on the other-side.
Seeing the massive Banko monster infront of
her she realizes that mere mortals are no
match for such a thing.
Laughing now she leaps from the building in
some hectic JoJo looking pose ready for her
otherworldly deathmatch against Gabimaru.
Shortly after, Fuchi still somehow alive wakes
up and comes to the conclusion that Shugen
must've held back as he defiantly could've
ended him then n there.
Looking over to his man, he then see that
Gantetsusai is in a terrible condition and
decides that instead of treating himself he
needs to help him.
With his hands trembling Fuchi tries focusing
on treating his wounds until he sees an apparition
of himself telling him that he should give
up since this new outlook of his on life will
not do him much good in this era.
This is an Era in which men happily surrender
their lives if a superior commands it.
One in which a Son takes pride in serving
as a Kaishaku.
Shugen is a perfect representation of this
and thats why he acts this way, he knows that
the Yamada clan is already treated like a
band of Ronin and this could cause them all
to be disowned by the Shogun.
His apparition pleads with Fuchi to know his
place as if he emerges from this, itl ruin
everything.
With Fuchi slowly beginning to fade he tells
himself that the clan does matter a lot to
him and he doesn't want it to be disbanded.
Still he believes that what he has learned
on this island matters and now he’s beginning
to lose his mind over these competing emotions.
He knows he’s that he does truly want to
support Gantetsusai, and even though Shu tried
to end his life, he doesn't blame him.
In the end he just wonders if this is what
if means to be human...
Opening his eyes himself to the sound of someone
mumbling, Gantetsusai instant rises to his
knees and panics seeing Fuchi lying down dead,
realizing that he had gave everything he had
to heal him.
Screaming at him he asks if Yamada Asaemon
Fuchi really just went and saved his life?
Unable to open his eyes or even respond, Fuchi
just becomes delighted to hear that Gantetsusai
called him by his name for the first time.
In his last thoughts, Fuchi warns Shugen that
the survivors are not to be underestimated
since he has observed their will to continue
fighting no matter what, everything and everyone
on the island is a walking paradox.
Fuchi then happily waves goodbye as he accepts
his fate and tells us all that he hopes everyone's
dreams become realized enemies and allies
alike.
AHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHH My throat
has a meteor sized rock in it rn, that hit
harder that Senta in my books.
Dunno if its cause I loved these two guys
and their interactions the most, but seeing
him happy for everyone in the end, figuring
out how he truly felt towards people and how
he came to see that everyone was similar is
just a great way to end a character that I
initially thought was a simple replacement
for the weeb king.
Plus to those saying this show it just has
hands, like yeah a lot of it is but its also
jam packed with proper character development
on each side and enough world building so
that we don't feel like were missing out on
some massive piece of info.
Might sound crazy, but for how concise and
quickly the story is moving, its still smashing
everything I want to know and more.
Plus the ART, GOD YUKI.
Also ahh Gabimaru is still alg man just ripped
the flowers off.
Several minutes before everything went down,
Gui Fa entered the Main Temple Annex to protect
the Basin as ordered by Rien.
While looking through the flame thingy he’s
holding, Gui Fa becomes confused if this was
indeed Rien's true plan all along.
In the present, Shugen is told by the Iwagakure
shinobi to not engage the giant monsters since
their touch will cause him to be engulfed
in flowers.
Not bothered by this Shugen makes quick work
of the monster using Senta's fighting style
and cries upon thinking about his passing.
Pushing forth he notices that the Banko isn't
paying attention to him and makes a run for
it to enter Main Temple before the vines could
block his path.
Meanwhile, Sagiri, Yuzuriha, and Isuzu defend
themselves against the monsters.
Next to them and seeing as how the Tao around
is being disrupted Mei slowly begins to start
blooming herself.
and that they must do something quickly before
it is too late for her.
Yuzuriha swings up to get a good look at Zhu
Jin and after seeing that its blocking the
entrance to the floodgates with vines and
monsters, notes that it seems as if there
back at square one.
She then sees that Sagiri is trying to convince
Isuzu into cooperating with the convicts but
to no avail.
Wanting to help her she drops in and tries
her hand in persuading her.
However, Gantetsusai arrives carrying Fuchi's
body while boldly stating that they do not
need to join forces with her as after all
it was Shugen who took down Fuchi.
After the group buries Fuchi in flowers, Gantetsusai
directs his anger towards Isuzu and once again
says that they don't need her help, which
Yuzuriha disagrees with.
Agreeing with him though, Isuzu says that
they do not need to cooperate, as Shugen is
here.
Members of this mission weren't chosen because
of their innate ability, rather the three
of them were ideal disposable pawns set up
for the amusement of the Shogun.
If it were a priority to them, then they would
have selected Shugen to begin with as his
power is incomparable.
Yuzuriha who knows that they need help becomes
annoyed with Isuzu’s stubbornness after
she continuously refuses and calls her a gorilla,
only for Isuzu to get hit with a fat dose
of that childhood ptsd and reply that gorillas
embody the very concept of Bushido.
Getting down on her knee’s Isuzu then intends
to commit seppuku to take responsibility for
the death of her comrades and hope’s that
her death will appease the shogun.
As everyone continues to bicker amongst each
other, Jikka arrives with Tōma, Chōbei,
Kiyomaru, Shion, Nurugai, and the Iwagakure
shinobi.
Jikka tells Isuzu that if she doesn’t return
home then the responsibility will lie in to
Shugen Kermit kermicide.
However he does also says that he just came
up with a great plan that will be able to
defeat Zhu Jin and might have a way for the
criminals to earn their freedom but needs
assistance from Gabimaru in order to do so.
Remember how I brought up that the Divine
Banko was literally the god of creation, in
creation myth earlier in the video, well now
with everything weve seen what do you all
think about that being reality in this series?
Chōbei, while suffering from Zhu Jin's effects
on his body, explains to everyone that according
to Mei the Divine Banko has spread all over
the palace and that the fragments in the air
are Tan particles from the flowers, which
will cause anyone to undergo Arborfication
if inhaled.
Mei also warns them that they have until morning
to destroy it or everyone's Tao will be disrupted
and cause them to turn into flowers.
Knowing that to stop it they have to destroy
the Tanden, Chōbei lets them all know that
he sense the Banko has five tandens of each
of the Five Elements scattered around the
grounds of Hōrai.
After remembering how he won their fight with
Ju Fa and Tao Fa, Gantetsusai predicts that
they’ll probably have to destroy all of
the Banko's tanden at the same time.
Looking around at the state of everyone, Shion
becomes concerned with their condition since
the battles with the Tensen's has left them
in bad shape to continue fighting.
As a few larger monsters roll up behind their
group, everyone easily takes care of them
destroying them in an instant.
After hearing Sagiri and Nurugai make excellent
points about needing enough Tao to destroys
the Banko and stop the monsters from pestering
them, Jikka, while lazily big chilling on
the floor, tells them that they need Gabimaru
to handle this problem.
Then out of freaking no where Sagiri ducks
after sensing a fire torrent coming from behind
her, which incinerates the monsters, and reveals
that the one and only Gabimaru has arrived.
However due to him being inflicted by the
Banko’s effects he collapses to the ground
after finally re-uniting with everyone.
With Gabimaru in a bad state, Jikka sees that
he has to change his plans and turns his attentions
to the Iwagakure shinobi beside him.
Alright cutting myself off cause i've always
wanted to explain this thingy Mangaka’s
do.
Gege does it occasionally from what i've seen
and Yuki did it here.
Its called “author's fiat" or "authorial
fiat."
It refers to a situation in storytelling,
particularly in manga, where the author introduces
a plot development or outcome simply because
they have stated it to be so, without providing
a logical or organic explanation within the
narrative itself.
Its often used to resolve complex or seemingly
unsolvable plot points, establish new rules
or abilities, or make significant changes
to the story without a clear build-up or explanation.
Some people think it can take away from the
story, but tbh I like it if its used correctly
as it can truly add to the hype of what's
to come.
I’d love to know your thoughts on it though,
so be sure to let me know down below!
Anyways back to the story!
Obviously Gabimaru was super glad to see that
Sagiri is okay since he reminds her that he
needs her in order to return and receive pardon.
Despite everyone feeling exhausted, Chōbei
says that they have to fight back no matter
what happens.
He then walks up to Gabimaru and complements
him on their first battle before stating that
given what he’s seen its fairly evident
that he’s also got something to lose.
To which our battered and bruised Gabi confidently
says that he does and that nothing else mattered
to him.
Chōbei becomes satisfied after hearing this
from him and Shion who’s close-by then looks
at Nurugai and sees that he also has something
to lose.
Jikka walks up to Isuzu, who wonders if Gabimaru
has charmed Sagiri after seeing her wanting
to help him.
She knows that she swore not to defile her
brothers legacy by working with these criminals
so instead she decides to defer and catch
up with Shugen.
With everyone onboard, Jikka prepares to discuss
the plan but wishes for Shion to explain instead,
much to his annoyance.
While Gabimaru is seemingly distracted, the
Iwagakure shinobi ready themselves while remembering
a specific shinobi principle: When going for
the kill, keep your presence suppressed, no
movements, let it all come as naturally as
breathing.
As if nothing is out of the ordinary they
all take the opportunity to attack him with
thrown kunai.
In the moments before they striked from the
shadows, Shion explained to the unaware group
that a tanden can only be destroyed by a user
with the correct Tao attribute, and Tao Restoration
will increase the attack potency.
Mei then confirms the Tao attributes of Jikka
who’s earth, Kiyomaru with metal, and Isuzu
with water Tao.
Wondering if the scruffy dude is anyone you
can count on, Yuzuriha questions Sagiri about
his skill, to which she also becomes unsure
due to the bad rumors about him.
These bad rumors btw are like that he pawned
his blade so the one he has now is trash and
often gets on the booze with the boys not
completing assignments.
While they are distracted, the Iwagakure shinobi
throw their kunai at Gabimaru in an attempt
to finish their mission.
Randomly though, Jikka notices their attack
and turns asking if they really wanna go through
with this.
So you see even Sagiri has been confused for
a while as to why Jikka is rank 3 and even
asked Shion back in the day.
Shion states that taking his personality into
account he’s the lowest of low, it was confirmed
that he sold his sword for some cash and now
only carries around a simple bamboo takemitsu
which is a sign of disrespect to the Shogun,
however he’s never once been accused of
it, due to how his blade cuts like steel.
Shion explains that one time while they were
on the booze he told him he could perceive
the truth in all things and through that manipulate
someone's momentum by applying force in certain
spots.
He claimed that it was something that went
beyond just the waves Shion was able to perceive
and in reality its fairly evident mans aligned
himself with some yin or yang as he was able
to easily reflect all of the Kunai back into
the Ninja.
Takemitsu btw refers to like a bamboo sword
carved in the shape of a Katana.
Its not the Shinai which is made up of bundled
slats or a bokken which is usually made of
heavier wood and sometimes referred to as
a bokuto.
The word Takemitsu can also be used as a pejorative
for a cheap, dull-edged blade.
With everyone stunned at what just happened,
Nurugai becomes confused because she thought
the shinobi were on their side but is told
by Jikka that he knew the shinobi were only
pretending to be allies to complete their
main objective of taking out Gabi.
Jikka confesses that he did not know whether
to side with Iwagakure or Gabimaru but after
seeing Gabi decided to stick with him thinking
that they were somewhat alike, although Gabimaru
disagrees.
Ya see Jikka tho he got a few ladies' n thats
why he thinks they’re similar.
Yuzuriha becomes convinced of Jikka's abilities
but still finds herself unable to get a good
read on him.
The group then decides to take possession
of the shinobi's equipment.
Sagiri finds herself conflicted, thinking
they have to start over with their harsh situation,
and knowing that even if they succeed they’re
all doomed to slaughter each other at the
end.
Gabimaru disagrees though as he believes there
are a few differences compared to how they
started and while looking at just how much
everyone has changed, Yuzuriha agree’s with
this illogical thinking of his, as thats when
he tends to be right.
And DAAAAMN everyone looks to fire with the
new fits, especially Chōbei dude looks so
demonic.
So everyone's’ pairings have pretty much
stayed the same, except this time instead
of being with Yuzuriha, Gabi is with Sagiri
since her wood Tao will help his fire, Yuzuriha
will stay with Mei to figure out the exact
locations of each Tanden and finally big G
will team up with Jikka to help boost his
earth Tao.
everyone well equipped and paired up, the
group sets off to destroy the tandens.
Falling into a memory of the Tensen, Zhu Jin
remembers Rien's explanation on the Rite of
Just Consumption and giggles at his poor drawings.
Ju Fa notices their smirk and reprimands them,
to which the youngling apologizes but remarks
that the cant stand the way Ju Fa picks on
them.
The Tensen knows that its all for Tao Fa’s
sake but finds it annoying he’s always on
edge trying to protect them.
Thinking on each Tensen more, Zhu Jin goes
over all of the good and bad qualities of
them and how at heart they’re truly nice
people.
Then remembering how they must work hard so
they don't fail like last time, large white
orbs begin appearing infront of her making
her think she needs to collect them all to
complete the Rite of Just Consumption.
In reality the amalgamation of Zhu Jin's Banko
begins grabbing at the surroundings doing
its best to gather as many different types
of Tao.
Having made their way to the Shu'itsu Temple,
Kiyo and Isuzu comfortably destroy a bunch
of random creatures protecting the entrance.
Isuzu starts to notice that she is getting
exhausted from staying too long in the area
and finally realizes that this is why they
had to ally with criminals.
Hearing her statement and while taking out
a few insects, Kiyomaru tells Isuzu to not
doubt Shugen's orders as he was the only one
who ever believed in them.
Shugen never judged them for coming from an
offshoot dojo or because they were young,
he trained everyone the same no matter what.
After remembering the respect Shugen showed
him, Kiyomaru reminds her of how he stood
up for her in the past and was even the person
who got her the teaching role.
Isuzu thanks Kiyomaru for reminding her about
her loyalty towards Shugen and remembers the
time Shugen pointed out the beauty in the
color of her skin.
Having cut their way through the overgrowth
outside the Palace, Isuzu breaks the door
open, rushes in and tells herself that Shugen
is in the right.
Standing there inside of the Shu'itsu Temple
the duo finally confront one of Zhu Jin's
Tandens.
After arriving at the Banko's Earth tanden,
Shion tells Nurugai to stay back as he defends
against the monsters approaching them but
quickly realizes he’s nearing his limit.
They then hear the sound of the conch from
Yuzuriha, signaling that everyone has reached
their respective tandens and can begin to
destroy them.
Seeing as how the tanden is too high up for
his sword to reach, Shion imbues Nurugai's
sword with his strengthen Tao and throws it
towards the tanden but unfortunately it only
leaves a shallow cut.
In her own dark world, Zhu Jin feels something
attack her hand but cant seem to figure out
what it is.
Reaching forth trying to grab a ball of Tao,
its shown that in reality she's controlling
monsters which are about to grab the duo.
Shion yells out to Nurugai to stay behind
him until the next sound of the horn since
her inability to use Tao puts her in danger.
Wanting to speak up, Nurugai remembers all
of the times Shion told her to stay back as
he fought alone and how he relinquished his
status as a Yamada Asaemon in front of Kiyomaru
in order to become her guardian.
He knows that due to the era he’s currently
in he has no hope of changing any of the laws
around her fate.
However a man can change himself and thats
why he decided to leave the Yamada clan, because
like the legend he is, he couldn't condone
the execution of an innocent person.
Nurugai asks Shion if he meant what he said
during that time, to which he answers yes.
After saying that she was happy to hear him
state that, Nurugai rushes in to attack the
monsters herself.
She already knows that its dangerous, and
remembers the reason as to why she cannot
perceive Tao.
So ya see in her clan they don't believe things
that cant be seen or touched.
However after thinking about what cant be
seen, and remembering the feelings she felt
towards Tenza, manages to awaken this ability
and breaks forth into the reality of gods.
Having cut down a bunch of fodder creatures
with this new technique, she tells Shion that
she needs to use her own strength to survive
and asks that he become her partner instead
of a guardian.
With a smile on his face, Shion states that
his eyes have clearly deceived him and because
his body cant take to much more, asks that
she take the lead until the next sound of
the horn rings out.
Agreeing, Nurugai rushes forth and takes the
lead.
Still unable to see, Zhu Jin becomes furious
at the random damage she keeps taking and
causes the Earth tanden to sprout multiple
bodies of Mu Dan, much to Shion and Nurugai's
shock.
While at the Wood tanden, Chōbei and Tōma
find themselves confronted by clones of Tao
Fa that have emerged from the tanden, leading
them to believe that the same is happening
to every tanden that corresponds with the
Tao attributes of that specific Tensen.
The brothers then begin to ponder on whether
they should make the choice of escaping with
the other survivors or act on Jikka's secret
plan of eliminating Shugen in order for him
to make a false report to the shogun that
they had died.
So i've held off sooo hard from saying this
earlier, but you see our friendly neighborhood
Jikka is actually what id consider to be a
first generation Yakuza.
We know for a fact that Samurai overtime did
indeed take that role throughout this period
of Japan, as with no war, they took different
routes of occupation.
Why he wants everyone gone is for the fact
man wants to be the next leader of the clan
and doing that would be perfect for him.
He wants to put this world behind him for
one of luxury instead, plus he also drops
the bomb that if Shion and Sagiri end up surviving
the bandits can take them down if they please,
but thats just a maybe.
After the clones partially transform into
their Kishikai, Chōbei prepares to fight
back but feels his body suffering from the
Banko's effects on his Tao.
He also senses that Tōma is gradually suffering
from the Tao particles in the air and tries
to think of a logical plan going forward.
Chōbei knows that its pretty much impossible
to take on both the Tao Fa army and destroy
the Tanden, plus they've got no time to do
the restore glitch effect.
Telling himself to break apart once more he
knows that he just gotta do it, originally
it was his plan to slam back the elixir with
his brother, but now he’s leaving everything
up to him without a single worry at all as
he knows he’ll win.
Watching his brother run ahead of him, Chōbei
pushes himself forth and forces vines out
of his back, front and all sides that destroys
everything around him.
Meanwhile, Gabimaru and Sagiri are approached
by Shija who has comfortably taken out all
of the Gui Fa clones.
Flashing back to the moment Gabimaru and Sagiri
confronted the Gui Fa clones, Shija comes
in and quickly disposes of the clones.
As the dust begins to fade its obvious that
she’s extremely delighted to reunite with
Gabimaru.
Gabimaru then takes the time to talk to Shija
due to knowing that the shinobi is unpredictable,
however, after hearing the sound of the conch,
Sagiri reminds him that they are running out
of time and must either have Shija cooperate
with them or take them on as an enemy.
Gabimaru tells Sagiri that he cant afford
to fight Shija with the current state he’s
in, prompting Sagiri to try to perform a Tao
Restoration on him.
Seeing this and while calling her a wench,
Shija darts in behind the two and prepares
to take out Sagiri, only to cease their assault
in an instant after being ordered by Gabimaru
to wait.
Hearing him out, Gabi just asks her to help
as he’s in great need of her strength.
With Shija having multiple personalities its
hard to know which way she’ll react.
Turns out shes been waiting for months to
hear those words.
A battle in her mind between helping the chief
or following her heart.
Happily she agrees to help Gabimaru but only
in order to truly resurrect his true self.
In a sense, she will dedicate her existence
to the sole revival of histories strongest
Gabimaru the Hollow.
As Shija rushes in to attack and despite his
previous injuries Gabimaru tells Sagiri to
take down the regenerated Gui Fa clones behind
them while he handles fighting against Shija.
Shija first starts off their attack by using
Ninpo: Hair Forged to throw multiple hair
kunai at Gabimaru.
While dodging them, Shija uses the opening
to use Ninpo: Flash Hand to push him backwards.
Gabimaru flashes out of the way of a kunai
and fights her in close quarters combat, with
the two using a multitude of technical techniques
to try and get the upper hand on the other.
Simultaneously the both of them end their
initial clash by using Ninpō: Fire Monk to
create a massive explosion.
Knowing that Shija knows more ninjutsu than
him, Gabimaru speculates that continuing to
fight with Taijutsu is more effective, however,
Shija literally word for word quotes what
Gabimaru was thinking and tells him that they
are aware of every move he makes as after
all they spent so much time observing him.
Despite this and as the two begin fighting
once more, Gabimaru tells Shija that they
are also able to read their actions with the
help of Tao.
He then purposefully takes a kick to the navel
in an attempt to send himself towards the
Banko's tanden and destroy it but ends up
only destroying the statue beneath it.
Shija sees through him and could tell that
from the very start of their fight he has
been protecting Sagiri (who they refer to
as ‘the hag’).
They then start to wonder if Gabimaru's current
state is because of the hags presence and
as she manages to get the upper hand, slamming
Gabi into the ground, Shija becomes saddened
after seeing that Gabimaru's body is suffering
from weakened Tao regeneration.
Picking up his face and staring into his eyes,
she finds it truly heartbreaking to see that
her love lost his deadly ferocity and instead
choose to protect others.
Shija then realizes in anger that Sagiri is
with Gabimaru to perform Tao Restoration and
jumps towards her direction in disgust.
Gabimaru yells out to Sagiri to run.
However, Sagiri refuses, stating that she’s
had enough, she wont stand being called a
hag anymore and prepares to face Shija alone.
Knowing that the ninja isn't an immortal,
Sagiri uses her Tao sensory to anticipate
Shija's attack, but is unable to react in
time as in an instant she appears before her
and slams her to the ground.
Having picked up a special bag earlier, Sagiri
pulls it out causing the female ninja to quickly
dart back and ask why she is allied with Gabimaru
despite her job.
Sagiri explains that yes once apon a time
she lived to a strict code, but this is no
longer the case, as an era begins to shift
its almost possible to sympathize with anyone,
not just Gabimaru, but the Tensen's and even
Iwagakure ninja.
After hearing this statement, Shija uses her
Ninpo: knotted locks, sending her hair through
the ground, before it springs up restraining
Sagiri, pinning her down.
Thinking that Sagiri wants to share a similar
experience to herself, she makes her inhale
the powder she tossed earlier.
So you see this powder is one that manipulates
ones sensations and makes them experience
an overwhelming sensation of pain.
Its often used in the training of young ninja,
which just like it shows with Shija, usually
results in only a few of the family members
surviving.
This toxin is known as nerve powder and all
in Iwagakure undergo intensive training with
it for 3 days and 3 nights until they acclimate
to the pain.
As they prepare to give Sagiri another drug
which is called never bliss and connects with
the pleasure section of the brain, Shija tells
her that all in Iwagakure are made to be numb,
stripped of their senses so that the only
feeling they have left is one of death.
Fear and despair in the face of death are
the only distinct sensation those inside the
clan feel.
Gabimaru first granted her that feeling, and
through her encounter with him she eventually
became aware of her own mortality.
Yes in it there is death which embodies life
itself, death which comes for all, true fleeting
life can only be found in that moment of parting.
Ahh Yuki back at it with the poetry, had to
change things up slightly so its not suuuper
morbid cause ya-know YouTube, but I recommend
everyone go read this for themselves as Yuki
kinda pops off with just how beautifully he
constructs a vivid image with words themselves
in someone's mind.
Usually a mangaka’s most potent tool is
their art or pencil, but sometimes Yuki is
just as great with the writing in my opinion.
With his body suffering and his Tao depleted,
as well as Sagiri being unable to combat against
Shija, Gabimaru see’s their chances of victory
slowly fade away.
Shija asks Gabimaru why he is desperately
clinging to life, to which he answers that
he desires to live a normal life with his
wife.
Shija tells Gabimaru that his wish can not
come to pass since Iwagakure will remain in
pursuit of him forever and his wife does not
exist.
Gabimaru denies the thought though as he knows
its the typical psychological warfare and
tries to buy time to recover his Tao and present
an opening for Sagiri.
Shija like shes done throughout the majority
of this bout, sees through his scheme and
pleads to Gabimaru to come to his senses as
they try to explain that his wife and the
life he shared with her is false, pure make
believe...
Back over at the main body of the Banko, Gantetsusai
focuses on preparing himself to cut down the
giant flower in front of him.
Meanwhile, Jikka who aint really that keen
to do much right now decides to lay down and
puts his faith in Gantetsusai.
Gantetsusai interprets his unfazed behavior
as a test of courage and sits down wishing
to follow along as well, which Jikka found
to be strange.
He then hears the signal to take action but
is told by Jikka that the roots will tell
them when the tandens have been destroyed
and when its the correct time to take out
the main plant.
Gantetsusai questions how he knows this and
Jikka explains that he has been able to understand
how things move ever since he was young, like
how to inflict a cut or exactly where a petal
would fall.
His moto is one of waiting as good things
are bound to come to those who wait.
Gantetsusai then senses that he is up to something
but can't seem to tell what his intentions
are.
Over with the grrrazy stalker gf, Shija explains
to Gabimaru that due to Iwagakure's influence,
no matter how hard someone craves a normal
life, its simply unattainable.
The chiefs daughter is no exception at all,
she possesses no emotions and has been merely
set up to fake a relationship with him as
a way to hide the atrocities he commits.
Her smile, taste’s, all is a deception crafted
to imprison his mind.
Cutting off the mental stuff going on right
now as I needa point out how cracked Yuki
is again, this here is a representation of
Bunraku theater
and the bodies are usually controlled by 3
different people.
Its just perfect imagery to show just how
manipulated and controlled Gabi’s life has
been.
With this in mind, she begs for Gabimaru to
revert back to his former self and throw away
any idea of a normal life.
After hearing Shija out, Sagiri awkwardly
smiles as she looks up at Gabimaru standing
back up.
Like Sagiri suspected all our boy needed was
the confirmation that she does indeed exist.
We know his Tao explodes whenever his wife
is mentioned, and for him these feelings are
tied to strength and weakness.
Due to that and because of how hells paradise
the dual forces of Yin and Yang can effect
someone's body and mind alike.
His body is then shown recovering after his
Tao becomes stabilized from the confirmation
he received of his wife truly existing.
Gabimaru remembers the words Yui imparted
to him, that this is the battle we call life
and its important to preserve a little normalcy
at all times.
Confidently he tells Shija that he always
knew his dream would come with a price, but
now he’s ready to search for a new normal
life with her by his side.
With his body back to normal, Gabimaru boldly
states to Shija that they will not have an
advantage over him and will not allow them
to get in his way no matter what.
This causes Shija to remember their past confrontation
with him when they were children where he
states the exact same thing, get in my way
and ill take you out.
Shija like the mental case she is then becomes
overjoyed with Gabimaru's newfound attitude,
screaming that this is indeed perfect.
In a past memory, Yui explains to Gabimaru
how to properly prepare chestnuts.
After Gabimaru questions the point behind
it all, Yui tells him that she doesn't quiet
understand herself, she just wanted to try
the normal way since growing up in Iwa wasn't
normal at all.
The two then sit down together to eat chestnut
rice which Yui says that she found to be "very
delicious and sweet".
Gabimaru though staring at his plate just
wonders if it really was since he wouldn't
know due to how his sense of taste is dulled.
Yui who’s sadly in the same situation then
tells him that by saying it out loud they
can at least pretend to be normal.
So for anyone who wanted to know, the dish
Yui made is called Kurigohan or chestnut rice.
Its a traditional autumn dish in japan that
adds a hint of sweetness to an otherwise basic
meal.
I just wanted to make the scene slightly sadder,
the fact they couldn't even taste the change
in food is rough.
In the present and during the current battle,
Gabimaru manages to inflict grievous damage
to Shija, who with a smile on her face realizes
that he is now fighting just like he did in
his hey-day and assumes its since he isn't
being held back by the flowers effects anymore.
Gabimaru says that he has not lost his battle
instincts, its just that the battlefield in
general for him has changed, referring to
his memories of how he could not understand
his wife's struggle.
At first he never understood why she would
do something so random, it just seemed like
meaningless drudgery to him.
What was the point of the food, the normalcy,
he could never seem to figure it out.
Looking up into his eyes, Shija figures out
that Gabimaru's "love" has no clear signs
of weaknesses, and in a last ditch effort
attacks with everything that was taught to
them by Gabi.
Darting at him, she tries to strike his vitals,
but to no avail.
Throwing a kick, Gabi effortlessly leans back
out of the way, before blocking a follow up
strike thrown by her.
Jumping back, she remembers the time Gabi
told her she’d never be able to master ascetic
blaze, before pulling her hand upto her face
and releasing a huge torrent of flames.
After using her own ascetic blaze, Shija boosts
forth, pushing the flames aside and somehow
managing to stab Gabimaru's heart.
Nonchalantly looking down at his injury Gabimaru
applauses Shija for her adept use of the ability,
explaining that if he was still human they
might've just killed him.
Now though and because he’s making it home
no matter what he grabs her hand, pulls her
in close and activates Ninpō: Ascetic blaze,
FULL FIRE completely setting the duo alight.
After being engulfed by Gabimaru's fire ninjutsu,
Shija thinks back over her sad existence,
she remembers how everyone had an admiration
for Gabi, but hers was different, something
more.
Wondering what it was she felt, she thinks
about the time she fled from Gabi when they
were children and questions if the reason
was because she feared that she might’ve
died.
As time slowly moved forth Shija caught wind
of Gabimaru being married to Yui and tries
to mirror her appearance by burning the right
side of their face.
In all reality though she's known for a while
that the pounding of her heart wasn't born
from admiration, nor from dread, but sadly
the time for that to had indeed passed.
Having collapsed to the ground with a smile
on her face, Shija with their last bit of
strength creates a large whistle from their
hair and signals all of the Iwagakure shinobi.
Asking what the signal was for, its revealed
that it was infact a cleansing ritual, one
to clear the path forth for Gabi and the last
Ninpo she’ll ever use.
They also tell him that Yui is indeed alive
and awaiting his return, apparently the chief
hadn't planned to do anything until after
they returned.
With their last breath, Shija asks Gabimaru,
that if she's ever reborn, in sickness and
in health, until death do us part, would he
face them once more, to which he answers yes
with a smile.
Shija happily thanks Gabimaru for his answer
and wishes them luck in his future battles.
Everyone thoughts on Shija?
Moving forth now, Sagiri rolls over to Gabimaru
and is told by him that they need to re-focus
their attention back onto destroying the tanden
while it is still regenerating.
With everyone around being in the prime position,
Yuzuriha sounds off the next signal and all
four teams simultaneously prepare to destroy
the tandens.
Over with the big chillers though, Jikka begins
getting back up on his feet after sensing
that the timing is right for him and Gantetsusai
to destroy the Banko.
Yeeet as Big G himself begins to stand, he
states that things might be slightly difficult,
revealing the titan sized Banko that had begun
taking on a new transformation.
In preparation to take on the transformed
monster, Jikka begins tossing off his clothing,
as a way to maintain his spiritual focus,
and asks Gantetsusai for his sword.
Gantetsusai finds it odd he doesn't have a
strong enough weapon to cut down the Zhu Jin-fused
Banko, but, after looking at his surroundings
and witnessing bodies of Zhu Jin sprouting
out of vines, Gantetsusai chooses to follow
with Jikka's plan and gives him his sword.
Yo this part is actually mental, like this
dude is him.
Using his own special intuition, Jikka senses
all the fatally wrong moves he could make
as he walks forth to take out the monster.
Eventually after casually strolling past countless
spots where he’d die in an instant, Jikka
comes to a good position with the right factors
like wind and presence around him to take
down the monster.
Finding that all is in sync now, Jikka swings
Gantetsusai's sword and successfully cuts
down the head of the Zhu Jin-fused Banko from
a distance, just like he did in the past with
the ocean monster.
Having watched this unfathomable feat Gantetsusai
becomes astonished and remembers the time
that he believed defeating monsters would
lead him down to the path of legends.
Standing in front of him now is exactly the
sort of man to go down in history as a God
Slayer.
Thinking on the past some more, he also remembers
when Fuchi freed a Dōshi and refused to explain
why.
As a baby clone of Zhu Jin approaches him
now, Gantetsusai states that he started to
understand where Fuchi was coming from and
that fighting monsters, in order to give him
a thrill in his old age, doesn't affect him
anymore.
Infront of him and having walked across a
field of flowers, Jikka steps up to the tanden
and prepares to destroy it.
Gantetsusai tries warning him that if he should
proceed then it might also have an affect
on Gabimaru and Chōbei since their Tao is
connected with the monster.
Despite being told this, Jikka ignores the
risks and destroys the Tanden.
With the Zhu Jin Banko's destroyed, all traces
of its remains start to slowly wilt away.
However, Jikka and Gantetsusai soon realize
that the giant creature is still alive.
This is due to it already being morning as
warned before by Mei, and now because of that
they must take on the task of destroying the
tandens simultaneously again.
Chōbei sees that the Wood tanden is beginning
to slowly regenerate from the sun and finds
himself to low on stamina to make another
attempt at destroying it again.
Tōma yells out suggesting to Chōbei in leaving
the monster behind and trying to find a way
off the island together.
In his eyes there's no reason in dying here
as that would make him no different to their
father.
Despite his brother's plea, Chōbei activates
his break down state one last time and uses
his vines to dig into the Wood tanden.
He knows he doesn't have the right attribute,
but skewering the roots with his vines will
allow him to cut off the regeneration to the
main body.
With only one job left, he chooses to do that
exact method with each and every location
as he can fully destroy the immortal..
His plan ends up becoming a success as everyone
around watches Chōbei’s vines burst through
all of the Tanden in each location.
One last time our Demon Bandit says breakdown
and come the hell apart... but not on himself
instead on the immortal Banko which as a result,
starts to wither away.
Having used up all his strength, Chōbei falls
to ground and hears his brother crying out
to him.
Falling into a flashback he remembers the
time he held Tōma as a baby and how he felt
like he could break apart at any second, but
still grabbed onto him for dear life.
Once realizing that he must protect him as
his older brother, Chōbei with tears in his
eyes says that he protected him, because thats
what big brothers do.
In the afterlife, Chōbei kneels down before
his parents and apologizes for the sins he
had committed in his life but was happy to
know that he was at least a good brother.
A young Chōbei then runs to his parents with
open arms as his life comes to an end... randomly
though and breaking through the light, he
notices a hand reached out to him.
After the passing of his older brother, Tōma
kneels down in grief while holding on to what
seems like a plant ovule.
Meanwhile, Mei and Yuzuriha run out of the
temple, while complaining about the foul odor
in the air, and encounter Gui Fa as a child
who’s holding on to this random Basin/Urn
looking thing.
So kicking things back off and as all of the
flowers around begin disintegrating Mei and
Yuzuriha confront Gui Fa who’s holding onto
that weird looking pot thing.
Gui Fa lets them all know that due to Jikka
cutting down the Divine Banko can senses that
not only is the Banko's Tao destroyed but
also the island's as well, hinting that the
land will soon meet its end.
The reasoning for what Zhu Jin did aswell
was explained to the humans who wouldn't have
had a clue about her want to be praised by
all of her fellow Tensen.
Btw im pretty sure I mentioned this, but when
a Tensen is in a child like state they either
speak like Mei or extremely slowly like Gui
Fa.
Yuzuriha comments on how she felt that Gui
Fa didnt seem bothered at all by the fact
the Tensen's are all dying, but is told by
him that death is not the end for them.
Every being passes from life, but their Toa
will still remain.
Even though reversing the process is insanely
hard, pretty much impossible under normal
circumstances.
The little man reveals that that they have
a chance of being revived through the Basin,
pot urn looking thing he’s holding.
Inside of the basin it holds all of the fallen
Tensen’s ovules which after 1,000 years
had passed will allow them to fully revive.
Yuzuriha who doesn't care about what happens
1000 years from now decides that it was time
for her and Mei to enter the floodgates but
is warned by Gui Fa that yes she might now
care about the future, but she better fret
about what's going to happen in the coming
hours, as Rien Cannot be stopped.
Meanwhile at the floodgates, Shugen bursts
his way through the overgrowth and grabs onto
the anchors line in an attempt to halt the
ships departure to Japan.
Idk what man was thinking and as we probably
all saw coming the line snaps allowing Rien
their safe departure.
However turns out Shugen actually tore the
rope in half himself to use the anchor as
a grappling hook to fling himself all the
way up into the boat.
Standing infront of the final boss, Shugen
states that he doesn't care what cargo he
intends to move, but he will never reach the
mainland!
Looking back at him Rien tells him the same,
in that not a single soul will leave this
island alive.
Darting at the immortal, she manages to easily
defend herself against Shugen but also tries
to hold back as to not damage the ship's interior.
Shugen screams at himself not to falter and
slashes Rien across the chest, connecting
with the tanden, but this has no effect due
to his Water Tao not being the right match
to hinder his Wood Tao.
Pointing his finger forth he then shoots a
blast of Tao which connects directly with
the spot on Shugen's chest where his heart
would be.
Sliding back while gritting his teeth, the
Yamada states that they will not fall to the
dark arts of these feigns, revealing that
somehow Rien's blast of Tao actually hit Tenza’s
headband which he’d placed under his robe.
Thinking about how Tenza saved him once more,
Shugen notes that reckless assault will only
serve him poorly.
Instead... to win he must call forth the true
essence of what it means to be a Yamada Asaemon.
Choosing to replicate the abilities of the
other Yamada to fight, Shugen bursts forth
and uses a plethora of his close friends abilities
to slash at the creature.
Rien senses something strange with Shugen's
Tao and upon receiving another cut to his
tanden from a replicated attack used by Shion,
starts to cough up blood.
Jumping back in fear, Rien is just confused
as he was sure this dudes Tao wasn't meant
to affect him.
Yet, after looking closer, realizes that Shugen
has the ability to change the attribute of
his Tao, which they always assumed was impossible.
Seeing that they have to take him seriously,
Rien drops the control they had over the flames
around them to give her full attention during
the battle.
Shugen who aint concerned with these flames
tries to attack, yet Rien who would have loved
to study this man on any other day, takes
things up a notch and severs Shugen's right
arm with a feathered fan.
She then states that the time for tinkering
is over and changes to their true form as
Yin allows for a far greater focus.
Back with the children sized Tensen, Mei asks
Gui Fa as to what exactly Rien's true goal
was.
Flashing into a dark room and using their
Tao illusion ability, Gui Fa shows Mei and
Yuzuriha what they saw earlier in Rien's laboratory.
Like remember in the last arc where he got
surprised at a revelation that wasn't expanded
on, well here its shown that not only did
he find the ovules, but also an extensive
amount of research on restoring the body of
someone, not the soul.
Then beyond that he noticed a wall that wasn't
in place, behind that unfamiliar door hidden
by an illusion was even more research and
notes that eluded to the true goal of Rien.
We all think its to merc everyone in Japan
and yes that is true, but just as everyone
reacts to these clones looking after a mysterious
crippled figure in a bed, mei lets them all
know that that person is the grand master
.
A sudden noise then breaks them out of the
illusion.
Gui Fa explains that the noise came from Rien
who’d managed to finally set sail on the
open ocean after having dealt with Shugen.
Despite the circumstance, Mei asks Gui Fa
to continue with there explanation on Jofuku's
plans.
Gui Fa tells Mei that they are making an incorrect
assumption, Jofuku had indeed died long ago
that their master had already died and had
been turned into a gold statue in order for
his body to be preserved after undergoing
Arborification.
Back in the past when they were first not
permitted to meet with the master, it wasn't
because he was busy, more that he had actually
arborified and passed from the mortal realm.
For the last 700 years Rien has worked non
stop for this day.
The way of Tao explains that the soul and
body are one and through this it led her to
believe they would have been able to revive
the soul just like any other part of a body.
Gui Fa then tells Mei and Yuzuriha that Rien's
true goal is to revive Jofuku using the Tao
of all citizens inside of Japan, not use it
to make a perfect elixir for themselves like
we originally thought.
Knowing that Jofuku was already dead and while
speaking in their native Chinese tounge, Me
asks Gui Fa who was the Hōko that they found
earlier on when getting the basin.
The little man reveals that the person was
the real body of Rien, who’d begun arborifying
in that room.
The person they’re familiar with is merely
a puppet crafted out of Tao.
The puppets insane quality is due to a level
of Tao manipulation that surpasses what every
other Tensen is capable of.
All of it points to one solid conclusion in
his eyes, Rien is not a Tensen, but infact
a human and the wife of Jofuku.
When Jofuku left ancient China with his 3000
voyagers, one of them was indeed Rien.
The Tensen all originally thought they were
an amalgamation of mystic Tao and Flower Tao,
yet this was false.
First Rien created another version of herself
and from that the other Tensen were all born.
Back when a change first started to show in
Rien, it wasn't because she was mad, but because
her body had started to under go arborification
limiting her time and only allowing her to
control the clone version of herself remotely.
Gui Fa who doesn't fully understand the matters
beyond his comprehension just calls Rien foolish
and starts to criticize the notion of love
humans have.
In his eyes it makes them pretty and cruel,
full of arrogance lacking in style, suspicious
and paranoid and even still it drives them
to sacrifice absolutely everything they already
have.
After over 1000 years of building everything,
Rien is willing to throw away everything if
it just means they get a chance at holding
their love once more.
Then with a final statement he tells them
that within two hours Rien will reach Japan
to initiate their plan.
Taking this all in, Yuzuriha panics wanting
some form of break after everything they’ve
been through.
She even questions if this is just another
trap the Tensen are trying to set up for them,
but Gui Fa explains that he’s stuck in a
paradox of his own.
He wants Rien to leave, but also wants to
save her.
Unable to understand the feelings he currently
he has, he asks Mei for her opinion on the
matter.
Before she could give her answer, Yuzuriha
hits her over the head and tells her that
they should hurry to where the others are.
As a parting gift, Gui Fa warns her that according
to the I Ching they found in Rien's room.
Which for those who forgot, I Ching allows
the Tensen to tell the fortune of specific
people.
Through this he was able to determine that
most likely, only two men and one woman will
survive, shocking Yuzuriha.
Gui Fa relies on the on this Ching to foresee
fate and those who’s names are unknown cannot
be include, but Rien themselves may be among
those counted.
One thing is for sure though, the art of I
Ching does not lie.
Having left Gui Fa, Yuzuriha and Mei then
arrive at the entrance to the floodgates with
everyone gathered (with the exception of Gantetsusai
who went ahead to try to stop Rien from departing,
as well as the absence of the Aza brothers
who have yet to return.)
Obviously this is because well he’s holding
onto the ovule of his big bro.
After discussing how they need to find a specific
ship with a light load to catch the main vessel,
the group enters the floodgates, only to be
left disappointed that all the ships have
been burned.
Looking out through the wreckages, Nurugai
spots one unharmed ship but is told by Shion
that they will not be able to use it since
the wreckage of all of the other vessels is
blocking the water from flowing and allowing
them to move out.
With everyone left hopeless, Gabimaru see’s
another vision of his wife and dives into
the water to try to remove the debris.
Jikka tries reasoning with him, but our boy
screams back that re-thinking is impossible,
he only has one goal and refuses to give up.
Wanting to help and seeing the pain in his
eyes, both Sagiri and Nurugai dive in to help,
despite it being an impossible task.
Standing behind them, our little girl Mei
thinks back to what Gui Fa asked her.
Pointing her hands forth and closing her eyes,
Yuzuriha then sees Mei about to unleash her
power, which she objects to doing since she
knows that her body will be at risk.
She pleads with her, asking if she wanted
to Talk with Rien and Jofuku, but with a smile
on her face Mei explodes and transforms into
her Kishikai, commanding everyone to get on
the ship while she handles the task of making
a path.
Ahhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhh WHY MEI
Back in the early days and while looking after
the first Humans who came to the island with
them, Mei asks Jofuku why he decided to bring
people to the island since the emperor only
seeks the elixir.
Jofuku explains to her that because Tao goes
far beyond just typical human understanding
and for that reason she shouldn't concern
herself with these difficult matters.
In another memory and after Rien finished
a session of dank Bōchū Jutsu with Jofuku,
Mei is told by her to not feel ashamed by
the practice as even the young ones will perform
this training some day, so she mustn't continue
to harbor doubts.
Then as the children grew older, she recalls
her punishment for defying Rien and how she
felt powerless to do anything about it.
She was fed up with it all, so she fled and
told herself that she was unable to make a
change, but After recalling Gui Fa's past
question as to why she returned to Hōrai,
Mei remembers that it was once again because
she was fed up with it all....
In the present, Mei explodes into her Kishikai
state and continues that she was fed up with
have fled over and over.
Not anymore though, now she flaps all five
of her massive wings and blows away the wreckage,
giving everyone a clear enough path to get
onboard the ship.
Sagiri prepares herself to yell out to Mei
in concern, but is interrupted by Gabimaru,
who begins yelling out himself, telling her
that she is running the risk of dying if she
continues to stay in her Kishikai form and
her original goal of being able to have the
normal life will fade away.
Mei then returns to normal, dropping out of
her fighting form and hugs both Sagiri and
Gabimaru individually.
She thanks both of them for everything they
have done for her, but this is how she takes
responsibility for everything.
She tells the confused Gabi and Sagiri that
watching them has a way of filling her with
courage and finally thanks Sagiri for combing
her hair, before slapping her palms together
revealing that they were actually in an illusion
and Mei had transported everyone to the ship.
As Mei uses one last gust of her wings, she
pushes the ship forth allowing them to rush
after the final boss.
In her last moments as she begins withering
away, Mei apologizes to everyone for not being
to sail off with them, to her father, to her
family, and to Rien for not realizing their
feelings after they banished her and how she
could not stop them.
Elsewhere and aboard the ship, our G, the
legend, king of the samurai, Tamiya Gantetsusai
walks his way through the flames of hell.
Over the other side of the burning ship, Rien
reclaims the Elixir of Life after finding
it lying next to the defeated Shugen.
She then wonders as to why he had it on him
but quickly dismisses the question after having
it back in her hands.
With the elixir returned, Rien sees that all
that is left to do is put her faith in the
Paradise Butterflies and becomes happy to
know that her dream will soon come true.
As things were going well in her favor, the
puppet randomly starts to feel its body suffering
due to the real Rien's Tao control starting
to lessen.
With time running short, Rien hopes that she
reaches Japan soon.
Meanwhile on the flaming deck, Gantetsusai
finds Shugen unconscious and starts to wonder
as to why his severed arm is not bleeding.
Shugen then wakes up badly injured and sees
Gantetsusai standing right in front of him
without Fuchi by his side, but soon remembers
as to why this was not the case.
Gantetsusai tells Shugen that he was glad
that he managed to wake up, since it wouldnt
have felt right to cut him while he was still
down.
Somehow Shugen manages to block the attack
on time but falls down after having been knocked
off balance losing his sword in the process.
Gantetsusai tells Shugen that its useless
for him to fight back now that he has lost
his right arm but is told by the injured Asaemon
that as a samurai he can not give up.
Just straight up annoyed Gantetsusai kicks
Shugen in the face and screams that all of
them are a band of fools, all this damn honor
and dignity forced him to cut down his own
friend.
He punches him in the face and kicks his stomach
while telling him that his ways of living
are utterly corrupt.
Shugen makes an attempt to defend himself
by swinging his sword but falls down after
losing his balance once again.
Gantetsusai turns his back on Shugen, calls
him out to be a purely pathetic samurai and
tells him that he doesn't care if he decides
to burn to death.
As he watches the blade of his sword burn
within the fire, Shugen grabs it and cauterizes
the stump of his right arm after remembering
Fuchi's advice about disinfecting a wound.
He practices getting used to swinging his
sword with his left arm in front of Gantetsusai
and recalls the time Fuchi discussed with
him how the human body is a tool and that
by searching its construction and limits one
can manipulate it as they see fit.
Gantetsusai then becomes shocked to see that
Shugen in a matter of moments managed to adapted
to using his left arm to wield his sword.
The Yamada screams to Gantetsusai that Fuchi
was caught up in his sentimentality but says
that his samurai spirit lives within him.
Falling into another memory of the past he
recalls the time where Shugen pointed out
how weird the Yamada clan was.
Fuchi tho said that even though they got rocks
thrown at them, the clan allowed him to partake
in his offbeat proclivities and for that reason
its always going to be extremely dear to him.
Shugen then proceeds to tell Gantetsusai that
someone like him can never understand a samurai's
sense of duty to protect all those they hold
dear and that he has long since abandoned
sentimentality.
After he finishes his statement, Shugen's
eyes mysteriously invert.
Not noticing this, big G points out the fact
that he sheds tears quite a lot for someone
without sentimentality and prepares to fight
him but senses something different.
Earlier before arriving at the floodgates,
Shugen senses a strange energy emitting from
the gourd containing the Elixir of Life and
becomes suspicious of its contents, prompting
him to straight up open the bottle and taste
test it for any underlying poisons.
Much to the shock of the shinobi accompany
him he spits out its remains and then declares
it to be safe for consumption.
By the time he faces Gantetsusai though its
obvious that the full effects of the elixir
is shown to have run its course as Shugen's
eyes start to change, along with his heart
beating fast.
In a moment he then darts at the elderly G
and tries to strike him down.
Comparing him to last time, Gantetsusai notices
that Shugen is able to fight properly again
as if nothing went wrong and that the way
he moves his body is similar to Fuchi's.
To him its as if he’s fighting against his
friend, which complicated things for him and
meant that he didnt defend as the fake Fuchi
sliced at his chest.
After his robe is cut, Gantetsusai sees the
bandages Fuchi used to heal him with before
his death and decides to stop fighting, keeling
down instead.
Looking at him, Shugen question if he was
ready to surrender.
Yeah in a freaking million years though, like
I think you need to understand that BIG Gantetsusai
is built differently, he tells Shugen that
he was just remembering the reason as to why
he boarded the ship in the first place and
how he never even intended to fight him.
Slowly standing up, Gantetsusai explains that
in the past he toured the provinces fighting
anyone of strength, but at some point they
never ever scratched the itch he sought to
find.
His nick name "Blade Dragon", came about after
he took down his very first monster, a Ryukotsu
known to us feeble English readers as a ship's
"keel".
With that said, Gantetsusai smiles as he brings
his sword down and slashes the ship in two
causing a massing explosion as the energy
blast connects with the ocean below.
Falling back with his wounds reopened he laughs
that he was unable to completely cut the ship
in half but figures that another attempt would
be able to.
Absolutely enraged with what's happened, Rien
floating there in the sky asks what in the
world he’s just done.
Gantetsusai that he could not stop the ship
since it is made out of Tao.
As she begins to slowly stroll towards the
duo now, Gantetsusai says that he hasn't managed
to cleave the ship in two, but he did managed
to slow her down enough for our next crew.
Guessing that his work is done, he readies
himself to get off the ship instead of continuing
to fight, stating that his life was a gift
given to him and that he will not throw it
away.
However, he does tell both Rien and Shugen
that someone else stronger than him will arrive
shortly and that he hopes their ready to face
him.
Looking over the boat and through the flames
he becomes happy to see that Gabimaru and
the squad had finally pulled up.
Gabimaru jumps onboard the ship, compliments
Gantetsusai for the work he has done, and
tells him that he will handle the task of
taking down the ship as he faces both Rien
and Shugen.
ITS THE FINAL SHOWDOWN!!!
Before boarding the ships themselves, Gabimaru
pointed out that the flames were far too strong
for everyone but him to jump onboard.
Alone and walking through the flames like
a Yamabushi Monk, Gabimaru approaches Rien
and Shugen.
Shugen standing there himself, takes note
of the setting in front of him and compares
it to the past portrait he and Eizen looked
at depicting hell.
Which just goes back to how the series is
called Jigokuraku and how that word when broken
down means 1 heaven and 2 hells.
Wonder if that also refers to the amount of
survivors on this mission 2 men and 1 woman,
could have been infront of our eyes from the
get go.
Either way lets push forth and discover how
Yuki ended this amazing series.
Nevertheless Shugen then announces that he
will for the sake of the world and the clan
punish even the devil himself.
Hearing his war cry, Gabimaru commented that
he’s already used to this hellish domain,
while Rien on the other hand just found her
situation with them to be irritating.
In an instant all of them clash blades, hands
and feet in a three way free for all.
Continuing all of them then weave through
each others strikes.
Rien blocks Gabimaru's attack and tells him
that she will not allow him to damage the
ship any further and will use everything they
have to kill him while stomping their foot
on the ninja.
Rien sees Shugen about to attack her from
behind and uses her fan to counter.
Taking things up a level, Shugen manages to
anticipates her attack using the Tao sensory
ability and comes in to strike using Shion's
Wood affinity.
However, Rien who’s just in another class
when it comes to the level of skill, stands
on the tip of Shugen's sword, telling him
as a Shinsen, the highest class of hermit,
a human such as himself will not be able to
harm her, before raising her hand and firing
a point blank invisible Tao attack.
Watching from the side, Gabimaru sees that
Rien is a lot stronger than Zhu Jin and Ran
but remembers from his conversation with Jikka
earlier that as long as Rien's priority is
keeping the ship intact he should be able
to hold his own.
In the battle though Rien becomes shocked
to see her tanden slightly cut and sees that
it was done by no one other than our queen,
Sagiri, who boarded the ship after remembering
that Gabimaru will need her help since her
Wood Tao will actually harm Rien.
After Nurugai makes a point that their best
chances at survival is fighting together,
the survivors (with the exception of Jikka
cause mans on the sneak) all decide to board
Rien's ship to take her down together.
Rien states that a gathering of humans will
do nothing to stop her, however Gabi silences
her nonsense, he already knows that they’re
just a bunch of randoms who came together.
BUT they will do anything to survive and make
it home.
Meanwhile on the survivors' ship, Jikka lays
down, while in support of his comrades, and
says that he will do his job of guarding the
ship.
Knowing that Rien's Tao is too powerful, Yuzuriha
and Gabimaru decide that the best course of
action is to try to have her deplete her Tao,
similar to how they managed to defeat Ran,
with everyone else acting as distractions.
Sprinting forth Yuzuriha makes the first attack
by using her Ninpo: concealed armor ability
in combination with Ninpo: puppet slime to
create her supreme move: Crimson confection
guard.
She knows that only two dudes and 1 chick
will survive, but pushes forth either way
and puts her faith in Sagiri and Shion, knowing
that the both of them can make the final cut
together.
Rien destroys Yuzuriha's armored soldiers
but is struck in the head after failing to
notice the sneaky Kunoichi charging towards
her.
Even still, Rien manages to simply send her
back with a Tao infused blast, however in
that moment she's caught of guard by Nurugai
who while sliding behind them, remembers Shion's
teachings in the use of Tao and cuts Rien's
left arm using Tenza's Itto-Ryu ultimate pounding
torrent technique.
With their body falling to bits, Rien quickly
reconnects it and uses the partially severed
branch arm to grab ahold of Nurugai but luckily
for our mountain warrior has her limb cut
off by the Blade Dragon..
Gabi who comes down from above notices a perfect
opportunity and in combination with Gantetsusai’s
merciless eye killer move: Skypeak Splitter
uses his secret art: Shandi gust to simultaneously
light on fire and cut the immortals tanden.
With Rien left wide open, Gabimaru calls out
to Sagiri and Shion to perform their combined
attack to destroy Rien's tanden.
Stepping forth in perfect motion, both the
Yamada use their ultimate technique: Hidden
Blade dual wheel moon to bisect the immortals
top half sending it flying up into the air
and bringing the intense battle to an end.
Jokes as if its over yet, we still got a goooood
amount to go.
In retaliation the Tensen simply claps their
hands together, revealing that she's perfectly
fine and the events that had transpired were
an illusion of Tao created by her.
Looking to her left she watches Shion falls
down infront of her.
With Sagiri stunned still, Rien walks forth
revealing that everyone (except for Shugen,
Isuzu, Kiyomaru, and Gabimaru) has fallen.
Irritated with the pathetic foolishness of
these Humans, she explains to Sagiri that
Hermits are those who touch apon the truths
of this divine plane.
The only thing that has ever remained beyond
their reach is the world of the gods themselves,
still in her eyes she will soon even reach
that state, revealing the buddha like Kishikai
state that she wields.
All that remains is the complete destruction
of Waguo.
After seeing Rien enter her Kishikai form,
Gabimaru prepares to use a technique against
her, yet, Rien instantly blasts him in the
face with a Tao lightning bolt before he is
given a chance to attack.
I just realized, its kinda like a mix of Buddha
and Raijin, but yeah.
Sagiri comes and actually manages to stab
Rien's tanden from behind but is told by the
Tensen that her Tao is far too weak to harm
her body.
Seeing that Sagiri was about to be crushed,
Shugen jumps in to save Sagiri from Rien's
Tao manipulation and orders both Isuzu and
Kiyomaru to have the criminals return to the
ship, explaining that they cannot allow a
monster to steal the Yamada clan's duty to
execute them.
WHICH IS CRAZY.
Hearing that some of that were gonna escape
allowing them to escape, Rien dismantles the
entirety of the ships exterior, while keeping
the room where Jofuku is placed intact.
As she holds on to Kiyomaru's hand, Sagiri
becomes shocked to see that the young Asaemon
has been crushed by a piece of the debris
that was previously sent flying.
Poor duuude, RIP Kiyo.
Seeing her comrade, Isuzu becomes shocked
and rushes towards their direction.
However, Rien senses her and literally takes
control of Isuzu's body, before ultimately
crushing her in front of Shugen, much to his
horror.
Screaming for both of his friends, Shugen
jumps upto where the immortal is and tries
to attack Rien in a blind fit of rage.
Sneaking up from behind as this happened,
Gabimaru grabs onto Rien and sets her ablaze
with an intense amounts of flames, which in
turn allows the meglomaniac Shugen a chance
to cut off one of Rien's arms but also as
a side effect is caught.
While trying to incinerate her, Gabimaru has
a sudden memory of Yui's face and ends up
ceases his attack, realizing that he’ll
perish if he continues.
Looking at is own hand, he then notices that
his Tao is starting to resonate with Rien's
and because of that he falls into a similar
dark world to that of Zhu Jin's before suddenly
bursting into a bundle of flowers and falling
to the ground arborified.
So back before they boarded the ship, Jikka
did his thing and made a bunch of predictions
as to how the survivors should go about fighting,
but believes that there is no solution.
Knowing that, Jikka decides to stay on the
ship as ya know they've gotta have someone
guarding it, much to Yuzuriha's annoyance.
In the present, Jikka watches the outcome
on the ship and sees that he was right on
the survivors not being able to stop Rien.
He then brings out a drinking barrel and decides
to toast to the end of humanity.
On board the skeleton of a vessel and while
watching Gabimaru arborify, Rien says that
she knows not of his ambitions, but hopes
that he has pleasant dreams and as the go
to land the finishing blow believe that all
those who are still alive will die in the
fire or will lose the will to fight as they
soon reach Japan.
Sitting there herself, Sagiri feels that she's
utterly powerless and reflects on all of the
times she has failed to do anything against
her enemies.
She then looks at Gabimaru and begins to say
she gives up, but stops in her tracks after
seeing just how bad his arborfication is.
Rising to his feet, Shugen, badly burned from
Gabimaru's flames, orders Sagiri to return
to the other ship since she cannot fight in
the state she is in.
He looks at the reflection in his blade and
to him its obvious that our girl lost her
resolve after witnessing too many of her friends
pass away.
So and since she is literally the only heir
left for the clan (apart from Jikka) he orders
her to board the other vessel as he cant afford
to lose her.
Having survived being fatally wounded, Shugen
boldly states that he will make Isuzu and
Kiyomaru proud by eternally carrying out his
clan's duty without any doubt within him.
As she senses Shugen's Tao surging, Sagiri
remembers the time Shugen congratulated her
for earning a ranking and how she will bring
about a change as a woman to the clan's male
dominant trade.
Speaking up Sagiri questions Shugen if its
even possible for people to live without doubt,
and if they do does it even translate to strength?
Over the time on this mission, she’s come
face to face with doubt over and over again.
Her doubt as well as those of the criminals,
executioners and even Tensen.
Everyone struggles and doubts themselves only
to struggle some more.
If abandoning doubt is truly the way of the
samurai, then like Shion, she rebukes the
roles and states that she isn't one in that
case.
With all of the fallen Yamada placing a hand
on her back she screams that she refuses to
leave these feelings behind and instead while
picking up her sword exclaims that TO THE
BITTER END, SHE WILL REMAIN FULL OF DOUBT
AND CONFUSION AS FOR THAT IS WHO SHE IS.
N im like hell yeah this actually gave me
the biggest spur of encouragement.
Im way to harsh on myself for my pronunciation
or the way I speak, or how bad I am at reading,
but stuff it.
Like Sagiri here im thanking Shugen for these
words as we are truly grateful to him.
Looking at her, Shugen feels this random sensation
emitting from Sagiri, its neither tranquility
or intensity but something else completely.
Sagiri herself then looks back at Gabimaru
and asks him in her mind if it was okay for
her to have faith...
In a time once passed we see Gabimaru being
introduced to the 8th daughter of the chief
Yui.
Initially she becomes spooked after Gabimaru
raises his hand towards her and pats her head
as if she's some kinda pet.
Yui questions his action, to which Gabimaru
answers that ever since that day he’d wanted
to become more open with.
But at the time it just didnt feel real, he’d
stolen lives so he thought he never qualified
for a normal life.
Yui says that she doesn’t understand where
he was coming from and tells Gabimaru that
he is still eligible to have a normal life
despite his past sins.
She notes that he seemed to be suffering some
kind of pain, but the acts of regret and reflection
are all apart of ones atonement.
She asked if it was enough that just a single
person accepted him for who he was causing
Gabi to question what she meant.
Thinking on this, Gabi believes that it is
enough and that he should accept himself for
who he is so that he can finally be free of
his burden and move on.
In the present, Sagiri raises her sword above
Gabimaru's Arborified body and tells him that
he must accept his burdens while continuing
to live on.
She then brings her sword down and executes
the roles she was initially charged with.
Momentarily, Gabimaru regains consciousness,
with his body back to normal, and finds his
own flower arborified head in front of him.
Noticing that his sense of self finally returned,
Sagiri explains that she had to amputate the
parts of his body that were deeply rooted
with vines and used the most outlandish method
of Tao Restoration by pressing his Tanden
next to hers.
While he stands there impressed with her approach,
Sagiri states that she cannot see a way to
defeat their enemy but is told by Gabimaru
that they need to keep fighting as long as
their alive, much to her satisfaction.
Gabimaru also thanks Sagiri for leading him
back towards doubt to increase the speed of
his healing.
(she did this by like guiding the thoughts
in his head, bring up his wife etc).
After Sagiri jokes about actually following
through with her original task, Gabimaru says
that they cannot rely on fate due to the risk
of failure and also readies himself to fight
alongside Sagiri.
Shion and Nurugai fall into the ocean while
carrying Gantetsusai who remains unconscious.
Jikka then tries to bring them onboard the
ship as requested by Shion but falls into
the ocean as well due to being intoxicated.
After everyone (including Yuzuriha) is brought
back on the ship, Jikka lets them know that
it would not matter if they had saved him
since he believes that Rien is utterly unstoppable.
While on the other ship, Rien senses Tao growing
from where Gabimaru and Sagiri's are, and
looks in their direction.
Jumping towards her Rien fends off a plethora
of attacks and uses a bolt of Tao lightning
as an attack but misses Sagiri after Gabimaru
pulls her out of the way.
Nurugai and Shion watch as Gabimaru and Sagiri
fight together in perfect synchronization
but also points out that they need some sort
of strategy.
Darting forth, Gabi is handed Sagiri's sword
and goes in to strike Rien's tanden.
However, Jikka notes that that strategy will
not work since the hindering attribute will
lose the necessary power needed.
Using another strategy, Gabimaru attempts
to use Sagiri as a human sword by holding
her by the legs, but quickly dismisses the
idea.
In light of their ridiculous tactics, Rien
sees that she cant afford to waste any more
time fighting them and must take down Sagiri
using her bulked up arms.
On the other side of the boat, Shugen looks
at Sagiri and remembers the time he felt worried
that she was selected for the shogun's mission.
He assumed that her kindness would be a hinderance,
but now in light of things starts to see that
it doesn't.
Sagiri remembers how Gabimaru pointed out
to her how she lost to Shija due to giving
into anger instead of focusing on the middle
path that gives Tao its power and in that
moment accepts that both strength, weakness,
and doubt make her who she is.
After her Tao is strengthen, Sagiri attacks
Rien with a clear mindset of knowing that
she is the "spear" and the “linchpin”
that will take her down while our sneaky sneaker,
Gabimaru is the spy from within the shadows,
as after all being a sneaky shinobi is what
he does best.
Moments before Sagiri made her charge and
remembering that Rien's true goal is to revive
Jofuku, Gabimaru tells her to remember what
happens when those extreme emotions take over.
It weakens their Tao.
Tao is held together by a clean discord between
both Yin and Yang, to much to either side
and the power fades.
So if her heart is filled with rage, then
maybe they have a chance.
In reality and as Sagiri is placating the
big boss, Gabimaru lands in the same room
as the gilded statue of Jo Fuku, causing the
buddha wannabe to fall directly into their
trap.
As he charges towards Jofuku's corpse, with
his Ninpō: Ascetic Blaze activated, Gabimaru
knows that when her Tao is disrupted, Sagiri
will slash her tanden.
The timing has to be perfect, but as he goes
to smash down on the floor of the boat notices
that there is a post-wedding brazier, a flower
crown, and a pair of traditional wedding garbs
laid out infront of the statue.
Stunned Gabi thinks back to when Yuzuriha
said Rein’s true goal was to revive her
master, yet after seeing what's infront of
him, Gabimaru for the first time realizes
that Rien and Jofuku are a married couple.
Beginning to falter, he tries pushing himself
forth as he knows he needs to be in perfect
sync with Sagiri and this truly is there last
moment, missing it means death.
Seeing his wife with the smile on her face
and knowing the pain that it’d cause someone
to loose their beloved, he drops to the floor
unable to follow through.
Unexpectedly, the merchant of death, sir order
66 Shugen jumps out from behind Gabimaru,
and screams that to be a samurai means being
prepared to give your life at any moment.
For DUTY is the pride of a samurai and the
pride of the Yamada Clan.
Raising up his sword he envisions Eizen doing
the same.
Free of thought till death, with singular
devotion, towards the embrace of deaths warm
grasp, he brings down his blade with the vision
of a demonic Eizen behind him, allowing him
to deal a powerful Tao-imbued sword slash
that not only slices Jofuku's gilded statue
in 2, but the entire ship itself.
Having witnessed confirmed passing of her
loved one, Rien screams in horror as her late
husband's body is destroyed, gives Sagiri
the perfect opportunity to bisect the Tensen
and destroy her plant ovule.
So with everything lining up for our girl,
she swings her own blade forth and manages
to slice the immortal Kishikai in two.
With the battle finally over, Sagiri, Gabimaru,
and Shugen are seen exhausted while the upper
half of the puppet starts to disintegrate
inside of the ocean.
Having defeating the final immortal, the ship
starts to fall apart, since the only thing
that was keeping it held together was Rien's
Tao.
After retrieving the Elixir of Life, Gabimaru
yells out to Sagiri to grab his hand while
they make their way back to the ship.
Sagiri wants to look for Shugen, but once
she turns around and sees that he has passed
away due to overexerting too much of his Tao
in his previous attack continues forth.
Randomly Gabimaru Sagiri suddenly receives
a gapping wound as if she was hit by some
sort of Tao attack directly in the stomach.
With Gabimaru left in shock he turns to sees
that the culprit is Rien, who stands before
them with her body being partially covered
in flowers.
Her only desire was to be with her husband
and now because of that she states that this
is the end of everything.
She furiously vows to Gabimaru that she will
take away everything from him and the other
humans.
Suddenly Gabimaru's left hand is then crushed
by Rien causing him to drop to the ground.
Laying there and after remembering a past
lesson from Eizen about how a Kaishaku is
needed when performing seppuku, since the
punishment does not have the victim die immediately,
Sagiri comes up with the idea of using hemostasis
on herself, but quickly concludes that it
may not work to help her recover.
She then remembers Gui Fa's past words to
her on how the only thing each side can do
now is steal lives from each other and ponders
if that is truly the only recourse.
After seeing Gabimaru punctured by Rien, Nurugai
prepares to rush over to assist him.
However, Jikka grabs her and explains her
that power will not be able to stop Rien.
Back over with the dying immortal and while
having Gabimaru suffer for his ‘crimes’,
Rien remembers how he hesitated to destroy
Jofuku's body and asks him as to why he did
so.
Gabimaru answers that in the moment he was
about to strike, an image of his wife appeared
in his mind, which caused him to end up faltering.
As Rien thinks about her lost love, Gabimaru
tries to reason with her, saying that maybe
he thought they could relate.
Having heard these words, Rien looks back
on her loving memories with Jofuku, how he
slowly started to grow old and arborify while
she till the very end stayed by his side.
Remembering the love that she once felt and
beginning to cry herself, She brings her hands
together and in a final act decides to heal
Gabimaru and Sagiri's wounds
With everyone watching, even the survivors
on the nearby boat, Rien starts to disintergrate,
turning her body into a bunch of flower petals.
In the afterlife its said that Rien who was
finally at piece managed to have her soul
reunite with her husband.
Jikka, while still intoxicated, becomes happy
with the outcome of the battle and tells Gabimaru
and Sagiri that he had faith in them all along,
much to their, as well as Shion's, Nurugai's,
and Gantetsusai's, annoyance.
On the other hand, Yuzuriha suggests in forgiving
him since he is the one in charge of steering
the ship.
Jikka becomes delighted to know that Yuzuriha
was on his side and tells them that he was
going to get back to "rowing" the ship, which
Nurugai and Yuzuriha commented on being ineffective.
As they make their way towards Edo, which
is around an hour or so away, Shion informs
everyone that he and Nurugai will not be returning
and will go their separate ways on a small
boat.
He also reminds them about their situation
with who will get the pardon upon returning.
After seeing Sagiri depressed, Yuzuriha tells
her that a happy ending was never going to
be possible for them and asks if an executioner
like her started to become fond of criminals.
Sagiri wipes a tear as she happily answers
yes, after coming to see them as people dear
to her and asks if it was wrong of her to
not know the answer to the situation.
Yuzuriha says no and points out that everyone
else besides herself was a villain, which
leads to everyone having a comical conversation
about just how villainous each person is.
After he and his wife are pointed out to be
evil, Gabimaru shocks everyone after he laughs
at the ridiculous thought of Yui being a villain.
Having become interested in knowing more about
his wife, the groups asks Gabimaru to tell
them more about her, to which he agrees.
Later, Gabimaru, Yuzuriha, Gantetsusai, and
Sagiri stand up to try and figure out who
will return with the Elixir of Life.
Shortly after, the shogun becomes informed
that a ship has returned from the island voyage
with only two men and one woman boarding.
At the magistrate, Sagiri and Jikka present
themselves to the shogun as the two only surviving
Asaemons to make it out alive and are ordered
by Aoki to make their report.
Sagiri remembers earlier back how Jikka will
take the initiative in making the report but
wonders as to what he will do.
Jikka first bows his head in gratitude for
being assigned to the mission and tells them
that, since Shugen has lost his life during
the mission, he will be the one to make the
report (covering for our boy, love to see
it).
Jikka then presents the deliverance of the
Elixir of Life and reports that the only surviving
criminal was Tamiya Gantetsusai after the
other criminals, Gabimaru, Aza Chōbei, Yuzuriha,
and Nurugai, were executed by him.
With this, Gantetsusai is then pardoned by
the shogun (and I never doubted BIG G FOR
A SECOND I knew man was gonna make it home,
like the blade dragon, aint no one killing
our man).
Before allowing Aoki to end all matters, Jikka
asks him about the arrangements that were
made concerning the Iwagakure chief.
Aoki confirms to Jikka that the Iwagakure
chief was dealt with, after the latter testified
that the leader had his own ambitions during
the mission, which was viewed as treason against
the shogun, and presents the leader's severed
head, much to Sagiri's shock.
Aoki also reports that the body of the chief
has been transformed into a tree after they
forced him to test the effects of the elixir
before beheading him, as per Jikka's suggestion.
Aoki then questions if the state of the chief
could be viewed as immortality but is convinced
by Jikka that the shogun could live forever
as a divine tree to watch over his family
in exchange for his humanity.
After their business with the shogun was over,
Jikka falls down tired and becomes pleased
that things somehow went according to plan.
Earlier on the ship, Jikka saw that Gabimaru
and Yuzuriha had picked Gantetsusai as the
one to receive the pardon due to his high
reputation and suggests that they themselves
abandon their names and former life upon separating
on boats.
Which just like Yuzuriha points out, it connects
this with the I Ching Gui Fa warned her about
on Kotaku.
As they prepare to depart, Sagiri receives
a goodbye hug from Nurugai and yells out her
farewells to Yuzuriha who happily waves back
already having started to leave on her own
vessel.
Looking over, she then sees that Gabimaru
is the last to depart.
The two meet each others gazes and as Gabi
walks by happily say their goodbyes without
even having to say a word.
In the present, Jikka sees Sagiri thinking
about the others and tries to cheer her up,
stating that it was fate that brought everyone
together and now all they can do is hope that
whatever path in life they are on, it will
make them happy.
After hearing these words, Sagiri looks up
with a smile as she starts to cry.
Meanwhile, Tōma is revealed to have somehow
found a boat and departed from Kotaku, but
not by himself, dude is mysteriously accompanied
by an unknown person.
After the arrangements were made by Jikka,
Gabimaru who had finally managed to make it
home becomes shocked to see Yui standing atop
some stairs and eagerly runs towards her.
After finally being reunited, the couple set
out on their own path in life.
(so we finally made it huh, our boy is home
with his wife who exists and he didnt have
to merc big G in the process, pure bliss)
Skipping forth in time though, over in British
Hong Kong during the mid-1800s, a young man
sitting in a chair notices that the men he
took down do not look like the locals, to
which he’s informed by his brother that
these men are from England due to the recent
war causing chaos in power.
You know who it is, the BANDIT BROTHERS TOMA
AND CHOBEI BIG CHILLING TOGETHER, Chōbei
hearing this becomes pleased, since he believes
that it is an opportunity for him to take
over the city and declares to the Englishmen
that he now rules the underworld from here
on out..
So as some of you might've guessed the reason
Chōbei is alive, is somewhat similar to Gabi,
but with the added use of the Tensen's special
pot.
His brother stimulated his ovule while keeping
him stored in the urn to help speed up his
regeneration.
One of them men suddenly whips out a gun and
calls Chōbei a freaking baby, which Tōma
translates for him and after learning that
he was insulted, Chōbei transforms into his
breakdown state and merks the dude for insulting
him.
At the same time, in a teahouse in Japan's
Hitoyoshi Domain, Shion gives his opinion
on Nurugai's new appearance, saying she was
too young to wear that, but is told that she
prefers her new look since the other girls
around her dress the same.
Nurugai is then hit on by two men, which she
found flattering, but sees Shion ward them
off with a threat.
Nurugai becomes disappointed but is given
a lecture by Shion about how all men are either
beasts or thieves, then noticing something
on her face begins to clean the dirt off.
The two then decide to head North to find
Nurugai's people and having watched this entire
thing happen a random woman wonders if they
are father and daughter despite not seeing
any resemblances.
Meanwhile, while traveling, Sagiri talks to
Yuzuriha about how Gantetsusai has opened
up a dōjō dedicated towards medicine and
swordsmanship.
In a flash over there and after finishing
up a patient, Gantetsusai is issued a challenge
by a man at the door but yells at him to silence
himself.
Sagiri then reveals that Jikka has taken over
the Yamada clan as the next head and is now
enjoying an easy life just like he wanted.
After being asked by Yuzuriha as to why she
has chosen to travel, Sagiri answers that
it was a good way to help her polish her blade
testing skills but also says that she wanted
to leave home for a while.
Yuzuriha figures that her current journey
is to visit Gabimaru but remembers her past
statement on it being a bad idea to do so.
Sagiri replies that she could not help the
urge for a little reunion.
She then asks her mate why she decided to
accompany her, to which Yuzuriha answers its
because she's her body guard who secretly
loves her.
Looking over at a random woman though, Yuzuriha
then spots Yui outside her house and as soon
as Sagiri see’s her, screams out her name
in surprise.
Standing outside together the three girls
all introduce each other and begin to have
a chat about all of the things that have happened
with them.
Once they all walk inside, Yui offers to wake
Gabimaru up to have him see them which causes
the chicks to be surprised as Gabi probably
didnt sleep at all on the island (apart from
ya know the knockouts).
Sagiri also finds it hard to believe this
but states that he was no longer the same
"Gabimaru" as before.
All of them then roll over to check up on
Gabimaru and after seeing just how out to
it he is, states that they probably cant rouse
him as dudes gone from stray cat to house
cat.
Letting him be then, we skip away from Gabi
for the final time and leave the three woman
to have a fat yarn with each other about everything
that has happened.
Time then fast-forwards several centuries
where Gui Fa is seen ending an online class
while living in human society (funnily this
ended during ovid so the whole online class
thing hits different when you think that for
the last 2 years of this series man was stuck
in doors writing).
Mei then enters the room to tell Gui Fa that
Ju Fa and Tao Fa have sprouted which was a
lot earlier than anticipated.
Walking off together Gui Fa just says that
he hopes they others progress just as well.